all right good morning members of the
ENA committee it is uh 9:02 and I want
to welcome everybody uh here today glad
you all made it we're uh we have a
pretty full slate today of uh we have
eight bills to hear and I do anticipate
doing some uh exec executing some bills
here after lunch won't don't anticipate
doing any this morning but uh it is
possible at any point in time throughout
the day if we get there but my
anticipation is after
lunch okay our first uh bill that we're
going to hear is House
Bill oh that's right sorry I do want to
start with the pledge and I would ask
representative Aaron to lead us
pledge aliance to the flag of the United
States of America to the Republic for it
stands one nation under God indivisible
liberty and justice for
all thank you for the
reminder okay our first bill we're going
to hear is uh House Bill 1168
establishing a committee to study the
New Hampshire law relative to soil
Commissioners conditioners not
Commissioners conditioners and I will
call on representative Bixby from
straford 17 to introduce the bill good
morning thank you um for the record I'm
Peter Bixby representing straford 17
from
Dober and uh the uh I first became aware
of the soil conditioner statute uh a
couple years ago when um a uh company I
order fertilizer from sometimes uh said
they couldn't ship to New Hampshire
anymore because because of uh the
because of the registration fees that
were particularly high in New Hampshire
and uh I looked into it a bit then and
then I didn't uh come up with a good I
didn't come up with a good solution at
that point uh and then I ran into it
again last year when uh at the last
moment uh some
lobbyists uh had uh convinced the Senate
to include a definition of um soil bio
uh see plant bio stimulants into the
soil Health Bill and uh they were
proposing to put it in a place in the
statutes that made no sense and uh
representative Pearl and I decided
figured out that the best place was
somewhere was in the uh the soil
conditioner
statutes and when we were doing that we
realized there were several issues uh um
several problems with the the statute um
so one of them is that the uh the title
of the statute soil conditioner is
actually not defined so uh we have a
statute on something that we have no
definition for what it actually is um
and
uh the another issue is that the
um the definitions don't take into
account requirements of the N uh n
National organic program even though the
state requires uh compliance for anyone
selling products labeled as organic so
uh organic fertilizer the it doesn't
have a definition of what would count as
an organic fertilizer even though uh the
uh laws indicate that uh such things
should be labeled
um and there are other there may be
other deviations from federal fertilizer
regulations or definitions that I was
unable to investigate in on uh at this
point and one of the reason Reas I'd
like a study committee is to to uh do
some further investigation on that uh
the definitions concerning compost and
exactly what counts as fertilizer are
also unclear under some definitions it
would seem that compost would be
considered a fertilizer under others it
would not um and the newly added
definition related to plant biotim
stimulants is somewhat unclear and it's
even less clear how it fits into the
regulatory framework in terms of um
how uh any uh of the standard nutrients
nitrogen potassium uh
phosphorus that happen to be in a plant
bio stimulant would be uh considered
either how where the where the line
between that being fertilizer and that
being uh just part of the plant bio
stimulant uh would be drawn
uh and uh so fertilizers and soil
conditioners clearly impact soil
properties and the scientific
understanding of how soils uh scientific
understanding of soils has grown
substantially since the chap chapter's
last significant revision which was in
the um I believe it was in the late uh
in the 1990s uh
so that's another issue that uh we need
to take a look at you know how does
current science uh affect the way that
uh these statutes are are um are
presented or or uh govern uh
agriculture uh another issue is that uh
is somewhat different from the the
details of definitions is that the
registration fees collected under this
chapter are sent to the general fund as
unrestricted
income and Pen penalties also go to the
general fund there is no indication how
the work of analyzing fertilizer samples
verifying and approving
labels and taking enforcement action
gets paid
for when I was when I think well I think
that sending penalties to the general
fund makes sense because you don't want
to have the appearance that the body
that is uh doing the uh enforcement is
somehow profiting from enforcement
actions however I think that the uh
sending to the registration fees the
general fund is sort sort of like
converting a fee into a disproportionate
tax and I think that's something we need
to look at fairly
closely uh even if it's going been on
going been going on since uh about 1995
1996 I still don't think it's Justified
um so I think we need to take a careful
study of this chapter and make sure that
it continu continues to be aligned with
its purposes and that uh we correct any
outdated or misguided elements
so with that I conclude and I'm happy to
take questions thank you representative
I appreciate this bill I I think it
encompasses a lot of the things that
this committee has looked at and run
into in the past and I appreciate you
putting it in are there any uh questions
for representative
Bixby seeing none I thank you again
apprciate the work you're
doing so that is the only pink card that
I have on this bill is there anyone else
that wishes to speak on hille
1168 seeing none uh hola do we have a
blue sheet on
that all right so we have a blank blue
sheet and the online signin sheet I'm
going to try and remember to read those
into the record as well I've finally
figured out how to access those so that
we can we can see what uh what we're
getting for input online there was also
no comments there all right with uh with
that I'm going to close the hearing on
House Bill 1168 and we will take up the
hearing on House Bill 1547 at
9:30
e
all right welcome back everybody it is
9:30 so we will open the testimony on
House Bill 1547 f Ben setting a maximum
contaminant level fororo chemicals in
the soil I think I got it and uh we'll
call our representative Moren money from
Hillsboro 21 is the prime sponsor
welcome thank you very much Mr chairman
Madame Vice chair my colleagues on the
committee good morning my name for the
record is Moren money I'm a state
representative from the town of marac
that's Hillsboro County District number
21 I'm the prime sponsor and I'm in
favor of passage of this bill
with with amendment number
2022 hyen
0249 H I've provided a copy of my
testimony with the amendment attached to
the clerk I've also emailed it to the
committee uh last night as soon as it
was ready from
OS
please know that Amendment uh
49h must replace the entire bill and I
apologize if there was any confusion
leading up to that point but I emphasize
again the amendment distributed to all
of you must replace the entire original
Bill to provide some background on House
Bill
1547 it came from a brainstorm storming
session meeting uh last summer
consisting of community activists and
legislators from miramac to provide some
background which you may be familiar
with miramac has suffered the worst per
fluorochemical pollution in the state's
history caused by a private
polluter these pollutants have
infiltrated water air and soil
the bill was meant to monitor soil by
placing maximum levels of
contaminants but while in extensive
discussions with the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services the
amendment is far more practical and
reasonable the amendment
0249 is in three
parts the the first part allows the
commissioner of Dees to initiate rules
for soil remediation standards per for
pero chemicals by November 1st
2023 this carefully chosen date is a
prime reason for the amendment replacing
the entire
Bill the United States Geological Survey
the US GS is performing a study in New
Hampshire of its soil due by the fall of
2022 and this study is
critical
critical to setting the soil standards
in New
Hampshire thus the emphasis on the
amendment replacing the bill the bill
rammed
through contaminant maximums and so
forth that cannot be right now because
this critical study is taking place now
and the information needed to determine
the levels of soil contaminants
Etc so in that section of the amendment
we're putting into law that deadline and
also a deadline for the commissioner of
Dees to use that study in order to make
those determinations of the soil
contaminants very critical that this be
a well-thought out
process the second part of amendment 249
H amends the groundwater protection act
rul making section and I've placed the
statute for you there in your email
incidentally it's a link so it'll take
you right to it to add soil and that a
person which also includes companies and
public or private corporations per and
person is defined in another RSA which
I've provided for you here with a link
in your email that goes right to the
language make the person liable for such
contamination they must provide safe
alternative water to an impacted well
owner
again emphasizing that person which is
the first thing I saw which was language
suggested from the AG's office and
thinking what is that is it clearly
defined out to in to include
corporations and entities it turns out
in that statue it is and I can assure
you of
that the third part of the amendment 249
H which is sections 3 through 7
very comprehensive clarifies language
describing certification requirements
for certain hazardous waste
generators that was suggested in order
to avoid confusion that takes place and
maintain consistency when it comes to
the certain hazardous waste that
generators um take
in so those are the three sections
of the amendment intended to replace the
entire content of the original House
Bill
1547 in my
closing and I know um another
representative from miramac is here to
provide
information um Dees is here to provide
information God bless you um in your
emails there should be
uh received from you a couple of letters
and I just want to end with this quote
this is from the SE Co students for
sustainability I met with them last
night they were interested in this bill
a group of uh teenagers and high school
students from around the state who make
up this organization interested in
issues facing the
environment representative rung and I
met with a student very impressive who
asked all the right questions about this
bill and was very
interested a few hours after our call
last night she wrote not one but two
very impressive letters endorsing this
bill and I just want to encl uh close
with this one paragraph because I think
it truly hits her having heard about
this bill and the amendment for the
first time but she truly captured it in
one paragraph
after our call last night and the
paragraph is as follows the
collaboration between the town of
miramac New Hampshire legislators and
the Department of Environmental Services
highlights how all parties impacted were
considered in the crafting of this bill
it is holistic it is evidence-based and
it can help those who have been harmed
in her own words legislative director
for the SEO students for
sustainability uh this amendment was um
worked on for
months as she said all of the parties
relevant were in on it and I would
appreciate your support of the passage
of this amendment and ultimately the
bill uh in an effort to monitor
soil thank you very much Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee for
your service and certainly for your
attention today thank you representative
uh will you take questions yes so I have
one myself actually two first one U
there's an acronym used on line 16 page
one AG gqs do you know what that stands
for it says
a pfas other than those for which the
currently the state currently has an AG
Qs I
do is the
answer if you if you give me I I yes I
do okay it stands for
ambient
groundwater quality standards okay thank
you wasn't quite sure what that meant I
appreciate that so so my other question
for you is so reading and listening to
your testimony it doesn't appear that
the state currently has any rules for
State uh for soil contamination by pfas
is is that accurate that's my
understanding okay thank you
representative era
thank you Mr chair and thank you so much
for your testimony and your bill this
morning and thank you for taking my
question I'm interested to know um with
uh respect to lines 24 to
26 um a requirement that a person who is
liable for or has otherwise caused or
contributed to such contamination
provides safe alternative water to any
impacted well owner so how will it be
determined whether or not a person or
company or Corporation or whatever is
the cause of that contamination
because uh is there is there specific
way to determine that
and is that going to be addressed
somehow with this
legislation thank you for the question
in the instance of miramac for example
um we have a a clear-cut
determination through courts and the
like that we have a private polluter in
town who has contaminated water not only
in our town but surrounding towns due to
Air and so forth uh that I'm sure would
be considered with regards to this
section as to determining a persons for
the sake of this section that has
polluted follow up yep go
ahead okay but for purposes of perhap
perhaps other areas in the state where
maybe it's not as a clear-cut
determination is there a method that is
used by either D or any other agency to
make that determination I mean how is it
proved that uh somebody in particular or
a corporation in particular is the pluer
yeah outside the courts you're saying as
in the case of miramac I I'm going to
let uh Dees take that okay thank you but
I appreciate
that uh representative Bixby yes thank
you for taking my question so um the the
obvious uh source of contamination in
this that that sort of initially drove
this bill is is probably the that
company in in marac but one uh other
place where soil and P contamination
issues sometimes comes up is in uh
places where um where uh biosolids or
sludge um septic sludge has been spread
uh on farms as a essentially is a sort
of like a compost replacement or
equivalent and it turns out later that
those uh that that sludge was
contaminated there was a case in arund
main uh few years a couple years back
where a Dairy Farmer basically lost his
entire operation because it became clear
that there that the uh buge that had
been spread was contaminated uh and that
it became clear it was not clear that uh
that was happening obviously when he was
doing it but uh that was the upshot and
I was wondering if this bill would have
any impact on the uh the S cases where
uh Sledge has been spread and in
contaminates agricultural
Fields thank you for that question I
would answer it
yes considering what you just described
may be uh classified as a person
considering how broad that definition is
great thank
you representative Murray thank you Mr
chair for taking my question and thank
you for taking my question it sounds to
me as if this um is a
self-attestation program a self
attestation program okay um so my
question to you is at what point does an
entity know that they are to
then fill this self-certification
out uh I'm going to leave that to of of
person testifying after me that's very
specific I appreciate the question but
thank you
yeah any further
questions representative
steton thank you for taking my question
um on page
two uh at uh line
four five certified hazardous waste
coordinator
program and following it makes mention
the the term small quantity is removed
but the 220
pounds uh hazardous waste per month
stands
what what happens if they're producing
hazardous waste more than 220 pounds is
there another section of of law that
applies to those not contained
herein excellent question I'm going to
leave that also that is specific uh
beyond my knowledge of these working
statutes sections three through seven in
the bill uh the purpose I can tell you
of those sections though is to make it
consistent with terms that are used uh
when these statutes are being executed
so I'm sure there's an an answer for you
but it would be beyond my expert
thank
you any further
questions representative
con there are forms generated by the
dees um for small quantity generators um
in manufacturing um that may produce
small amounts of hazardous waste how
will this affect
them I too I'm going to leave that that
is a very specific and Technical
question I appreciate it certainly uh
but with the definitions being altered
uh to really the purpose of that section
of the amendment is to make the practice
of these existing statutes more
consistent so I know that these statutes
are being uh exercised all of the time
and uh with regards to that question
related to the exercise of those
specific statutes so I'll leave it to
someone who's more technically
knowledgeable about it but thank you
very good
questions any further
questions seeing none we thank you for
your testimony thank you very much and
if you just give me a moment I'll wipe
down the microphone
certainly
okay next we'll uh call up uh
representative Rosemary rung from
Hillsboro
21 good morning representative welcome
to Ena good morning Mr chairman and
thank you very much um for hearing this
bill and for uh welcoming me to your
committee
um I have written testimony I'm going to
read I didn't hand it out because I was
still editing it but um I do want to
thank representative Mooney for the hard
work she put into this bill and to the
amendment as many of you know marac has
been dealing with past contamination of
our groundwater since at least 2016
that's when it was first
reported and um P asked just to give
some of you a background our class of
chemicals that are termed forever
chemicals
because of their resistance to
degradation their primary mode of
contamination of the environment and
their bio accumulation in humans and
pets begins in
soil pasas deposited on soil from
industrial operations leeches into
groundwater and finds its way into
public and private Wells thus
contaminating the drinking water for
people and animals served by those Wells
this amendment will allow
Dees an opportunity to address
contamination earlier and closer to its
original Source thus reducing the
likelihood that it will reach
groundwater at presently we address the
contamination in groundwater this bill
allows us to back up back up back up to
soil and eventually to the the the point
source of the
contamination another reason I I support
this amendment is by empowering Dees to
require testing of other pasas will
enable New Hampshire to respond to
evolving scientific understanding and
also address the wackamole issue when
manufacturers alter a molecule or
placement of an atom on a molecule to
make it into another
pasas that evades regulation so for
instance if um
PFA is regulated it's it's
not very difficult for a company to
substitute it with another molecule very
similar but different that it's not
under those regulatory
requirements Dees recognizes that the
more we can manage peas as a class of
chemicals bring all of these different
molecules together the more we can
ensure New Hampshire stays on top of
these
substitutions companies may make to
newer generations of molecules because
if you'll see there is a there is a
clause in the amendment that allows Dees
to to test all they can be required to
test all past not just the ones under
regulation so finally the assignment of
liability and responsibility in lines 24
and 26 of the amendment will provide
innocent well owners faster and more
efficient way of getting safe water
outside of engaging in lengthy and exp
expensive legal process the amendment is
good for families the environment and
the state and I urge you to support it
thank you very much and I'm welcome to
answer any questions thank you
representative any excuse me any
questions for representative
rung representative eron thank you Mr
chair thank you representative rung for
your testimony this morning and thank
you for taking my question so I'm
interested to know um
we we know now we have these
contaminated places and Wells and
contaminated soil in marac how are
people dealing with that contamination
now what do they have to do okay thank
you very much for the question um first
let me preface I should also say that I
also serve as chairperson of the HB 737
pasas commission it's h it was
established in law in 2019 to address
the environmental and health
implications of the contamination caused
by Sano Bane performance Plastics um but
the that contamination is not just
restricted to miramac miramac I guess
ground zero but it also includes the
communities of Bedford Lichfield and
recently uh lenary was added to the
commission because of the extent of um
the
plume um when that contamination first
was discovered and brought to the
attention of De s Dees and S gobain
entered into what's called a consent
degree it's a settle a legal settlement
that outlines the responsibility that
SLE Bane has in this
situation um and I'm I'm sure Dees can
can go into this in more detail but what
it requires of Sinco Bain is that within
a certain boundary that's defined in
that consent degree um when water is is
um tested it to be more than the legal
limit s gban has to provide alternate
water so we actually have hundreds and
hundreds of families who have been on
bottled water since
2017 in some cases where um the
neighborhoods have been so impacted and
um the access to infrastructure s gobain
has um paid to have um Municipal
waterline hookups to to neighborhoods so
some people have gotten uh they're now
on Municipal Water they've abandoned
their their private well and now they
they have to pay to be on public water
because it's safer um some people who
aren't in a convenient location for that
are on bottled water and um I also
believe some families have um installed
whole house filtration or at least uh um
usually it's a granulated activated
carbon system where water coming into
the house the pasas is removed before it
Services faucets so um that's that's
really about the only way you can remove
P from water is um by going to an
alternate source that you know is safe
or removing it as it's coming into the
house I hope I answered your question
yes you did thank you and follow up
follow up good so besides water
contamination are there
other contamination going on soil in so
far as you know can these people grow
gardens in their backyard and well I
know for the um Community across the
street from St gobain it's a condominium
Community called Webster green those
people have been instructed not to
Garden don't disrupt the soil um it's
been found in dust on wind on window
sills um but until soil testing becomes
more widespread and the science of of
that analysis becomes well
more well documented I guess um there's
really no way of knowing how much soil
is in someone's yard I mean we've spent
the last several years as a state um
testing just getting getting a handle on
the extensiveness of the groundwater
contamination I mean you asked um
representative Mooney about how we know
who is responsible well many times you
can look at the plume of contamination
by testing and work your way back to the
point source of that contamination we
also know um companies that use these
products in their manufacturing and so
naturally it would make sense that they
may you know just in their waste removal
of their process that you know they they
use so much that it it's likely that
they might be a point source so there is
another company similar to Sano bank
called TCI which is also been found to
be a source also firefighting foam um
not so much anymore but pasas was
commonly used in firefighting foam
that's why we see the contamination at
peas um from their their um use of
firefighting
foam I hope I answered your question yes
thank you very much you're
welcome so it actually generates a
question I was going to say for director
whims app but I'll I'll throw it to you
if you can answer it okay I hope so
we'll see so if we put this into place
what remed remediation practices would
be available what do you envision I mean
are we talking soil removal and
replacement or or are there other types
of remediation practices that are
available well just speaking up about
myself um I I think it really depends on
the concentration I think and and it
also depends on the
soil's um the geometry of it to the
underlying if there's Bedrock or
groundwater there may be some situations
where the soil has to be removed there
may be some situations where there might
be a pump and treat well installed which
would it's a well that it'll pump the
groundwater remove the pasas and put it
back um so I think it really depends on
the concentration and the um the the
soil chemistry that would either
encourage or maybe inhibit that leeching
into groundw some soils May retain the
pasas more than other
soils so I guess guess I didn't answer
your question chairman Pearl no you did
fine I I always am concerned if we're
going to put a practice into rules that
there's at least a practice available to
satisfy that rule so thank you any other
questions see none we thank you for
coming in thank you very much appreciate
it so next we will call up uh director
whims and sorry the second name Bonner
is that correct all right I I'll allow
you to introduce yourself from Dees
thank you
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Mike winsat I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services with me here today is Wendy
boner who is uh the uh rules coordinator
for our hazardous waste management
Bureau and uh she would be here to speak
speak to any of the specific questions
about sections 3 through eight of the
bill uh thank you for the opportunity to
testify uh in support of this amendment
to House Bill
1547 uh Dees supports the amendment and
uh I want to just briefly go through the
three sections and then uh both Wendy
and I will be happy to field any
questions that you might have uh first
of all the first section uh directs uh
Dees to conduct uh to initiate rul
making um by no November of 2023
relative to specifically addressing past
contamination and specific very
specifically to develop and begin uh Ru
making for establishing soil standards
for the four past chemicals that we
currently regulate in groundwater and
those soil standards would need to be
protective of groundwater quality so the
the whole idea of that is that as you've
heard from previous from the sponsor and
representative Rong is that uh when uh
in particular in Southern New Hampshire
when we had uh uh a significant amount
of pasas uh falling being emitted into
the air being deposited onto the ground
getting into and onto the soil that then
percolated the rainwater falls down on
that and then that percolated down leech
down into the groundwater aquifer both
in the overburden and the sand and
gravel aquifer and in the Bedrock
aquifer so we have many hundreds of uh
drinking water wells in the the five
town area that was discussed that have
been impacted by that contamination so
um I do want to make it clear we um
already established soil standards for
many compounds we have that that are
based on the numbers are based on uh a
desire to protect groundwater quality so
we already have authorities to set
standards for soil to protect
groundwater quality um but we have not
done that yet for pasas and one of the
reasons we haven't done it yet is that
Pas chemistry indry is is quite a bit
more complicated than many of the other
uh chemicals that we that we regulate
and we we came uh to the conclusion
several years ago that we could not use
our usual methods we had a certain model
that we used to sort of model how a
contaminant moves through soil and then
gets into the groundwater and it works
pretty well for a lot of chemicals but
it really doesn't work well and it's not
appropriate for pasas so um what we've
done is uh I and I'm I'm jumping ahead a
little bit but uh We've as
representative Mooney indicated we hired
the USGS we have a contract with them to
do a three-part study and the first
thing they've done which is largely done
and we're waiting for the report on it
is to go and look at soil concentrations
for pasas throughout the state the idea
that pasas is a global contaminant it
has been deposited on all pretty much
all parts of the Earth because of its
expansive use in Commerce and we wanted
to understand just in the absence of the
local source of past contamination what
do soils look like in the state so there
were over a 100 soil samples taken
across the state in locations where we
didn't have any particular reason to
believe that there was any local
contamination Source just trying to look
at background soil concentrations so
that's the first part of the USGS study
the second part is to go and then obtain
soil samples from specific sites where
we know we have pasas
contamination and bring and and also
obtain soil samples of different soil
types from around the state that aren't
contaminated by any local source and do
laboratory studies to see how past
chemicals interact with those soils how
fast they move through them whether
they're you know bound to them and
retained by them that helps give us
information about how we would then go
about setting a a leeching standard for
for soil for past and then the third
part of the study is to do some field
studies at some existing past sites we
do have a number of sites where past
have been released um and to go and
actually do some infield studies to see
how p is interacting with the soils at
that site and how it's moving through
those soils to get to groundwater so I I
hope I'm not going too far into that but
I want you to understand the the breadth
of this USGS study so we're waiting for
that we expect to have the report on
those three parts by the fall of 2022 as
represent Mooney indicated and then once
we have that we'll need to use that
information to then do some further
development and modeling to f figure out
what the numbers should be it's very
possible that we will propose through
the normal rulem process so there' be
plenty of opportunity for public
participation in that but it's very
possible that we may propose um
something we haven't done with other
chemicals which is uh soil type based
standards so when you have a site that
has certain kind of soil um it might
have a different standard for past
contamination than another soil type
because the p moves differently or at a
different speed in that type of soil so
that's maybe more than you need to know
for now but that gives you an idea why
we need this time to do do this work
very carefully and then go through the
normal rulem process to establish soil
cleanup standards and as uh
representative rung indicated a second
part of that first section uh will allow
us to do really what's kind of happening
anyways but it'll give us more clear
Authority um and that is to uh look to
parties who examining their sites or
doing monitoring to not just test for
the four compounds but test for an
expanded list of compounds most folks
are already doing that but um the
problem is that there are a handful of
past compounds that are beginning to
emerge as perhaps a concern that we
don't yet regulate and the problem is is
if we if we wait until it's determined
that that's a problem then we have no
data about those compounds where they
exist where they're a problem so looking
ahead at the that the handful of
compounds that we are concerned about
and getting data on that ahead of time
before we look to set some kind of
drinking water standard or soil standard
is going to be very helpful to us I
think it's going to be more protective
of the public as a result so um the
second part of the uh Bill basically uh
amends the groundwater protection act
and and and and does two things there
one it clarifies some existing authority
to establish soil standards as I said we
already have a host of soil standards
for a number of compounds but this just
clarifies it and and makes it clear that
what we should be doing is setting
standards to protect groundwater and to
protect human health so the idea is that
we and we already do this with our soil
standards in some cases we have two
standards one is a is a number that we
determine would be protective of
groundwater quality so a number in the
soil a concentration of the soil where
you wouldn't have an impact above
groundwater standards in the soil and
another one is human health where it's
just direct contact so it might be a
different number if you're just trying
to protect children playing in the soil
because you know kids play in the dirt
and they eat a little bit of the dirt
and they get um an exposure that way and
so the analysis and and the work that
you need to do to set those standards is
different so this just makes it clear
that those two things are appropriate um
criteria that we should be using to set
soil standards and then the second part
of that is uh it's a clarification but
also putting a little finer Point making
more explicit our authority to require
persons who are responsible for um
contamination of of groundwater as a
result of their emissions and this is
not with respect specifically to P but
really to any contaminant um uh or who
you know somehow they're either liable
under the law for what's happened or
they just simply cause the release of a
contaminant that has a groundwater
quality standard so the idea is that if
you um if a person whether it's a
company or an individual uh diso
improperly disposes of a contaminant and
it gets into the groundwater and impacts
an individual person's drinking water
well they have a responsibility to
provide safe alternate water and that
for that person which could be putting
treatment on the well or in some cases
could be connecting them to a public
water system I want to emphasize this is
something that's happened for years Dees
has a site remediation program where we
have
uh required individual parties who have
caused contamination to provide
alternate water um that includes
companies that have had big releases and
impacted people's wells in a
neighborhood it includes municipalities
who have a landfill who's impacted you
know a couple of neighbors next to the
landfill drinking water as a result of
releases from the landfill um in answer
to representative aon's question we have
a long history at Dees of of making
those analyses to figure out you know is
is this something that really happened
did this person really caus the
contamination and uh the way that we do
that is through really traditional um
soil and groundwater investigations so
we have the the party who who if you've
had a documented release you're already
required under the law to do site
investigation put in groundwater
monitoring Wells do soil samples and it
sort of almost becomes a a game of
connect the dots so if you have a l a
you know a site here and a well that's
impacted here and you do the study in
between those two places to look at soil
and groundwater quality can you make a a
reasonable argument that that that yes
that releases what caused that well to
be contaminated in some cases it's very
clear we have parties that you know just
say yep it's us and we'll provide the
alternate water in other cases it may
not be that clear um and it may be very
difficult may be a very complex
hydrogeological setting where it's hard
to tell and certainly if a party feels
like they're being unjustly accused of
causing that problem they have all the
the remedies available to them they can
appeal if if we ask them to do it and
they refuse to do it but we're confident
that it's their responsibility we might
issue them in administrative order they
have the right to appeal that and have
that heard before the council and the
courts or if uh we had if we took them
to court to do it they obviously have
their rights to to to uh to fight that
in in in the legal setting in the court
setting so um that's the second part and
then the the third part is
um uh and I want emphasize that I know
it's confusing reading the amendment
sections 3 through S there the changes
that we are making actually don't change
the responsibilities of the regulated
Community one bit this is not creating
new responsibilities it's not creating
new law or making somebody who wasn't
responsible to do something now
responsible we have a hazardous waste uh
generator certification program that is
limited to um small quantity what we
have up to now called small quantity
generators those folks who generate less
than 220 pounds of hazardous waste per
month and there are 3,000 there there
are over 3,000 of those entities small
businesses in the state that generate
relatively small amounts of hazardous
waste they have a host of requirements
that apply to them but they're not as
significant or robust as the
requirements that apply to larger
generators who generate more waste but
they do have to comply with those as you
can imagine we can't have a fleet of
inspectors that can go out and regularly
inspect 3,000 generators so what we do
is a number of years ago we established
this small quantity generator
self-certification program which we
essentially administer with one or two
people basically um and it's very
efficient and worked very effectively
where every three years if you're one of
these small quantity generators your
responsibility is to basically do a self
audit look at the rules look at what
your requirements are see if the way
that you're managing your waste is in
compliance with those
and fill out a form that that
representative K refer to and that form
would not change um and and basically uh
self-certified that you're in compliance
with the rules um or if you're not let
us know that and and seek whatever help
you need to come into compliance and
then we do some auditing with interns to
try to kind of check that as well or
with our inspectors but it's been a very
successful program none of that changes
this is will be exactly that program
will be run exactly the same way it'll
apply all the same people but what we'll
what we're changing here is that because
when we created that program we put this
term small quantity generator language
in the statute just to be descriptive
because that's what we called it the
problem is if you go back in time um we
have a program for hazardous waste uh
management and regulation that is uh
essentially analog to the federal
program and when the federal law came
down in the n in the mid1 1970s to
establish responsibility for hazard
space Generation Um states were had the
opportunity to develop their own
programs and then seek authorization to
implement the program in Le of the
federal government we did that it's been
a very successful program for for you
know 40 years now um but when we did
that we we we used we chose to use
slightly different terms to describe the
the different sizes of generators and
the letter shows a table there that
compares how the terminology that we use
is not the same as the terminology that
the federal government uses and that's
worked okay we' spent a lot of time
educating generators but we have a
number of businesses as you know who who
work in more than one state they have
facilities in more than one state and
it's created confusion and some
inconsistency in terminology because um
what we call a small quantity generator
um is not the same thing as what the
federal government might call a small
quantity generator in the past so as a
result um if for businesses that work in
more than one State when we start using
our terminology they look at us crossy
and get kind of confused and say that
doesn't make sense you know what what
are you saying and so what we decided is
that without changing our rules or
changing the way we regulate these
parties we want to align our terminology
with the federal government so we
eliminate that confusion make our rules
and our program easier to understand and
more user friendly for the business
Community it's also going to facilitate
as we move forward with uh we're
required as you know EPA has develops
new rules related to hazardous waste all
the time we're required to adopt those
rules on a schedule to maintain the
authorization of our program and the
approval from the federal government of
our program as we do that it'll be much
easier to do that if we're using the
same terminology and that's really what
this is about so again it it's easy to
conclude that it's changing something
but it it really doesn't what it really
does is it scrubs this language about
small quantity or very small quantity
out of the stat statute puts it in rules
where it belongs so if this amendment
were to pass and these Provisions were
to change in the Hazardous way statutes
what we would do along the heels of that
is then go into our rulemaking process
and change this terminology to align it
with the federal terminology and then
we'd have consistent terms being used
between us and the federal government
and I've spoken far too long and I we'll
be happy to answer any
questions thank you director I guess
I'll start with one that I have so
looking at the original Bill there were
concerns expressed in the fiscal note
about the quantities that and
limitations that were set originally in
in the statute yes and looking at the
amendment those have all been taken out
and correct sort of put to the rules
making process and I I guess on line 15
it says such rules may include a
requirement for testing for pfas other
than those for which the state currently
has a groundwater quality standard
standard one of the purviews of our
committee obviously is is agricultural
policy and looking at that and I know
there was some concern expressed in the
original fiscal note about uh its effect
on biosolid
application do you perceive that as you
go through the rul making process that
the standards that you will want to set
will have that same impact on the
application of biosolids our
agricultural Community depends a lot on
those for the production of of many
crops sure that's a great question I'm
glad you asked that um and in fact the
USGS study that we're doing will include
a site where biosolids have been land
applied um to try to understand that
that's been a concern we have you you if
you're involved in that Community you
may know Anthony um uh now I'm
forgetting I've known Anthony for years
Anthony uh is a is a person who does the
biosolids regulation program at Dees
he's been a just a Stead fast Champion
for you know trying to make sure that we
do that in in the most careful and
appropriate way and it's been a very
successful program it's something that
we're looking at carefully we know that
um it seems that what's happened in
Maine was in large part um a result of
paper mill sludges that were part of the
biosolids we don't have as much of a
history of that being part of biosolids
in New Hampshire as they do in Maine um
having said that there are you know
there when biols are mismanaged and we
had a facil faity that actually um was a
processing facility for those materials
that did have impacts on near nearby
drinking water wells with pasas and so
we've had to deal with that specifically
um to address that having said that um
we're not seeing we're still studying it
but we're not seeing similar impacts um
at at biosolid facilities that have just
been utilized in for an Agricultural
purpose um but that's something that I I
guess the best way to answer the
question question is we we're
specifically making that part of the
USGS study because we want to understand
more about that and we and by with the
authorities and the and the directive
that this gives us it would give us an
the ability to
tailor you know specific standards and
practices to the bio solids application
so that that could you know be addressed
in a way that was practical and
hopefully you know would allow for
continued appropriate use of biosolids
thank you I know I know it was a bit of
a complicated question it is indeed yeah
but I I appreciate the answer and we
certainly appreciate your attention to
that matter because it is quite
important to the agricultural community
and I apologize I I got to give Anthony
credit Anthony drwan is fair enough well
I put you on the spot so any other
representative Bix yes thank you for
taking my question um first off I'd like
to thank you for all the work that you
did on this amendment I looked at the
original bill and I thought but this
doesn't have this doesn't really have a
real effect uh and it's not going to be
useful and this amendment completely
changes that and I think this is uh uh
Leaps and Bounds ahead of the original
bill um but my question has to do with
uh the representative Rong mentioned
that uh there are uh chemicals that are
um not the the P chemicals that are not
the ones that are currently have
standards and suggested that the they
those chemical variants might be have
been intentionally made to to vary so
they wouldn't fit under the standards
and I my impression was that uh when
you're dealing with Fass it's it's all a
waste product that is the result of not
your intended chemical operation but uh
sort of the byproduct of uh the thing
you're really trying to make and because
chemical reactions are complicated they
spew out more than just the isolated
things that you're planning to make uh
or that you would initially anticipate
so I'm wondering is there any intention
in the ones that don't fit under the the
the current regulations or is it that
they just haven't been uh assessed yet
and they need to be assessed in order to
see if you know make figure out how they
fit into the the um the standards sure
that's a great question so it needs to
be said there are literally thousands of
pasas compounds um it's certainly it's
it's a complex little bit complex answer
to your question I think the the simple
answer is it's yes both um what you
described is a condition that exists
sometimes but it's also true that very
specific chemistry is designed for
specific uses it is you know as we
understand it um you know if you think
about a pasas compound it's basically a
carbon chain with some kind of
functional group on the end of but all
the carbons are just saturated with
Florine atoms that's it just Florine
atoms in one particular case it appears
that the
industry uh designed a chemical that
would have one um hydrogen one Florine
replaced with hydrogen so that it would
basically not be the regulated chemical
and so that's a concern for us too so we
have to pay attention to these things
they're they're they're complex um it's
also the case that you know for good
reason reason um the industry will
Design when when when a particular
chemical is identified as a health risk
they'll try to design a chemical that
isn't going to be a health risk that
does the same thing chemically that
they're trying to do in Whatever
Manufacturing process and so as those
chemicals be become used more frequently
we're just looking at those in in the
toxicology Community nationally in
globally are looking at those chemicals
to see if those are a concern so what
you have is you have a host of you know
we have the four compounds we regulate
right now and the reason we regulate
them is we have quite a bit of
information that they may pose a health
risk and we we know quite a bit about
their prevalence we know how they were
used in industry and we know that that
we have concerns about their potential
to harm health so we're able to use the
information on that use good science to
set defensible standards in groundwater
and drinking water for those for those
compounds there's a whole host of other
ones where we don't have those
conditions we may not know very much
about where it's used or how it's used
we may not know very much about um where
it exists here in in in the state in in
soil and groundwater and we may not know
much about the toxicology so but but as
you can imagine the the the the
community of toxicologists and
researchers are constantly looking at
this and new information emerges as that
new information emerges a particular
chemical may rise to the top and say
wellow we're a little bit concerned
about this and we're going to do more
work on that we don't have enough
information to really develop a
defensible standard right now but we
know we need to look at it and what I'm
suggesting with with this build just Mak
when we identify those compounds we
might be able to say look we don't have
a standard for this right now but when
you are looking at your soil or your
groundwater for these Ford regulated
contaminants we'd also like you to look
for this one that sounds complicated in
practice it's pretty easy because what's
happening is the um Laboratories who
routinely do this work really they they
have an expand panel already in their so
if you order up a past test you actually
have to order custom to get the four
compounds if you order a standard past
test you'll get a panel depending on
which test you pick you may get a panel
of 17 or 25 or 39 but the idea is is
that this just makes this bill would
just make it clear that it's it's that D
has the authority to ask to look at some
of these additional
compounds thank
you representative a
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question so I'm curious to know how
other states are dealing with this uh
issue and are there more are there
states that are more successful than
others and where does New Hampshire
stand in that Continuum of States well
that's a terrific question there are a
number of states who are dealing with
this I mean basically any state that
doesn't think it has a past problem
hasn't looked because these compounds
are so widely used in Commerce that
there we can guarantee that there is
soil and groundwater contamination of P
pass in every state and Most states that
have done the work have have confirmed
that regionally um the states of Vermont
and New York State have had and New
Jersey have had to deal with this
problem pretty extensively and in fact
the the same sort of saga that started
with us in March of
2016 started one month earlier in
Vermont so I was at a meeting with my
counterpart from Vermont in February of
2016 he took a call during the meeting
and when the problem emerged there in
North Bennington and they had very
significant impacts just like we had as
a result of air emissions of p in North
Bennington a month later we we we dove
into that because we learned that we had
the same situation in marac um so I
guess the the short answer is that uh
New York State Vermont New Jersey have
worked very effectively to do this you
know I'm not sure I'm I'm the right
person ask is I'm probably biased I
think we have done in New Hampshire um
probably more
uh aggressive sampling of groundwater
and soil um than any other state because
we've had to um and I will say our our
neighbors in Vermont are probably a
close second and New York State uh also
has done just tremendous work but it's
uh every state responds to the specific
problems that they're dealing with um I
think we we still have a lot of work to
do I mean we have a number of people at
Dees many people um who work every day
almost all of their work is focused on
Pas because of you know we've never had
anything like this before where we
literally have um you know thousands of
homes in Southern New Hampshire um that
have been impact who drinking water have
been impacted by these contaminants so
it's an outsized response but it's an
outsized problem thank you additional
question if I may followup thank
you uh my my second question is do these
P compounds occur naturally at all no
they are entirely synthetic they were
invented in a chemistry lab uh back in
the early
1940s thank
you so that's actually a good segue to a
question I was going to ask so like with
oil spills and things of that nature
there are microbial things that can
occur that sort of help break these
compounds down and and take care of them
naturally do any of uh any microbial
action or any other type of things we
can do exist for re remediation of these
P components once they're in soil or is
it strictly removable and or you know
some of the other things we talked about
pumping filter and things of that nature
I believe there's some very limited
evidence that microbial action can
impact the degradation of these
compounds but it is very limited and
very slow these are you know one of the
reasons they're so widely used in
Commerce is they're very unique and
they're they're really powerful
chemicals in the sense that they they
have the ability simultaneously to repel
water and repel oils and grease which
almost nothing does it's usually one or
the other right these can do both and
there and it has to be said these are
very important products I mean the the
the Teflon and and the various variants
of pasas um are used in products that
that uh you know make all kinds of
important medicine very you know
possible um you name it I mean they're
they're they're used in so many
different ways because they are very
valuable and useful um and you know one
of the things that Dees has said is that
you know if a heart valve needs Teflon
we want we want them to be able to make
that heart valve but if a hamburger
paper needs it to keep the grease out
maybe that's not the highest and best
use so society's going to have to make
decisions about where they really want
to use these compounds where it's makes
sense and it's important and any risks
are worth you know worth managing in
other places where Maybe they're not and
that's not something we're going to do
here but nationally and globally those
decisions are are you know starting to
be made and you know at some level the
industry is is making those decisions
too they you know if they have a
high-end need to make a product that
can't be made any other way they're
going to do it but if they've got a
product they could do another way and
not take on the risk of using p the
industry and commerce already making
those decisions to eliminate from those
types of
products thank you representative
Murray thank you Mr chairman for taking
my question thank you for taking my
question so one one question that I do
have for the Department is that we have
talked at length about potential
remediation strategies and I think a
previous speaker had mentioned that um
individuals were instructed not to drink
or use their soil in that manner and you
also mentioned an incoming report due in
next year or excuse me October 2022 is
that correct around that time yes yeah
thank you so in which case I guess I'm
wondering is that perhaps when when will
those remediation strategies be
available to folks or what what are the
next steps to getting folks some
Remediation in those
areas thank you for the question so
really that that's a two-part question
the the question on drinking water is
pretty easy it's it's not easy or
inexpensive but it's it's it's it's
known techn technology we can very
effectively treat drinking water with
granulated activated carbon it can also
be you know uh treated under the sink at
a you know just a local point of use
treatment filter for a a kitchen sink
using reverse osmosis so there are
existing tested well-known affordable
Technologies for removing past from from
drinking water so that piece is really
just about resources and time we don't
need necessarily new research to get it
it's not like we're waiting for a
breakthrough on on that we we have
tested Technologies to take care of that
um on the soil side it's be much more
difficult there really um there's some
work going on that looks at treating of
actually sludge and um and soil through
some sophisticated methods that are
still kind of in the research and pilot
phase and they may come um but the
reality is if you look at I like to talk
about in the context of Southern New
Hampshire because the problem is so huge
Southern New Hampshire that even if you
had a costeffective technology for
treating soil it's just the magnitude of
it you know there's just the the what
amounts to millions of tons of soil that
may have detectable concentrations of
pasas we're not going to be looking at a
remedial technology now on in the
aggregate right so basically what we'll
look at is making sure that people have
safe drinking water either through
treatment or a public water system in
Southern New Hampshire so they're not
getting Expos osed and then we're going
to look at soil concentrations to make
sure that locally where they might get
exposed to those soils they're not
getting an exposure that's unsafe in
most cases we've not seen based on what
we understand right now concentrations
in soil in except maybe you know and
very close into the plant site that
would pose a risk to somebody playing in
the soil you know a kid playing in the
soil or something like that so the main
concern is about whether those soils
pose a risk to groundwater and the
reality is in Southern New Hampshire
that will probably be the casee for many
years to come and there won't be a lot
we can do about that other than to make
sure people have sources of clean
drinking water um on an individualized
basis on a site there may well be
technologies that will be available
right now we have other you know sort of
run-of-the-mill contaminants if you will
that aren't past where it's also
impracticable to to treat the soil and
and we we rely on um institutional
controls like putting a cap on the soil
or you know basically eliminating
contact with it elim ating rain water
from falling on it so that it can't
percolate down into the groundwater so
um the short answer is we don't have a
sort of a Magic Bullet for treating soil
and I'm not sure we're going to have one
anytime
soon thank you thank you representative
vix thank you for taking my question so
um I'm wondering if uh there's an issue
with uh the uptake of f past chemicals
by agricultural crops
that's a terrific question it's one
we've been we've been Fielding really
since the first pro the problem was
identified in
2016 um unfortunately the the amount of
research available for that is not large
there has been some research and I think
there's increasing research looking at
uptake by agricultural plants by food
crop plants of P um right now to be
honest I think our knowledge about that
at Dees is still in its infancy um we're
there's more work going on there's work
in other states they're looking at that
and um it it it can be a concern um but
I think that based on everything we've
seen so far the primary route of
exposure that is really the one that is
of concern for humans is the drinking
water and the whole idea is it's a
matter of dose right because you know
most people are getting through cooking
or drinking you know two liters or more
of water a day so that's your primary
exposure you're ingesting that water
it's a direct impact um and the
agricultural piece is obviously um it's
it's it's it's a few steps removed plus
you know people don't eat the very same
thing all day long all three meals so
even if one part of their diet might
actually have a a vegetable or or crop
of some kind that has peast in it
they're probably not getting a very big
dose because you know unless they're you
know always eating the same thing all
the time um so it but but again our
knowledge of that is still pretty
limited and we're we're still looking at
that all right seeing no more questions
oh we do have one in the back
representive Perez for taking my
question my question to you is um I know
that um marac London der Le feel is
those the areas that more concerned
right now but I just wonder if a Dees is
going to be checking other areas with
single Von has uh buildings and um
for example in my area we already have a
superai of soil contamination from
previous company so we already have that
issue and the soil was removed and we
not allowed to drink the water so we
have water coming from another town but
even though we already have the
soil remove and bring new soil into the
area we have a a a problem with um soil
in miler and uh we have to even put
whole filtration system in our houses
because we getting um uh Rush skin rush
and other issues related to either soil
or water I just wonder if you guys
thinking about taking those areas with
sovian and other companies may be
contaminating the water and the
soil yes thank you that that's a
terrific question and and again you know
we manage somewhere on the order of 7 or
800 hazardous way sites in the state
where we have active
investiga director could I get you to
turn your mic back on I I think I hit
you off by mistake they probably wanted
me to stop
but um yeah thank you for the question
we have about 700 uh sites uh that we
manage at the state level 21 superf fund
sites that we managed in in concert with
the federal government and when we
discovered the p pass problem we we
didn't just we were working to be sure
we were working diligently in Southern
New Hampshire to address that but we
realized that it was a Statewide
question so we actually um reviewed what
we knew about our sites we reviewed the
businesses in the state and tried to
identify which ones might be using
processes that would use past chemistry
and we went out and indeed we found a
handful of sites in places other than
Southern New Hampshire where we have P
problems as a result um at the sites
that we already know know about like the
site you're I think you're talking about
we've got ongoing monitoring and what
we've done at all our Superfund sites
and at our state sites has asked folks
who were already doing groundwater
monitoring to include pfast testing in
their groundwater monitoring at least
one time to evaluate that and then if
they don't detect it they might not have
to continue monitoring but if it's
detected then pfast becomes a regular
part of their monitoring program so we
are looking at the sites that are in our
inventory to make sure that P is not an
additional contaminant that we didn't
know about and in some cases it is I
mean for example that you know land you
have 400 closed online landfills in the
state every single one of those
virtually that that we monitor for
groundwater quality we found pasas in
the groundwater and now that's part of
the routine
monitoring well thank you uh to both of
you for coming in and um I appreciate
all the information you've given us uh I
have no more pain cards is there anyone
else that would like like to speak on
this bill before I close the
hearing all right seeing none uh we'll
read the blue sheet we have uh four
signed in on the blue sheet two opposed
two supporting and we had 17 signed in
online in support so with that I will
close the hearing on House Bill
e
okay we are going to open up the hearing
on House Bill
1187 which is relative to milk
pasteurization and I'll call on
representative Allard from marac 21 to
introduce the
bill good morning and
welcome thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh if I look Vaguely
Familiar it's because I have come before
you twice
previously uh with the exact same
language uh the first bill as some of
you may remember uh died as a part of
the Omnibus bills that uh died with
covid uh a couple of years back
now and uh a year later I resubmitted
House Bill 95 live with the same
language uh to uh allow for the uh
production of ice cream as a product as
one of the allowed products of raw milk
production uh House Bill 95 uh went
through this committee
unanimously uh as had its predecessor uh
it went through the house on consent and
it and it's stalled in the Senate and it
uh we had even been been informed that
it would not pass the Senate and so uh
during the open Period uh this fall I
submitted House Bill 1187 again with the
same language uh to move uh uh to move
this process forward and uh at the same
time uh fortunate for me the bill uh
received a uh uh some sort of CPR in the
body across the wall and uh
uh it was
uh rejuvenated by the good work of some
senators and uh if you have seen the
conquered monitor this morning on the
front page uh House Bill 95 uh has
passed the Senate uh it will come back
to us for a small uh amendment that the
senate had put on about labeling but uh
House Bill uh 95 uh for right now is
alive and well which more or less makes
House Bill 1187
Superfluous uh but uh in keeping with a
parliamentary procedure I must introduce
it to you um I perhaps would
uh
until uh House Bill 95 is signed sealed
and delivered I might recommend to you
that you retain 1187 if that is your
good
judgment uh and Beyond that uh I guess I
might suggest that I give it to you and
you could write some Omnibus amendment
to it and do other good things for the
agriculturalists of New Hampshire uh
with it but uh uh as far as uh the
production of raw milk ice cream 1187 uh
as I say is Superfluous now uh on the
assumption that 95 will get signed uh
sometime this
spring and with that I'd be happy to
take your questions Mr
chairman uh thank you
representative so uh we don't have the
ability to retain because we're in the
second year of our of our uh session the
longest I could hold the bill would be
into early March but I'm not sure that
that's going to satisfy House Bill 95
passing through the rest of the
process so I guess um
I guess I'd like a little feedback from
you would you like us to OTP this bill
and or do you are we fairly confident
that the governor is on board and we can
dispose of this bill as through an
itl uh Mr chairman uh with the the long
life of this process uh that we've had
thus far I'm not sure that I would uh I
would have the confidence to bank on
anything so uh
I I would throw myself at the mercy of
the committee and say I think maybe then
we ought to uh OTP this bill and uh uh
and let something happen to it in
future one final question I would have
is the language that you submitted in
1187 does that contain the changes that
the Senate did in House Bill 95 uh no it
does not okay it it is as 995 was
originally if we're going to pass this
bill would it make sense to amend now
I'm assuming that you're okay with the
the changes that were made would it make
sense to amend this bill to match that
of that came out of the Senate it would
indeed okay all right thank you that's
all the questions I have anybody
else seeing none we thank you appreciate
you coming in thank
you next we have uh representative
Woodcock from I'm sorry I can't see who
you're representing but I'll let
you explain
that thank you Mr chairman unfortunately
word processing is much better than my
cursive and printing a Carol County 2
North Conway Eaton chattam uh I have had
the pleasure with representative Val for
the last three years to meet before this
group once again I think the first time
was OTP 20 the second time was OTP 190
and hopefully I disagree with my friend
over here I'd say OTP again uh 209
whatever the collection number is uh
when I came three years ago and it
hasn't changed uh Jim and I started this
or he started and I jumped on we both
had two small goat farms in our
districts with people just trying to get
their their small amount of product to
help with some cash flow in the summer
doing some ice cream out of the front
Farm that's where all this started and
we still have the same two Farms however
they uh listened to Gemini uh which was
an error because they went out and
bought a freezer and one bought a
machine and think well 190 200 terrific
well now they're seeing there with this
equipment as well so we'd really
appreciate it if this time you could uh
continue to support this bill uh and
pass it once again uh forward because
this is this is nothing more that I
could possibly think of that helps
directly the small family farm in New
Hampshire than this bill be happy to
take any questions thank you
representative any questions for
representative
Woodcock seeing none we thank you for
coming in thank you committee appreciate
it uh next up and the final pink card I
have is uh is uh Robert Johnson from the
New Hampshire fire
Bureau good morning thank you Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
Rob Johnson representing the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau as the
federation's policy director and I'm
basically here to Echo what the the
sponsor representative Allard had had uh
testified to and asked I think as most
of you are aware um we've met with the
the sponsor and and uh representative
Aon as a co-sponsor was part of the
discussions Department of Agriculture uh
Department of Health and Human Services
and and others uh couple years ago to so
that we were all on the same page and we
came to you and um so the one suggestion
I would I would make clear that if if we
would support as as I I believe has been
indicated before that you grab the
Senate Amendment and Tack that onto this
bill just to be sure um if you allow me
Mr chair I would like to speak to to the
house bill 95 which is over in the
Senate and just remind you that that
bill has an effective date of 60 days
after passage so we would urge you to uh
act on that as soon as you can when it
come back to you and then urge the
governor to sign it soon because with
that 60 days it would be great to have
the law effective so the farmers can
utilize it for this summer season
starting in June so I would say by the
at the uh latest we hope the governor
would sign up by mid April and I I'll
leave it at that and thank you as always
thank you any questions for Mr
Johnson seeing none we thank you I do
have one uh final pink card that was put
in uh from Colleen Smith from
DHS good morning and
welcome good morning for the record my
name is Colleen Smith I'm the
administrator of the food protection
section within DHHS and yes I um I've
been before this committee on regarding
this bill for a few times also um I just
want to go on the record that the
department feels strongly against the
expansion of raw milk products because
of the increased risk of foodborn
illness while the labeling um
declaration that's in the Senate version
of of hb9 5 is in the right direction
there was a just so you're aware last
January there was a very significant
outbreak um so that's after I had
testified to this to this committee
previously where up to U more than 50
people were sickened across three states
due to raw milk production not raw milk
ice cream but raw milk so it just you
know it certainly brings home that there
are by doing more expansion this is this
is a risky product and we just want to
make sure um that our concerns are are
presented to
you happy to take any questions thank
you very much any
questions for
DHS representative
comto I thank you for taking my question
I was just wondering what states had the
outbreak so it was a New Hampshire based
Farm but because of the proximity to
this Farm to Massachusetts and the main
borders there were also residents from
other states that were sicken from
drinking the milk from this New
Hampshire Farm thank
you yes representative Oregon thank you
very much Mr chair and thank you very
much uh Miss Smith um do you think do
you think there's a uh extenuating do
you think maybe this bill is made less
bad because we're talking not about raw
milk but about uh yogurt and butter and
products which um already naturally have
some bacteria as part of the what I want
say processing but whatever the
culturing process for them well
certainly one of the concerns that we
have is the product ice cream that's
that's being expanded in this bill
because it's a product that is consumed
by young children and older old the
older population and those folks are
more vulnerable to foodborn
illnesses any further
questions seeing none we thank you for
your
testimony anybody else that uh wishes to
speak on this oh representative viby I
have a question to the chair okay um so
uh in term just in terms of the process
of the Senate Bill since it's amended do
we need to is there some sort of
Committee of conference that needs to
happen before it can go to the governor
or uh or how is that uh that difference
reconciled it's my understanding that
will come back to the house and we'll
have the opportunity to aced to the
changes or ask for a committee of
conference okay so so um does that
accession need to be uh made in a full
session of the house uh we would have to
accept the changes and then be voted on
by the Full House to accept the
committee's um agreement to acced to the
changes okay so that needs both a vote
by our committee and a vote by the Full
House too that that is my understanding
yes okay uh is there any way to speed
that or do we just wait for the slow
wheels of government to get it over to
our side I've I've not in my experience
with the house found any way to make it
go any faster or as fast as I would like
to but I will certainly inquire and see
if we can move it along all right thank
you any uh any further testimony on this
bill all right seeing none I have the
blue sheet there is one sign in um in
support and there are 12 online in
support and with that I will close the
uh the hearing on House Bill 11
87 we will take up uh house spill 1412
at 11:00 a.m. which is about 10 minutes
so if anyone needs to use the facilities
or stretch your legs now would be a good
time
they
was
a
aot
[Music]
are
they
hell
for
go
oh
for
okay seeing as it is 11:00 we're going
to open up the hearing on House Bill
1412 relative to gardening homesteading
and organic food production and I will
call on representative Foster from
Hillsboro 5 to introduce the bill
welcome to the
e thank you Mr
chairman for the record I am
representative William Foster um from
Hillsboro 5 which are the towns of New
Boston and Mount Vernon and I'm here to
introduce House Bill 1412 relative to
gardening homesteading and organic food
production the purpose of this uh bill
is to encourage and protect the
sustainable cultivation of Fresh Foods
at all levels of production including on
residential and agricultural properties
for the purpose of personal uh
consumption and non-commercial sharing
additionally it seeks to promote the
development and and sustainability of
USDA organic certified agriculture at
all levels in New Hampshire by lowering
Financial barriers to
certification initially
um this bill came about because of
discussions I was having with voters in
my district um some were concerned that
they had seen in other states where um
the right for individuals to uh produce
their own food on their their property
had been
um ridden over by zoning and so forth
they were concerned about um the
grandfathering of these kind of Clauses
into um you know for them and as far as
I could tell I
I'm I'm a gardener I grew up on a 5 Acre
Farm in New York that was we were just
raising some sheep and some other things
it was very much for our own personal
use
um but I'm not a lawyer so as far as I
could tell by looking through things um
it seemed like the grandfathering was
there but I wanted to be sure so I went
in and talked with some folks and uh
produced this bill I tried very hard to
make sure that it didn't infringe on any
current laws or any potential Le
developing laws except to say that um
the person if someone bought a piece of
property and it had they had the right
to do it that they retained that right
until the property was sold
um so I did that and as I was doing that
um another issue appeared and and some
some some other voters talked to me
about um organic farming and we had been
closing down the state certification
part of it being replaced by private
certifiers their concern was in the ca
cost of um the certification itself and
how it presented uh barriers to smaller
operating um units so as I talked more
with people about that
um and wanting to promote this
Statewide I started looking and saying
well all of the the um steps that you
would take to become organic certified
those are tax deductions as far as I
again as far as I could tell but I
wanted to be make sure that that was the
case but the important thing was the
cost of certification had occurred to me
um if we could do a tax credit uh for
people on that certification um where it
wasn't being paid for because I know
there are some things that get paid for
by the federal government but any part
that wasn't being paid for if we could
um provide a tax credit it would
eliminate the the financial burden and
would encourage people to um look into
and consider organic farming um and so I
I had that written out and uh the uh
office of legislative Services helped me
with where to put it because I had no
idea and hopefully I got it in the right
spot um but I think it's a good idea and
I'm asking for the um committee support
for the
Bill thank you
representative U I guess I'll I'll start
with a question of my own first so
well I understand the intent of the bill
there's as a committee we're always
looking at agricultural policy and we
always certainly try to Pro apply those
opportunities equally across all
spectrums of Agriculture be it you know
organic commercial or or any other type
just curious is there a specific reason
you chose to give tax deduction
specifically to fees that um Organic
certification would do versus uh
commercial AGC culture as well the fees
that they pay okay
the the reason I did it for organic
certified is because that's the issue
that came before me um in reality in
looking at it I think that that there
could be quite significant advantage to
um allowing giving a tax credit allowing
people to
um get
certified um using the tax dollars that
they had you know that they're they're
putting into the state so um it's
basically giving them back the money
that they're they're they're paying into
the state as is in order to help them
develop further markets that they can
take advantage of and increase their
revenues so um I have no problem with um
applying it to pretty much any um
certification that's going to do that
for a business I think it's a good way
to go it's not it's not utilizing uh
um other people's money it's it's
literally giving them back the money
that they're they're putting in so um I
have no problem uh doing it for any of
them this just happened to be the one
that came before me thank you for the
question uh representative viby yes um
I'm a little bit confused about the tax
credit because uh the credit would be
against business profits tax and my
impression is that uh there is a fairly
th fairly High net income threshold for
even beginning to pay for business
profits tax do you know of uh you know
what what size of oper of organic
operation would
be uh liable to um to to end up paying a
business profits tax when the the net
income I
think I'm I'm not I know it used to be
75,000 but I believe it is now 50,000 is
the the minimum that you need to be
netting in order to uh get uh to in
order to actually be liable for business
profits
tax um yeah again I I'm not a lawyer I'm
not a tax lawyer um I I spoke with the
the folks at legislative services and
tried to figure out what you know what
tax would be best to to use um so if if
this is a situation where that is not
going to work I would be uh open to
amending it to a situation that would I
just think that um from a a a standpoint
of
um these regulations presenting barriers
to smaller operations that aren't
presented to larger operations I just
think that by reducing those barriers um
we could uh encourage more people and
encourage the growth of these uh kind of
of um certifications in New Hampshire
and that leads to markets that people
would otherwise not be
um that would not be available for
people so if you're a Dairy Farmer and
um you can get organically certified you
can sell it to a yogurt uh Factory that
is um wanting organic milk to produce
their yogurt so from my perspective if
if that is not the right tax then um
like I said I'm not a tax lawyer so I'm
just trying to get the the concept and
move the concept forward thank you thank
you for the
question uh rep comto thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um having dealt with a lot
of people coming before our committee in
all types of Agriculture and farming um
part of the reason that businesses
choose to go organic is because they can
charge a substantially higher fee um so
um as opposed to someone in traditional
farming um that doesn't have the will or
can't possibly do that due to other
barriers now because they get to charge
a higher fee um their profits are a
little bit on that could be on the
higher side there is a business reason
why people go organic and or do
traditional um I don't see that giving a
tax advantage over someone who can then
profit more from doing something uh
would be uh Fair across the board to all
Farmers I was just wondering your
thoughts on that yeah I I would um I
would think that by reducing the the
barrier for all farmers in other words
the the cost is going to be the same for
anyone trying no matter the size of
their operation it would increase the
the the number of people engaged in
organic farming and because of that it
would increase the amount of organic
produ produce in the in the State and
probably lower the cost I would imagine
of that produce so um
if you know initially what it's going to
do is is you're going to have people
that are still charging a premium on it
and that's fine you're you're all that's
going to do is bring in more business uh
you know that that's going to actually
bring in more revenues so I don't see a
problem there and in the long run I
think that um what it will do is it will
increase the amount of organic food
that's available within our state and
also at at your your your flea Mark not
flea markets but your farmers markets
and things like that if you're organic
certified and you're you're going to a
farmer market to to do your food you're
you're still competing with all the
people that are there so um I don't see
a problem with it but you know I I
understand where you're coming from on
it representative
Duty thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um I'm
not what is the cost of getting
organically certified and is it a
sliding some kind of a a scale so that
if you're a you know if you're a home
Gardener versus five acres versus a th
Acres uh is there a difference in terms
of the
cost well it was my understanding and
the people that I talked to that it was
um somewhere in the neighborhood of
$1,000 and 800 some OD um when it was
being certified by the state and that
that cost went up to um a he it
basically just about doubled when for
doing it um with one of the non-state
certified certifiers that was my
understanding thank you thank you
representative
Oregon thank you very much Mr chair
thank you represent Foster um we're
we're moving in the direction of
legalizing marijuana or as we like to
call it cannabis um do you feel this and
of course uh tobacco is already uh legal
to grow um so you feel like does this
definition um do does this definition
give enough protection for uh home
owners and tenants who want to grow
either of those plants on their property
for their personal use or do you think
maybe might need to be tweaked of course
I'm just a subsid on the committee so
any like work sessions I probably won't
be at but you feel like those give
enough for for growing like those two
plants or other things that people might
might smoke or
not what I smoke thank you very much for
the question
um I really don't and the reason I don't
is in the bill itself um it is very very
clear that nothing in the in the the
subdivision um shall be construed to
um hold on where is
it it basically is saying that it it it
cannot go uh contrary to existing law so
as long as those things aren't uh legal
to do right now you can't do them this
law doesn't change that but thank you
for your question all right thanks thank
you Mr chair end Murray thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um thank you to the prime sponsor for
taking my question as well I am curious
a little bit about the intersection of
gardening homesteading and farm stands
and how the differences in those
regulatory arms if you will are
intersecting with one another on a
larger scale of organic food production
can you
explain in what
circumstances the organic food
production certification process is
necessary is that necessary for a
homestead or a Farm
Stand well it's it's it's really
designed more for the smaller form
operation at least in my my thinking
it's designed more for smaller
operations
um and basically by getting that
certification they can sell their their
organic eggs or their organic milk to
other packagers or other um food
processing places that are looking
specifically for organic for their their
products um and it basically is just
opening up more avenues for those um
Farms to actually sell their products
thank you thank
you representative Duty yes thank you
again for taking my question so if I
read this bill correctly it seems to me
that it's really aimed at
smaller uh let's say smaller gardeners
or or a large scale Gardener but not
necessarily a farm for somebody who
wants to be organically certified to
maybe um uh have a home business and
sell at farmers markets is are those the
kinds of people that came to you and and
requested the spill yes because okay
so and and they're finding out that the
the cost the barriers to entry are too
high for them for their gardening
operation $1,000 for a certification
would be would be too high for what they
could produce is that basically what I'm
hearing that was the feedback I was
getting okay thank you
any further questions for representative
Foster seeing none we thank you sir for
coming in thank
you next we have uh Rob Johnson from New
Hampshire Farm
Bureau good morning
again morning again Mr chair members of
the committee once again for the record
Rob Johnson representing the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau as a federation
policy
director we certainly support the intent
of the sponsor and we certainly support
our right to guard in New Hampshire no
doubt
um I just want to point out to you that
our state's uh Planning and Zoning
statutes relative to the authority of M
municipalities in RSA 674 col 32- C it's
under the agricultural uses of land
section already go we believe above and
beyond what this bill does and of quot
it it's the tilling of soil in the
growing of Harve excuse me I'll start
over again the the the tilling of soil
in the growing and harvesting of crops
and Horticultural Commodities as a
primary or accessory use shall not be
prohibited in any District period that's
been on the books of some time and it's
basically I would say it is our right to
right to Garden uh statue you could say
in many regards Rob what was that irsa
again 67 74 col 32- C 674 col 32- C
thank
you we're all we we're also concerned
and and I'm saying we're we're speaking
in Oppo opposed to the bill though again
we we we we we very much support the
intent of what what the obviously the
representative Foster is a supporter of
Agriculture no doubt
um I wanted to point out in the bill is
drafted I mean it could be
read to say that it weakens current
statute and protections for agriculture
under four proposed uh 432 colum 38
section
4 under a uh AB C and D you know where B
for example exempts uh it says that
nothing in the subdivision should be
construed to exempt any commercial
agricultural operators from existing
local state or federal law what
agriculture we're already exempt from
from many statutes I'll give you an
example is the Shor land protection act
provided agriculture follows best
management practices so it weakens us
right there under SE where it mentions
water use
um the currently municipalities can't
regulate water use I mean there are
reporting requirements that farmers have
above and beyond a certain threshold
they they municipalities right now they
can regulate water use as far as uh uh
watering Lawns is is where they where
they have the authority and then it goes
on next one is fertilizer use there's a
preemption statute on the books that
again protects Farmers for again
providing where they're using bmps and
then in D it gets see appears to allow a
homeowners association to to regulate
which current under current law they
couldn't do so again I I hate to be up
here opposed to a bill when somebody is
supporting agriculture we just pointing
out the uh these items getting to the
second section relative to the the uh
tax exemptions and and and and uh such
um there currently under federal statute
the USD organic program if if is again
the this is from what I heard was
designed to help smaller smaller Growers
the existing USDA program exempts uh you
can call yourself call your product
organic if you've got under $1,500 or
less uh in in gross sales you you still
have to abide by the USD regulations but
you don't have to have go through the
certification
program USDA does provide cost share
funds if somebody would like wants to
convert there's a there's a cost share I
from what I understand it it depends on
exactly what you're doing but adds up to
a good 50% or more of the of the uh the
cost um and as far as the and
representative Bixby alluded to this
earlier the with the the business
profits tax piece there there already
are exemptions on the books that are
it's it's it's in the neighborhood again
that 75 to 100,000 I know there was
legislation last year in the budget that
increased that so again the intent to
help smaller Growers uh we just don't
see that this this would do
that uh there were I try to address a
couple of questions representative
Harrington you asked the question about
marijuana well as the the RSA 21 colum
34- which which defines the agriculture
in the state I believe it's defined as
it it's there mentioned in it legal crop
so if it's not legal in the state it it
wouldn't you know wouldn't uh obviously
wouldn't be covered um and and
representative did you ask a question
about the cost of Organic certification
and uh yes there was a recently the the
the Department of Agriculture uh this
past fall um notified uh Farmers that
they were no longer providing Organic
certification for what they what they
call processors or handlers or and for
um uh uh what was the other one there's
four sections there process handlers
wild and which we didn't have any in
livestock um so they they're not we had
a dozen or so livestock um so they're
they're doing this for crops and those
people and this is what the sponsor may
have heard those people are now required
to find a a uh another certifier and the
Department of Agriculture is the only
certifier in New Hampshire there's
certifiers in in MA in Maine Vermont and
Massachusetts not State entities they're
private agencies that do it and and
there the the the or the organic uh
certification cost in New Hampshire it's
set by Statute and it was number of
years ago when it was set so the cost
are for New Hampshire Growers using the
Department of Agriculture are quite a
bit less than what they are to use uh
certifiers in other states so there
there is that's what I think the sponsor
is saying there is is an increase there
and actually there's a bill that in
that's was introduced in the Senate that
looks to that and I think everybody from
what we're hearing is uh an agreement
that those costs are going to have to go
up if the program is going to continue
uh so I think that's a piece of that and
just lastly I will was also mentioned
about existing Farm operations and
grandfathering and we have a New
Hampshire and a right to farm law that's
been on the book since the mid 80s 1985
I believe that is I seen seen as one of
the stronger ones in the nation it's one
was one of the first and again that
that's RSA uh
432 uh 32 through 35 that's 432 column
32 through 35 and that is known as you
won't see the Words Right to Farm but
that is our right to farm
statue and I'd be happy to try to answer
questions as always thanks for your time
and attention thank you Mr Johnson any
questions from the
committee representative
Aron thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Johnson
and
so the sponsor of the bill mentioned
that the reason why this bill was
thought of was because he saw other
states had various zoning laws and other
laws that were uh coming onto their
statutes that were prohibiting
farming and basically didn't want to
have that happen here and I just want to
confirm that your statement is that we
already have those Protections in place
through RSA 674 colon 32- c as well as a
right to farm bill RSA
432 uh 32
to35 is that correct I just wanted to
verify that that's correct I mean there
are always I should say always there are
occasionally challenges at the municipal
level but we do have we do have uh at
the state level good Protections in in
in New Hampshire what I'm saying is
basically that the the language that's
proposed in this bill weakens our
existing statute that's what it boils
down to okay thank you very
much any further questions for Mr
Johnson seeing none we thank you for
coming in
today that is the last pink card I have
is there any uh further testimony that
anyone would like to give on this bill
seeing there's no one in the audience
I'm going to guess that's
no I will uh read the blue sheet we have
uh one signed in in support on the blue
sheet and online we have 12 in support
and one
opposed with that I will close the
hearing on House Bill
142 we will uh be in recess until 1 pm
when we open up the afternoon agenda and
I do anticipate executing some bills
this afternoon so I would ask that
everybody's is here and ready ready to
go when once we get going thank you
we'll be uh back at
good afternoon everyone being uh one
o'clock or slightly after we will uh
welcome you all back and first thing I
want to do is say thank you to the the
committee for the sympathy card I really
appreciate it
okay we will uh open up House Bill 1517
FN creating a pollinator solar scorecard
and I will ask uh recognized rep hacken
Phillips from Handover to introduce the
bill welcome to Y thank you good
afternoon uh for a matter of
introduction um I am representative Mary
hacken Phillips from Grafton County
District 12 representing hover and lime
which includes the Dartmouth College
residents
thank you for hearing my testimony today
and presenting hb1
1517 I sit before you today as lead
sponsor and on behalf of a constituent a
Dartmouth 22 college student Mr Riley
Gordon we propos this legislation for a
pollinator scorecard which is known as
hb1
1517 as you know poll or as you may know
pollinator collapse is a growing
Phenomenon with a troubling implication
or set of implications for future
Generations the environment and
agriculture here in the state of New
Hampshire pollinators like bees support
our plants which support our animals
that make up our food without
pollinators the natural cycle of life is
endangered and it follows that
pollinator friendly policies will
ultimately benefit our state especially
when implementation is very low
cost Mr Gordon's idea was to Model A New
Hampshire based law
um from other states existing
legislation to create a pollinator
friendly standard promulgated for solar
fields in which owners whether Municipal
residential commercial or otherwise of
these said Fields could voluntarily meet
a set of standards and then claim a
one-time status that the field was
beneficial and pollinator friendly the
idea was that standards could be set
forth for a solar vegetation management
plan where Native PL
could be planted beneath the ground
mounted solar fields to attract
pollinators and serve as foraging
habitats to
birds amongst the pollinator benefits
these plans would help reduce heat
beneath the structures thereby improving
their efficiency and improve the beauty
of the fields for communities as opposed
to a grass field or a soling rock
covering underneath the solar
panels I agreed to help Mr Gordon with
this proposed legislation which is how
this proposal is reached you initially
we had a lot of interest from New
Hampshire sa our pollinators Coalition
but as you can see um from previous
testimony submitted by the Department of
Environmental Services uh last week that
we've had trouble bringing Dees on board
as well as the uh UNH extension
professors with this
idea so there are pre three primary
reasons why I would be cutting this
introduction short today uh with a
recommendation for
itl uh which I will just know I did
previously share with the
committee before so first I spoke with
UNH Professor Amy Papo who has expertise
in this field and she's co-created along
with another retired Professor unh's
Cooperative extensions Master Gardener
program and a pollinator G Gardener
certification program these focus on
much smaller scale Gardens and as I
understand that Professor papan didn't
think this proposal was feasible given
that each Wildflower a native plant
garden tends to be extremely sight
specific um particularly you know what
is in the ground previous to the
cultivation um and that will also
dictate you know success of the the
field
itself she was also saying that it's
very uh difficult to cultivate and
maintain um what is in and underneath
the soil and she has concerns about
scaling up the size of a small backyard
garden to a large solar
field she is obviously cautious about
creating a scorecard with a set of
permanent guidelines because she really
believes that working one-on-one with
certified pollinator experts are
required to have a successful
field um and ultimately she did not
recommend the previous leg uh the
proposed legislation as an immediate
step
forward um second I spoke with um both
Mr peler of the dees and Phil trobridge
of the Land Management Bureau
uh which is the proposed governmental
body that we would propose um be charged
with publishing the ultimate
scorecard as I understand it U Mr trage
had concerns about the Department's lack
of expertise in creating the scorecard
or even evaluating what would go in the
scorecard um and then the long-term
expense in tracking the status of the
scorecard and owner's compliance I
explained that we were simply asking
Dees to public the scorecard after UNH
extension had co-created and endorsed um
our
proposal and that we've identified the
dees for purposes of publishing that
scorecard because it's where we believe
owners of solar Fields needed to go to
get the required permits at the
outset I also explained that this law
would be designed where voluntary
compliance
um and claims of beneficial ownership
status did not require the state to
track the
scorecard um for either their compliance
in the field itself or you know whom is
claiming
it so um the idea is that it'd be very
low cost it's just a simple statutory
permissive compliance and people can
choose to you know cooperate and comply
whether or not they want
to U Mr trobridge believes that the
department of fishing game would be a
better promogator of this scorecard and
um we have yet to coordinate with the
Department of fishing game so I'm not
prepared to offer an amendment at this
time
third neither the Dartmouth student nor
I have expertise to cultivate this
proposed SC scorecard without UNH
extensions advice and guidance so we
were at a loss of what to bring to you
today which we understand is a critical
part of our proposed
legislation um so it's clear um you know
even though there are models existing
elsewhere that we would like to design
one that's more you New Hampshire
specific um and so there's a little more
work to do there as well and I think
fourth um which I did not mention to you
in my previous correspondence that there
is um some language twe tweaking that
needs to be done the original proposal
submitted
to uh the office of legislative Services
was based on a Vermont text and um for
whatever reason an alternative States
text was chosen and proposed here um
which I think it doesn't appear very
permissive and its um
titling so there's some tweaking to do
there as well although we are obviously
we that there is similar legislation
existing in Vermont and feasibility
concerns have been addressed elsewhere
in States across United States we
realized obviously a lot more workers
needed to identify and bring along the
relevant stakehold
holders and to propose you know our
example scorecards there's a lot more
work there to do as well
um this is why we're working to revamp
our proposal in the coming months and
I'd like to resubmit an LSR in the
coming year that
said
um my belief is that we could be more
efficient and productive by bringing
that work offline um and that um
proceeding with an interim study is
probably not the best use of resources
at this time um but of course I will
look to the committee um for its
guidance on how they would like to
proceed and I'm here happy to answer any
questions that you might
have thank you representative so I guess
I'll just make sure that I'm clear is
your request of the committee you wouldd
like us to itl the bill at this
time that was my proposal but I'm happy
to follow your guidance okay just wanted
to make sure I was clear on that thank
you any uh questions for representative
hackin
Phillips representative
Duty yeah I know this bill will probably
be it but my question in reading it is I
don't understand what the goal of
certification
is uh it's simply a PR beneficial status
that we're hoping it will help bring
other folks to the table in recognizing
that pollinator friendly fields are um
available to the state of New Hampshire
um you know for folks here to claim it's
status but to Pro to promote the
beautification of these spaces as well
so not only you know having more
awareness raised by it actually to make
these spaces more beautiful and more
know beneficial to our
society follow sure um I'm on the
nashille Conservation Commission and we
uh had to make we made a favorable
recommendation regarding a solar uh
solar panels that were done in a in a
field near a uh a wetland buffer and one
of our stipulations ations was that they
uh create a pollinator field underneath
that and make it wildlife and pollinator
friendly I'm also part of the pollinator
Pathways organization and we're also the
Conservation Commission is part of the
the I think they call it the Wayside so
I mean there's a number of organizations
in New Hampshire that promote uh
education around building pollinator
Gardens and being pollinator friendly so
why not take an educational approach as
to you know what seems to be just a lot
of steps and a lot of bureaucracy for
something that is basically just
educational in um you know in its intent
uh thank you for the question
representative I have not myself
considered that in the past um but I
will be happy to share those comments
with the Dartmouth student who proposed
this idea and to see if we could
incorporate any of that moving forward
thank
you representative Murray thank you Mr
chair for taking my question and thank
you for bringing this bill forward and
thank you for taking my question um one
thing that I was curious of I understand
what your intent uh and proposal to the
committee is regarding um which
direction you would like to see the bill
but I was curious to know about whether
or not the
plantings that within the proposal are
they New Hampshire native plants or is
the there any sort of delineation around
that that would ensure that what is
being planted in these proposed Gardens
are native and non-invasive or any of
those types of things thank you
representative for the question um yes
to be short the long answer is it was
our intention to coordinate the listings
of what acceptable or eligible native
plants could be included in the actual
scorecard itself and we were looking to
UNH extension um for guidance on what
you know identifying which of those
plants would be most helpful and you
know maintaining its space um and
obviously pollinator friendly
so uh yes obviously that's part of the
work that would have not needed to go
into the scorecard and um know when we
initially met
with uh the UNH uh Professor about you
know our proposed idea we' we'd shown
her a previous scorecard that identifies
native plants in this particular
instance it was Vermont uh so similar
but obviously different
and um we did not get into the
nitty-gritty of the details at that
point because she was um not yet on
board with the general proposal so um
yes that is something for the future to
be worked out thanks thank you for
answering my
question representative Bixby yes thank
thank you for uh for taking my question
um what I'm wondering is why this needs
to be legislation as opposed to uh using
existing avenues like uh Cooperative
Extension which has a very good rep
record for public education and uh and
perhaps other um other organizations
that uh are already working with the um
sort of public education public science
uh citizen science and of things I'm I'm
not sure why this needs to be
legislation thank you for your question
uh and I should say that I think the
best answer I can provide you at this
time is that my understanding is that
small backyard gardens are the focus
currently at UNH extension uh these
sized
um the size of these current
program focuses are much smaller than
what we're proposing um of course
coordinating with other organizations
who are you know for instance like the
Conservation Commission that I've just
learned about um know these solar
fields are much larger and they will
need a different set of focus um and
different you know there's going to be
different management plans for that
scale so I think it's a matter of
working out you know reaching out to
other stakeholders who may already have
more knowledge about this and I think
the educational benefits will come if if
it's something that is promulgated more
widely across the state clearly there
are many stakeholders at the table
already with their fingers in this
project at various scales we need to try
to give them a centralized program or
for instance this permissive legislation
that would you know really extend much
further than the small circular work
that each of those organizations are
doing so that's the intent with our leg
legislation
any further
questions okay seeing none thank you
appreciate your
testimony so uh we have representative
um MC Williams from marac 27 but I guess
I will I will ask all of the remaining
folks who have put in cards where we
have a request from the main sponsor to
itl this bill I is it uh if you want to
wave off testimony let the committee uh
discuss what uh has been offered we
would uh we'll accept that but it's up
to you if you'd like to testify we
certainly have a some time for you to do
that so welcome to the EA and go
ahead thank you chair Pearl uh for the
record my name is representative Rebecca
McWilliams I represent the west side of
conquered and you are currently sitting
in my district so welcome to my area of
conquer um I'm a co-sponsor on this bill
and I think my take is slightly
different than the sponsors take so I
think it's it's worth putting it on the
record um so uh I would say that we have
heard from all kinds of interested
interested parties about this bill and I
think this bill has potential legs um I
think there's something that we could do
here
legislatively um so I would respectfully
disagree slightly on whether this does
or does not need to be legislation I
believe this does need to be legislation
and let me tell you why I think this
needs to be legislation um basically we
have a nent but growing solar industry
in New Hampshire right so more and more
companies are coming in and offering
solar panels and people who own large
tracts of land are seeing the value in
either doing a ground lease or
potentially selling and doing solar it's
happening
slowly if we leave this to the market
what will happen is these developers
will do the cheapest alternative
underneath the panels so on a smaller
scale that may mean gravel or wood
chips on a mid-range scale that might
mean using fossil fuels to mow grass
underneath the panels and on a large
scale that might actually mean removing
the entire top soil from a several Acre
Site and bringing in some other medium
that's easier to maintain so we as the
state have the ability to set some
parameters and rules for what happens in
these large scale solar developments and
in some cases small scale solar
developments but leaving it to the
market means that the cheapest possible
alternative is likely what will happen
and that is not necessar necessarily a
good thing for the environment of New
Hampshire and so as the legislature I
would remind you that we have the
ability to set some parameters and
thresholds for what these developers do
on a solar site when they're developing
in New Hampshire so um obviously uh
representative hacken Phillips has
already talked about our issues with
pollinators in New Hampshire this is
reaching a crisis point we know there's
a problem we have less bees every year I
don't need to tell you guys this you've
heard this your your Ena um but big
picture um I think that there's an
ability to do some studying on this bill
and if it's studied offline that's great
um but I think this bill does need to
come back in some form to talk about
either capping or setting separate
requirements for acreage for solar
developments in New Hampshire and what
that looks like that's best for the New
Hampshire environment um so I do think
that we should take a heavy hand with
this and not just make it an optional
opt-in scorecard program I think we
should have some serious parameters for
the score card and I think we should
make this something that's required
because otherwise we're not going to see
what we want to see for these Open
Spaces that Encompass large swats of
acreage across the state so I'm happy to
take questions thank you representative
any
questions all right seeing none we thank
you for your testimony thank
you next up we have Phil tro
Bridge from New Hampshire Dees
good afternoon welcome to
Ena thank you chairman Pearl and members
of the committee can you hear me okay or
should I okay okay um I I thank you for
the opportunity to testify I'll keep
this brief um we support the
recommendation to itl this bill um the
department had several concerns um and
you know some of which have already been
covered related to duplicating effort
with with UNH Cooperative Extension the
one part that hasn't been mentioned yet
today is that the Department's main role
with these solar sites is in storm water
management on the on those sites and so
we would want to make sure whatever
proposal comes forward is consistent
with that uh I think Native vegetation
pollinator friendly vegetation could be
consistent with that we want to make
sure that it is um when we did a we
don't have a lot of expertise in this
area when we did some preliminary
research um some of the recommendations
were needing to strip down soil and and
put down some plastic barriers which
would increase erosion and that would go
contrary to what we were trying to do
through our permitting of these sites so
there's definitely ways to make these
two things work together I support we
support the goal and the intent uh we
just think it uh needs some further
study thank you thank you you any
questions for Mr tro representative
Bixby yes uh so um in do uh at the ele
school where my kids went uh at UNH did
a project installing rain Gardens to um
slow the the uh runoff of uh rainwater
particularly from the building roof into
a relatively sensitive uh local Brook
and I'm wondering if uh something in
terms of
of uh rainwater management Gardens might
be something that would be workable in
the future as as if someone want was
trying to continue this
legislation yes thank you representer
Bixby um I think the answer is a
qualified yes and it it all depends on
the scale we deal with some of these
solar Farms are 100 acres and so a a
rain Garden would be quickly overwhelmed
um with the amount of runoff from such a
site so we often have to have uh quite
sophisticated storm Water Management
Systems just to handle that to make sure
we're keeping the soil on the site but a
smaller site a rain Garden could work or
a distributed a distributed system of
rain Gardens could work um but it it's
when we are permitting these things
we're getting engineered
plans uh to to C that show how the storm
water is going to be captured and
managed and uh it can be uh fairly
complicated thank you than
you any further questions representative
Mason thank you for taking my question
um thank you for being here today
question I have is pretty simple you
spoke about 100 Acre Parcels being used
for these projects um is there a seed
available that is a native seed for New
Hampshire that people can purchase and
and and plant that with a native seed
crop I don't know of any place that
manufactures that has that
available um thank you representative
Mason uh there is a seed mix that is
supported by New Hampshire fishing game
and it it it may be better to call it
the absence of invasive species seed
than um a a you know purely native
vegetation but when we permit these
facilities we do require the use of the
seaing mix that does not introduce
invasive species thank
you any further questions
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you all right the final
pink card that I have is uh Patrick
Hackley from the division of forest and
lands thank
you well good afternoon and welcome to
Ena uh good afternoon chairman Pearl um
for the record my name is Patrick
Hackley I'm the director for the
division of forest and
lands um I'm going to testify anyway
because we have some suggestions about
uh revised language so we're happy to
work with h the sponsors of the bill uh
if and when this comes back and uh it
does have legs um we're willing to work
like I said to to refine and make the
bill uh more meaningful for the intent
so thank thank you for the opportunity
to testify on HB
1517 creating a pollinator pollinator
solar scorecard the Department of
Natural and cultural resources division
of forest and lands we take no position
on this bill but we wanted to offer
these following
comments so the division of forest and
lands as most of you know is one of the
five divisions under the Department of
Natural and cultural resources and
within that division the natural
heritage Bureau responsibilities include
collecting and analyzing data on the
status location and distri distribution
of native plant species and natural
communities to develop and Implement
measures for the protection conservation
enhancement and management of native New
Hampshire
plants as many of you know again native
plants support a diverse food web due to
a long history of interacting and
evolving with Native Wildlife most
native insects evolve to be Specialists
on native plants therefore we suggest
amending the proposed language in
section 362
f161 uh a to also include other Wildlife
that benefit from native
plantings I I'm I'm GNA offer very
specific amended language changes but I
realize way ahead of the curve here
since it's the sponsor is asked it to be
itl so I've submitted my testimony to
you I don't know that it's productive
right now for me to go through the two
or three amendments we're suggesting but
I did want to let let um the committee
know that the division of forest and
lands natural heritage Bureau is very
willing to work with the sponsor to
refine it one one last point I will say
is there's been a question of expertise
as far as how to advise the sponsors on
how this scorecard can be developed and
I would like to just uh give a plug for
our staff at our division so the natural
heritage Bureau and our colleagues at
the uh non-game and endangered species
program at fish and game department uh
those two agencies would really be a
good source of technical guidance for
the sponsors going
forward thank you for your testimony any
uh any questions of Mr
Hackley seeing none we thank you I might
suggest you give a copy
to representative I emailed it just this
morning perfect awesome thank
you that's all I have for prink cards
anybody else wish to testify on this
bill all right seeing none I'll read the
blue sheet we have two signed in in
favor and we have online signin of 20 in
favor one opposed and one neutral with
that I will close the hearing on HP
it's
so we have a couple of minutes before we
can hear our next bill I'm going to go
into exact session on uh House Bill
1517 and I'll look to representative
Bixby for a
motion turn your mic off
I move we take the sponsor suggestion
and uh move and make this bill
inexpedient to legislate do I have a
second representative Stapleton seconds
do we have any discussion from the
committee on the motion of
itl seeing none I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the
role representative
Aaron okay representative coma yes
representative Arnold yes representative
Stapleton yes represent
hola representative Kennedy yes
represent
Mason representative
Sor representative Bixby
yes representative forgan yes
representative
Schultz
no represent
Duty represent Murray
yes represent Von
plinsky
yes represent klin
yes represent Perez no Mr chair yes
yes I have 14- two 14 motion passes
motion passes 14-2 any objection to
putting it on the consent
calendar seeing none will place it on
consent thank
you are we going to have a Minority
Report will there be a Minority Report
or a majority
of I don't I don't if it's on consent
there can't be a minority okay oh that's
right okay thank
you been a while since I've exec
[Laughter]
one okay and now that it is 1:30 I
will lad is here so I will open up uh
the hear hearing on House Bill 1584 FN
establishing a capital Improvement grant
program for the benefit of state fairs
and agricultural
fairs I see representative lad is here
when he's done his testimony I'm certain
he'll give me a p card yeah sorry I
apologize that's okay thank you rep lad
welcome to Ena well thank you very much
I kind of feel like I'm out of my
baileywick here you know I I I probably
belong downstairs in education um for
the record my name is Rick lad I come
from havil New Hampshire
and that's up on the Connecticut River
just a little south of Littleton and a
little north of Hanover uh I come from a
a a farming Community a community which
is very rural and a community that
really uh looks at agriculture as is a
primary source of income for so many
people whether it be the John Deere
dealership or the hatchland da which is
a large uh dairy in this state or it be
growing apples we we have it all right
there in um in U havil as you do many
other parts of the state here so I'd
like to address 1584 which is
established as a capital Improvement
grant program for benefit of state fairs
and agricultural fairs uh throughout our
state and to start off
with uh the the issue of state fairs in
our in our state uh we've had state
fairs it's been a way of life for going
back to when my my grandfather came here
back in the 1700s a direct grandfather
in haal New Hampshire from haal
Massachusetts and Newberry Port um but
we have been as a past in the state here
and I'm sure the commissioner will be
able to address even a little bit more
that back in
1989 we had funds that came from the
paramutual pools there at Rockingham
which money came annually to state fairs
in our state back in that year it was
$145,500
and it's it's G it's grown to $150,000
then down to $50,000 and stopped in 1979
or thereabouts at around
$275,000 now the the North havil Fair
which I'm very familiar with because
it's just in my own backyard is a fair
which uh attracts folks from all over
New England as does hopkington fair and
some of the others which at times can
attract as many as 70,000 per uh people
during the course of that fair and when
I came across and back to I'd taken the
grandkids over to look at Saratoga and
the battlefields and all that uh came
back through Vermont and when I came to
the visitor center there in Vermont this
is two days before the north faval fair
opened up one of the gals came running
in and said I see your license plates
are from New Hampshire guess where I'm
going I'm going to the north North hail
fair I said guess where I live uh right
there only a little bit I live in havil
there's a whole lot of towns within our
village districts within havil from Pike
to North havil to havil to Woodsville
Etc but any rate we used to get that
funding and I I leave the committee this
I had research do a research on it this
goes back over the years on state fairs
and how the it was done by Anna Bickford
who is a researcher there in in the
office so I'll leave that for for your
records so Madam clerk you won't have to
do any um writing on that
part but there have been some recent uh
research here this is about 10 years old
done by Plymouth State
University um I was just up again
talking with Don Burks who's the
president of Plymouth State last night
at 3 o'clock to 5 o'clock and we talked
a little bit about fairs and how they
feel that that's an integral part of our
our lifestyle up there but back then in
in um they started started in 2002
they've gone all the way through 2011
they said what what is the income that
comes from these state fairs here in the
state of New Hampshire and it's over
$4.6 million annually some from the
state fairs but it's dwindling it's
dropping off and we got to be cognizant
of that and try to address the report
stated agricultural fairs in New
Hampshire generated 97 jobs 27.4 million
in household income and $7.1 million in
state local government receipts this was
this is about 10 years ago when PSU did
these surveys they haven't done it since
but that information was available back
then now we're dealing with a situation
where the life and fairs is really
changing it's changing in terms of the
need for having Capital facilities
buildings and three-phase power and all
that coming in and that's adding costs
you have to have uh many utilities and
and and various services for uh visitors
available and that's required by Dees
and many of the organizations which
assess this in hail our state fair does
generate a sizable honk of dollars and
one thing they try to do up there is
that because they are a nonprofit they
do not um they don't have to pay their
taxes but they do pay property taxes up
there because they're trying to make
sure that the local taxpayers don't get
caught with the bill for for the fair
and um the fair is set up and this bill
that you have before you defines who's
eligible for a capital Improvement Grant
and in order to be eligible to receive
grant money that we are proposing that
$250,000 be contributed to a grant fund
to support Capital Improvements be it
the roof be it the the toilets be it
whatever in in this you had to be member
of the New Hampshire Association Affairs
and
expositions I I don't know the exact
number it's probably around 14 or so
right now and you have to promote
Agriculture and the B and you have to uh
develop uh support economic rule
Economic Development and support the
youth that through 4 and and Future
Farmers of America and you have to have
those types of elements which contribute
to Agriculture and the way of life and I
I believe the fair at at at at North
havil does that of course I I know
there's some maple syrup Growers here
I'm looking at one and uh we do have the
museum and all the paraphernalia goes
with it but we don't have the facility
for it we it's it's sitting outside and
rusting and we do have a maple serup
Museum in fact uh the commissioner and I
went through that this just this year
but we need some help and and all these
fairs need help right now and to
maintain this way of life to maintain
what New Hampshire is there there this
bill tries to do that um in order to be
eligible to receive a grant according to
this bill you got to be a nonprofit
organization Association located in New
Hampshire that is a full member and good
standing with the New Hampshire
Association of Fairs and
expositions after annually hold events
that offer contests or exhibits of 4
members and clubs granges Farm crops
domestic livestock competitions or home
crafts we're seeing that especially in
this last year because of the pandemic
the N uh number of displays did shrink
of course we're also in competition with
some Regional Affairs going on down in
Massachusetts um the the grants that
we're talking about here um are
controlled through the appropriation
which goes the commissioner sitting
behind me
uh commissioner Jasper and there's a
merit system in which the grants can be
handed out and this bill also provides
rule making authority to the
commissioner and the rul making
Authority is what the department shall
adopt Rules pursu to This 541a relative
to procedures for Capital Improvement
Grant applications relative to eligible
New Hampshire fairs and there's a merit
uh rating system that this bill re
quests that be implemented uh it
accounts for such factors as the area
the population the fairest serving the
youth per participation attendance your
gate receipts number of type of exhib
exhibit exhibits Community Support
evidence of successful achievement of
desired outcomes and purposes of the
fair uh extent of improvements made to
the grounds and pH facilities from year
to year just backing off a little bit
the school building Aid here in
education we do not award any grants to
schools that have not demonstrated that
they maintained their buildings in a way
that they should be maintained for the
last 20 years we also make sure that
there's an effort to uh from the
community to support the the grant that
they're receiving the same should occur
here there has to be an effort to
maintain and not let things just go go
to
heck um the overall condition and
appearance of the grounds and Facilities
is also looked at which is is really
important
um grants are on a competitive basis uh
the department shall develop and manage
appropriate contracts with the selected
uh applicants monitor pro project
expenditures and grantee performance and
so there's a process that's outlaid in
the bill here on the health or safety C
uh uh or C safety Capital Improvements
and contract
requirements so I won't take much more
time on this we see it as as uh vital uh
and a good way to vital for Community
growth vital for agriculture in our
state and a way to maintain and continue
what we have in the state I've worked
with the fair Association they're very
supportive of this of course they would
be but they are but and I've also Lo
worked with the 4 and and those that are
in FFA up in our our NEC Woods um in
havil and I I believe that this is uh
not a great deal of money we're talking
about here a capital Improvement fund of
$250,000 of which grants that go out 5%
would be remaining for the commissioner
use in administrative purposes um the
remainder would go to the you know
districts as on a merit basis based upon
how the commission decides they should
go there's a lot a latitude in this bill
for the commission of Agriculture and
marketing so in conclusion I would like
to you know just uh maybe hand the Baton
off to others that are more
knowledgeable about agriculture I'm not
I I plant my own garden every year but
that's about the extent of it nothing
comes out of the ground I
have uh you know a lot of weeds so and I
do go out there periodically every every
so often to try and Chase the dog and
various animals out of it but doesn't
never work so thank you very much for
the opportunity it's always a pleasure
to come to agriculture it's uh I'm
surprised you don't have some food for
us here
thank you representative first we can
get you an educational course in
farming only one question that I have is
there is there language in here that
caps an individual project as to the
portion of that
$250,000 I I didn't see it but it may be
there I I can't you know quite
truthfully I haven't looked at it since
I put this together with the farming
Folks up there uh I can't recall
um
uh contributed contribute matching funds
and are kind there's a yeah there's a
requirement that they also match some
money 15% but I don't recall seeing what
you're addressing this it's something
that you know I don't think people would
be objecting to I I I do believe if you
talk to Sean Jasper about that U there
may have been a provision when that's
been done in the past sure I I'll save
that question for the Commissioners as
well any other questions for
representative lab we'll start around
repes com
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my
question um just to you're asking for
$250,000 out of the general fund um we
have just instituted historic uh horse
racing and chable gaming in the state in
the last few years why are we not
tapping into uh those funds as opposed
to adding additional funds from in from
the general I in response to that when I
when we put this together we re
recognized $250,000 is about what we
wanted to start we didn't want to shoot
for the
moon I was really relying upon Ways and
Means to figure out where how this money
would be appropriated and and and I I
think that's where I still am on that I
didn't get into whether we're going to
deal with horse racing or some other way
of doing this which is you know
Rockingham is just not not a source
anymore and you know I know I've had a
number of bills just Rec recently with
15 early bills and a lot of them are all
asking for more money and there again
we'll send it on to nor major and let
him figure it
out uh representative Murray thank you
Mr chair for taking my question and
thank you to the sponsor for bringing
the bill forward I do have a question
sort of in line with representative cona
and maybe um you can answer is the
capital Improvement grant program where
the monies will be deposited non-aps so
that this could be in years forward used
it yes it is and that that's the intent
of this bill that the money you
know if you're re if you receive a grant
that has to be expended within a
two-year time frame that's that's I
believe in the bill as far as yes the
money's non-aps it's just like our our
fund which we have for infrastructure
money for
schools thank you
representative
hola yes thank you for taking my
question uh you if I heard you correctly
you had mentioned that there was a grant
program prior or there were money monies
prior and I was just wondering if you
know the time frame of when those were
and what kind of financials were
involved with that and and why that
stopped when that stopped I believe was
1979 but in
1979 I was living in Alaska so I can't
really get give you that uh the
historian amongst us right now is your
commissioner standing by you know his
family comes believe it or not we're
related and and uh I'm very proud of
that uh and uh but the paramutual I I I
gave you that that information and which
I'll leave it with you that was which
was done by research and that goes
through how those monies from rocking
ham have been used during the short
period of time that that
existed can I follow on uh yes sir thank
you for the follow on question to follow
on to that if if those monies were if
the fairs have existed since
1979 without additional funding um
besides the is it just the
infrastructure is dated 1979 and now it
needs to get
replaced what's the justification for
you know 50 years later to to now start
that program back up I I think we're
getting the point where the fairs have
tried based upon revenues that come in
from gate that a a fair cannot survive
just alone on those four or five days
when the fair is open at their for their
big Fair a lot of the grounds are used
like in north haval right now if you
were to go up there and look at all the
facilities we have cars which being put
in them while people are in Florida we
have storage in them we're making money
that way there's there's various uh
travel groups that come and setup shop
there um so that that type of Revenue
has always the the revenue that comes in
from other than during fairgate and what
you have to pay out to exhibitors and
what you get from
that that is not enough to sustain the
North havil Fair alone we have to have
sources coming in from the other months
and we're working very diligently to try
and find ways to do that now what's
happening is that with the cost of
maintaining we have put new roofs on the
buildings new sighting on the buildings
um and we're trying to keep up however
the the washrooms for example the
bathrooms they need some work and we're
at the point now that there there just
isn't the money there and it's a way of
life that's going to slide from us very
quickly fairs are really part of this
state and I'd like to see that history
continue and with the the funds which
would come from a grant and with the
local having to put in 15% or so in kind
maybe maybe it's through Labor or
through something such as that I think
we'll be able to really um address some
of those issues for example bringing
three-phase power into the North havil
Fair has been extremely extremely costly
we didn't have to have that in the
operation of the fair you know 20 30
years ago but now we do with all the
campers that come in and and and Park so
those are the type of what this time is
asking us this year and the recent years
have required us to do to stay in
business so I hope I answered it
somewhat uh you did okay you did if I
could check have one more one more one
um you said there's a cost share of 15%
for the community yes is there a reason
why that cost is is so modest because I
know you know when you're talking
certain federal grants it's usually a 2
575 is there a reason why that 15 well
in looking at $250,000 and splitting
that up
amongst all the state fairs are those
that are prioritized by the
commissioner's office um when you look
at 15% 15% in terms of North haal Fair
Association is a lot of money uh this is
why I'm coming forward with the request
for there be a capital pool available
for us to help out with some of that
right now
um the hail continues to pay the taxes
on the property too fair not the town's
people so we're not pushing that burden
off I guess they could try to do that
and get a tax exemption from the select
board as some fairs may do however it's
it's uh something that you're just
somebody's going to have to pay for all
that and and it's the feeling of the
people up there that they'd rather do it
and the 15% they can get that that could
be you know that could be modified it's
not necess putting up 15 thou 15% in
cash it could be in kind I know that
when we got a grant from the federal
government to fix the covered bridge
going across the Connecticut River up
there we matched that through bringing
in time and effort from our town so that
was already budgeted for the in our town
manager in some of the equipment we use
so it was inine type contribution the
county does that as well you're welcome
representative Murray thank you for
taking my question um thank you again
for taking another question so with
regard to the in-kind matching I'm aware
that that does exist as you mentioned
but I was curious to know I think it is
enumerated on line 23 of page two um for
your purposes who is monitoring the
value of those inine Services is that
enumerated in rules or like how would
that that would be that's right we I we
didn't get down into the weeds as far as
getting there however we did give stat
Authority for to not stat rulemaking
authority to the commissioner so when
the application comes in how
accountability how to say that that is
an in kind that we're going to accept or
not accept that would be up to uh
Agriculture and marketing to make that
you know and go to Jael car and and sell
their product okay thank you very much
you're welcome representative
Schultz thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my call sorry
to be behind you a bit here um I love
state fairs I've been to the Iowan and
saw the butter cow I grew up in Kentucky
huge fair but I've always been a little
confused because there technically isn't
a New Hampshire state fair by deao I
guess it's the hopkington state fair oh
it's north Harville Fair okay well that
gets to my point aren't I and I'm mean
no offense but I had never heard of the
haal fair to say that all of the these
Regional fairs are de facto state
fairs um I'm not sure everyone would
agree with that and wouldn't it make
more sense for regional fairs to be run
by say the County cooperative or the
local towns and
communities I I I just on that question
right there I I'll default to the
commissioner but uh the
Grafton County for example is the only
County left that is uh State Farm or
County Farm an active County Farm which
has produce which we use to provide
produce for the nursing home we use it
you know for people in need within the
community and it's also helps uh uh
substi some of the costs at the
corrections facility by providing food
there as well um so the county up there
is very involved with
Agriculture and um I there is the state
fair Association and and I guess that's
the closest thing we can get to as a
state type operation even though that's
not it's a
nonprofit um I as far as getting into
the mechanisms and the governance and
all that I think it's wise to put that
forward to the commissioner and find out
a little bit about where we've been in
the history why we don't have a state
fair um North ail fair I'm surprised you
haven't heard of it it's uh a wonderful
Fair uh it really is it's it's got all
the rides it's got all the you know
activity for young kids even if you like
bumping cars apart and all that but it
also has the oxen and the horses and the
sheep and and and and we we give Awards
there's in a commissioner's award as you
know in other fairs the commissioner
also gives award out to the best exhibit
in terms of Agriculture and that's done
in havil as well um it's the big deal at
the end of July every year up that way
right up to North and down to Hanover
and farther
south thank you representative uh
representative
Perez thank you for uhu giving me the
opportunity to ask this question and
thank you for taking my question my
question to you this build sounds
amazing but um we not Tak in
consideration festivals and uh all homes
um yeah and and I just wonder um if
that's the intention to add them or just
U talking about uh
fairs so I I didn't quite get the
question could you say it again please
maybe it's because I'm on the other side
that's do hangy here yes my question is
because the bill sounds really
interesting and and and good but we're
not including festivals for example uh
in my my my area we have the Pumpkin
Festival which is a big deal and and
it's other festivals in keen and
festivals in other areas and then we
have the old home days in in certain
areas in in New Hampshire and I just
wonder uh these
Bill uh intentionally not putting those
into consideration as well well we have
the old home days over in Warren that's
just on the other side of moose loock
from us and it's part of the region we
do have the pumpkin farm up there that's
Grafton County and we bring all the kids
out of school and they all go down there
from the grade school and pick their
pumpkins every year um there's a lot of
associated activities that go along with
the fair up there the fair is an
integral part of the culture and the way
of life up that
way any other questions uh excuse me
representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so as I I
understand it um these all these fairs
throughout the state are local
supported and so would would this bill
enable the state to participate in a
more active manner to come under the
umbrella of
sponsorship and thereby kind of make it
more of a state recognized uh operation
activity uh tradition I think it's
important that the state be involved
with these these fairs um it is New
Hampshire where jobs it's a lot of job
it's a lot of money that comes from
these um the state involvement is good
as long as the state doesn't try to
start telling them how to do it um I'm
I'm a local control guy um so but I I I
think that in terms of supporting some
of the organizations like our youth
organizations the 4ers and the FFA
that's an educ ation and and what we're
trying to do up there right now is that
we are trying to develop more
educational opportunity through our
fairs for the schools and we're tying in
the just like you have the Agriculture
and the schools um committee which is a
group that is not made up of legislators
or senators or Representatives made up
of various associations in a state ver
that are vested in
agriculture and we have that bill in
front of us um this year so I I think
that for the state to be involved that's
important um we look at recreation in
our state which is powerful agriculture
is especially some of the uh smaller
Farms the the innovative ways they're
getting involved with by local we've had
several bills today just we've dealt in
downstairs which have dealt with uh food
in our schools meals in our school
lunches etc represent Oregon is aware of
that
and and um we are looking at trying to
figure out ways that the produce and
growing of of crops locally can be used
within our schools like using that milk
that comes out of hatchin dairy and
rather than taking it from a large Co-op
that takes it out to New York State and
does it all out there and then ships it
back let's give the guys a little break
here in our own
State it's it's going to be good for our
economic future and just for Main
maintaining our rural sense of
life thank you any other
questions seeing none we appreciate your
and we'll look to commissioner Jasper to
perhaps shed a little more light on some
of these
topics I have some materials here should
I just give them to the clerk so them in
the record so they won't have to
okay commissioner Jasper you are
representing the department of
a all right commissioner you have the
floor welcome to Ena thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee it's
always a pleasure to be here this is one
of the Committees that I always wanted
to be on but never got assigned to
so um
so I am here in in full support of this
this bill and I appreciate the fact that
uh representative lad uh sponsored this
and I appreciate the other sponsors as
well uh I did work with him on this bill
to some degree I was also approached by
the Association of Fairs last year
asking how we could could help I try to
get to every Fair every year can't
always make
everyone um so I'm well aware of their
their needs and their struggles I
generally meet with u members of their
board board of directors when I'm there
and the the uh the managers of the fairs
you heard about how much um activity
there is monetarily the fairs bring in
unfortunately not a lot of that money
actually goes to the fair associations
they go to the vendors and the people
who pay a relatively modest fee to to be
there a relatively modest gate
attendance there's that issue issue of
when do you go up too much and and
people stay
away I I want to first before I forget
talk about the issue that question that
was asked about festivals in Old home
days I am not aware of any of them that
have Capital needs those generally just
set up um on a field or within
city-owned land or something for a
period of time they go away there's no
footprint this is for the capital needs
and and so the history and
representative lad covered it pretty
well my my distant cousin um covered it
pretty well but it it it was an
interesting story because when uh
Rockingham asked to have Races they had
to pay paramutual to the state and then
they wanted to expand the number of
racing days and there was a state
senator it was he was the deciding vote
essentially in the Senate
and so he came up with the scheme to
allow them to
expand that got a took a quarter of
one% of their uh premiums essentially
and put them to the state
fairs for um paying premiums to the to
the people who came in and exhibited um
showed animals and and whatnot so
anything that the fairs paid out in
monetary prizes most of that money came
from Rockingham Park and so that number
that number grew over the years and
eventually Rockingham went into into
Decline and the the num the money went
away that was really how we lost the uh
the Plymouth State Fair is they had not
really they didn't see it coming and
they didn't adapt and then suddenly the
money from the state went away and they
didn't have um the ability to pay the
premiums that they had been most of the
fairs were able to um pivot a bit and
and change their model um we've lost a
couple of fairs since those those days I
think the number is at 11 right now um
stratum just will probably not be coming
back number of factors with that and
there was another one that tried to
start up an eeping that is also um
closed down so
the issue of of capital investment is is
really very important particularly if
you were to go to um a fair like rooch
Rochester um which has been on the brink
for years they've got some big old
buildings they've got some benefactors
who help but their agricultural
buildings are primarily gone they very
much want to get back into that business
and start attracting more people there
they simply don't have the wherewith
with all I can tell you that in in many
cases now the fire departments are
putting a very heavy burden on the on
the fairs uh in terms of fire safety
where before it was okay you know it's
50 feet to a door people are going to
get out there's never been an accident
but now oh you have to have this
particular system that may cost you you
know 100 or 200,000 to put in in some of
these these cases so there's a lot of a
lot of issues there there are aging U
buildings and well what did they do over
the last you know 50 years well I I'll
tell you you know I'm a member of the
Hudson Historical Society I was the
first and I think I'm still the only
Junior member that the Historical
Society has ever had I still sit on the
board of directors and I'm still one of
the youngest members who participating
in historical society a and that is
pretty much true of all the
organizations that I belong
to there are very few organizations that
have the younger members who now have
the Physical Agility and the energy to
say well I'm going to go roof that
building myself you know and that's what
used to happen 50 years ago it was
pretty easy to get a group of of people
who were young enough and agile enough
to do that maintenance now you're in
many cases looking at the same people
who've been running those fairs for for
30 40 years you know obviously
deerfield's one that we're pretty much
all familiar with how long has Junior
Gardner been doing those
ads you know it's still Junior Gardner
out there I think I was in my teens the
first time I heard Junior Gardner doing
those ads and I think that pretty much
tells you the story of of what's going
on um with with everything in in the
state um and so they do need need the
help they are very very important to New
Hampshire you asked a question Mr
chairman about limit and I don't think
there should be because when you look at
$250,000 it's not a lot of money for
some of these um projects and if we were
to say well you can only get you know
25,000 we'd probably see more buildings
being torn down because they just
couldn't could couldn't get there there
are um occasions um where Cornish just
put in a beautiful livestock Pavilion
you know they worked very hard and got a
lot of local businesses to to help and
that's great and that's what we would
certainly encourage but then I look
around at the fairs and see those those
that can't and see the things that need
to be done and if we have facilities
that aren't up to par people are going
to start to go elsewhere they're going
to say okay look at how Vermont's fairs
are are supported and they do support
them look at Maine you know and people
are going to start to drift away and the
Situation's going to get get much worse
in New Hampshire I you know as as to
your question of the general fund I
don't know where the the money from the
historic racing or anything else is
going uh I think that representative lad
hit on that that's a decision for ways
and means to me it's all one pocket of
money really because you take it from
one place it's not available you know in
another so but um I I Look to Ways and
Means where I'm sure this would go or
Finance to decide um if if the general
fund is the appropriate place I
certainly hope we do support this um and
it is different than what was done
because before it was the prize money
and and I will tell you the prize in
money needs to be increased to the
people who are are showing animals
because it's more and more expensive for
them this will take some of the pressure
off but it will guarantee that we get
something in return because it will
improve the facilities directly instead
of just giving the money there it will
allow for an adjust adjustment and I I
think there are fairs that may apply and
wouldn't get any money because they're
doing very well and others that um would
get more because of the difficulties uh
they've had every every fair is
different
as to why they're called state fairs you
got me on that that's just the
traditional uh name we call them state
fairs hopkington just put that in its
name it's got nothing to do with its
relationship with the state they've all
been considered I think state fairs
because they occur within the state of
New
Hampshire uh but if we ever had a a
state sponsored fair I'm actually not
aware of it but so I think that's a
distinction without a without a
difference and you if you look into the
actual definition although the title is
state fairs Capital Improvements act the
ne definition of a fair has nothing to
do with State Fair so I don't think
there's anything that requires to be
changed because that's just the title of
the chapter that um was was put in place
by legislative services so I'll be glad
to try to answer any question that I can
and if I miss some that were
um um asked and I've forgotten that's I
just turned 63 on Sunday so it's just
old
age well yes happy birthday so just for
the benefit of the committee this is an
early bill I don't know what it second
committee assignment is but my
assumption it would be either Finance or
Ways and
Means uh representative
Kennedy thank you for taking my question
and thank you for being here as being an
exhibitor over the past 20 years years I
have seen the decline of a lot of these
fairs um and I have also been the
culprit of going elsewhere because prize
money for the animals that we put a lot
of money into has uh not been what it
once was you mentioned how Rockingham
paid in was that a part of the original
fund that ended up disappearing or what
happened to the original fund that was
part of all it was an annual
appropriation as I said it was a is a
quarter of 1% of what they paid to the
state so as the revenues declin and then
Rockingham eventually closed I'm not
sure if it if the legislature changed it
after 79 or or not because I the fair
the uh racing occurred there for many
years afterward so I I didn't look at
the history of that but it obviously um
went away at some point and rather the
legislature just said oh wait a minute
they're getting too much money as
representative lad said they were
getting
275,000 all went towards premiums at
that point in the legislature might have
might have said well that's a lot of
money but it started out by by the time
they went to night racing which is when
the monies really went up um yeah that
150 was a lot of money in the 40s and I
think it was the very early 40s or the
late 30s when the whole scheme started I
did write a market bullettin column
about that couple of years ago and I
should have brought that with me but I
forgot
any other question representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my
question property and liability
insurance is a big load on many
businesses and Enterprises and private
and even charitable organizations and
it's climbing what extent does Property
and Casualty have on the fairs that
you're talking about I I don't have any
um firsthand knowledge of the premiums
they're paying but I thank you
representative because that was
something I did intend to mention was
that in fact you know the liability
insurance is definitely climbed I know
you know in my business and in anything
I'm involved with it's a big ex expense
and particularly when you're dealing now
with with animals and even though I'm
sure the all the uh companies that run
the midways are insured you can't escape
that liability if it's on your your
property so I'm sure they have to have
coverage for that but but all of those
things add up and this is the problem
they're all adding they're all adding up
and they're adding up on an aging um
group of people and that was one of the
factors in stratom they were all aging
out the town did some things that hurt
and it just there wasn't the wherewithal
to continue and I really we worry that
when we look at some of some of the the
buildings on some of these fairs if we
don't provide some help these people are
going to become overwhelmed and just
throw in the towel and they're there are
too few people coming up along I mean I
worry about that in everything that we
do in in agriculture and the other thing
I meant to me mention is that these
these fairs are really no different than
farming they're dependent on the
weather and when the weather is bad
their revenues go down and and they have
expenses that continue throughout the
year and so if they have a bad year
because it rained consecutively on the
weekends on the gate attendance was down
where's the money going to come from
it's going to come from building
maintenance facility maintenance and it
just continues a cycle I'm not surprised
there's not a lot of people here today
because I'm having a hard time keeping
up with the schedule of the bills that
I'm um trying to keep track of I'm sure
many of the fair associations weren't
aware of them and frankly they're all
volunteers um so please don't take the
fact that there aren't throngs of people
here from the fairs that uh don't take
that to mean that um that they don't
care they do they met with me they asked
for help and and probably if anything
and I I'll put a little blame on my my
cousin and take some myself that we
probably didn't do the Outreach that we
should have because he's busy running a
a a department I'm a running a committee
and I'm busy running a department and
and things are things are crazy I just
don't think they knew that this hearing
was taking place today represent
commissioner thank you Mr chairman for
taking my question thank you to the
commissioner sorry I am thank you for
taking my question I wonder um and this
is just I I'm curious to know what your
thoughts are on the balance that might
result um that would could or should be
with regard to what port portion goes to
building maintenance code compliance all
of these other types of things alongside
of the things that you mentioned like
prize funding Etc well I I a capital
expense is going to be a thing like a
fire alarm not a premium Capital could
be repaving a section of Ro roadway um
building a new building potentially
repairing what they have but it would
all be related to the agricultural
portion of the fair so not to to some of
the other the exhibitor buildings that
that may be showing some of the other
things what my focus would be on is
making sure that the components relating
to agriculture were improved but they
would have to be something that had a I
think the bill says a life of at least
20 years follow up if I may sure one
thank you um so to that end then so it
is you would take this on a per
applicant basis for the request correct
thank you and that's in if I may that's
why I think it's important that it be a
revolving fund because there may be
years when it's going to be important to
let that fund build up knowing that
there are things coming up that may
total more than that and some years well
there's nothing that that's critical but
you can see into the future that there
are going to be be things
250,000 in buildings don't doesn't go
very far but it's going to be a huge
help
repola yes thank you thank you thank you
sir for taking my question um you had
mentioned sort of the the Aging
committees that are running these um if
I understand this
correctly um as I know that this goes
towards the Capital Improvements is
there a concern that even if this money
is allocated that on the on the regional
and town end they may not have the
manpower to even say
oversee that fair is that a concern
well as I as I just told you it was a
concern in in
stratum um you know there are people out
there who are often willing to help but
don't have the time that folks used to
and so if they know all right I don't
have to do the fundraising I don't have
to do the actual construction I'm
hopeful that this would encourage people
to to take a uh a more active role you
know we've had a societ
in New Hampshire and probably in most of
the country where people were very
Hands-On they got involved in in
something I mean I jacked up the shed at
the Historical Society and poured you
know footings under it yeah and I don't
see myself doing that anymore and
there's nobody coming along to do that
but if I knew there was you know the
money for that to be done I wouldn't
mind being part of the planning process
and so I'm more hopeful that that that
happens and and Hope hopefully um while
we may not have people involved as much
in the 20s and 30s that when they get
towards
retirement they'll be more willing to
take part in something that has a a
revenue stream where they don't feel
they're going to have to do the physical
work thank you it's only a hope but it's
all I can do and I know hope is not a
plan any further
questions yes rep excuse me repi thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh
commissioner for taking my question and
I will apologize Upfront for this
question okay and and that is you know
you're coming to us to ask for
$250,000 out of the general fund and two
years ago uh we were looking at a bill
to fund the uh animal abuse fund and we
were looking for 50 cents a year
increase in the dog fees and my
honorable colleagues um voted that down
because it was a tax okay so if we
couldn't allocate 50 cents a year um to
the increase in the dog fees um because
it's a tax why should I now which I
would like to support but why should I
now support a bill taking
$250,000 out of the general
fund that's an excellent excellent
question and I'll probably get myself in
trouble
but the general fund doesn't have a
constituency dog owners have a
constituency snowmobile owners have a
constituency and and I remember the bill
you're you're talking about but there
are always going to be people from those
constituencies saying I don't want to
you know pay more money for that for
whatever reason the snowmobiles I bring
up because that was a particular fee
increase that the snowmobile users
actually wanted to pay so that the
trails could be improved the legislature
still said no because unfortunately we
have groups out there that are scoring
legislators and saying no more fees no
more taxes and you get a ding next to
your name if you vote for an increased
fee or tax and so even in those cases
where the constituents want the increase
there's somebody out there doing a score
this isn't going to be scored by anybody
for 20 you know
50,000,000 so this is more likely to be
a case where if um ways or means or
finances yeah we can do this then people
should be good with I mean there's
always going to be people I I I've said
get myself in trouble again that there
are are probably people in the
legislature who don't want to spend any
money on anything and so there'll always
be
opposition but um I think this is one of
those hopefully wholesome things where
people know that if we lose our fairs we
lose an important part of who we are as
a state we lose an important part of our
Our Heritage and for something that
doesn't amount to 25 cents a person a
year uh in you know it's less than 20
cents per person I think that that's one
of those things that and I and I get it
there's 10,000 things out there
everybody can say the same thing too uh
and and so I understand that and I I
understand the decision that you have to
make but hopefully as the environment
agricultural
committee you can see that this is an
important part of of Agriculture and who
we are as a
state any further
questions see none we thank you for your
test testimony thank you my pleasure to
have been here always a pleasure to have
you so I have no more pain cards is
there anyone else that would like
to are those for this bill oh okay
anybody here who would anybody else that
would like to speak to this
bill all right seeing none I will read
the blue sheet we have one person signed
on in support on the blue sheet and four
people that signed in online with that I
will close the hearing on House Bill
for
okay we've got about six or seven
minutes before the next hearing so I'm
going to move us into exact
session and we're going to open up the
exact session on House Bill 10:49
and I'm passing out some
amendments give a minute for the uh
amendments to get passed around
so I'm going to actually take a motion
on this and get a second second and
while these are being passed out and
then I can start explaining uh what our
process is here so I am going to uh I'm
going to move House Bill 1049 ought to
pass and do I have a
second I didn't catch who it was who
seconded s
yes okay so what we've done as as you
all remember we have a uh we had several
bills that were of similar topic that we
heard last
Tuesday I apologize I got to switch
sheets here oh there it is that's the
one I'm looking
for so we uh in our various caucuses
discussed a path forward with this and
we decided that we would move a lot of
the bills specifically the content of
House Bill
1111 the content of House Bill
1121 and the content of House Bill
1454 and combine that into house bill
1049 and so the amendment that I've
passed around which we haven't approved
yet but I'm just kind of giving you a um
an idea of how we're approaching this
contains all of the uh all of the
criteria uh excuse me all of the active
parts of those bills and adds them to
the the part of House Bill 1049 so that
that all becomes part part of the study
committee representative Bixby uh spent
a lot of time over the weekend in
putting this language
together and so I want to
offer to the committee the amendment to
house bill for 1049 which
is the uh oh actually we have to take a
vote on OTP and then we we we actually
shouldn't take a vote on OTP okay that's
right oh we we should we need to do the
motion to amend you want me to do that I
always get that back backwards okay so
I'm going to look to uh representative
actually I'm going to make a motion to
move house the amendment to House Bill
1049 Amendment
2022-23 I'll look for representative
Biby for a second um I will second that
thank you and would you like me to speak
to it sure I think I've given somewhat
of an oversight on it already and I'll
turn it over to you to continue on okay
so um the amendment essentially places
the um existing uh duties of the
committee the first two elements are uh
exactly the same as were in the um the
original Bill uh and then we've added
that to that uh section three which is
looking at uh the uh maturity bonding of
landfills to ensure that there's a
capacity to um pay for potential damages
and uh what particularly needs to be
studied there is a clarification of uh
how damages would be determined and who
would uh and who would be eligible to
seek compensation for damages uh that's
something that
um that uh so that's something that
needs a needs study you both in terms of
is that something that we need that uh
we should have require of landfills as
the new landfills and the mechanisms for
doing it if we uh if that if we decide
that's important thing to do
um uh the next uh section is the content
of uh uh dealing with the content of HB
1154 uh which is changing the setback
for uh the um for a landfill from a
water water body uh which is currently
defined as 200 feet which is sort of an
arbitrary number uh this would look into
uh looking at iological characteristics
of the site as a way of determining what
that setback should be based on how fast
a um contaminant might travel uh if it
if there is a a breach uh and so that
would essentially um looking at how to
do a more science-based uh assessment of
that uh we are also going to be not
executing that bill right away but
potentially seeing if we can amend amend
it before the deadline uh which would
then make this part of the study less
important but uh if we if we can't come
up with a resolution before the deadline
uh then we can we'll still have this
committee this part of the study
available to uh cover that um the next
section is uh the question of extended
producer responsibility which is a
fairly broad concept uh and uh it exists
in some uh in some forms already uh
there are uh re so when you get a when
you um buy a new car battery you return
your car battery that is a form of
extended producer
responsibility um the uh similarly with
tires there are some states that already
have programs for electronics uh like
computers and television screens uh New
Hampshire does not have one of those we
can look at those States and see how
they are doing that uh and there are a
couple of states that have looked at uh
that that are moving towards doing a
similar thing similar um program with
packaging and a number of Canadian
provinces are doing that as well we can
look we can study those laws and see if
those laws would be uh something that we
could adapt to New Hampshire and um and
all of the benefit of all of those
things would be reducing the pressure on
our landfills which is costing us in uh
what we pay in our M Municipal Taxes for
uh tipping fees uh transfer disposal Etc
so
uh uh this basically fits in with also
with the that initial the section number
two in terms of reducing pressure on
landfills one of the things that I think
is really important in terms of uh doing
any sort of extended producer
responsibility is making sure that it
really fits Within in how we do how our
New Hampshire solid waste system works
in terms of our system of uh local
transfer stations local recycling
centers that uh and so if in order to
make it work in New Hampshire we need to
study how it works how it will work with
the New Hampshire system already uh if
uh trying to take a bill from another
state and just graft it onto our laws
probably won't work work so this is
going to take us a fair amount of um you
know fair amount of uh work and and
research uh the last piece on here is uh
probably the least important piece
because uh HB 1134 the bill dealing with
wipes uh we are going to uh deal with
that later today and hopefully pass it
with Amendment so that it can go to
resources as a second committee and they
can figure out what to really do with it
but just in case that that has some
hiccup along the way we put it in here
for uh insurance so uh that's um I I
urge you to uh vote uh otpa with this
and
um any other comments or questions all
right thank you any other any further
questions or comments representative
Murray I did have a question thank you
Mr chair uh I'm not sure if this is for
the spor the amendment or or both of you
but we we're both are okay yeah thank
you um is there a date that this would
be do out bu that That Remains the Same
as the date on the initial on the
original bill which we did not change so
it's is it October
31st I don't have the original bill
right in front of me I'm sorry I have
about eight of them here I'll open but
all we were actually changing is the
duties portion the remainder of the bill
stayed the same thank
you
I I believe it is October 31st but I
need to pull up the right stack of
papers here to find it to answer that
it's all good thank you appreciate it
any further questions or
comments seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the rooll on o ought to
pass for amendment number
2022-23 N8 which is an amendment to
House Bill 1049 uh just a point of order
yes sir I think first we need to pass
the amendment and then we need to pass
the O do the
that's what I did
okay are we ready we are ready uh
representative K yes representative
Davis yes representative Stapleton yes
representative hola yes represent
Kennedy yes represent Mason yes
represent sour yes represent Bixby
yes representative poran yes
representative Schultz yes yes represent
Duty yes represent Murray yes represent
vinsky yes represent klin
yes represent
Perez yes Mr chair
yes
160 Amendment passed so the amendment
passes 16 to
zero so now we move on to ought to pass
as amended on house Bill
1049 with amend using Amendment uh
2022269928
[Laughter]
okay any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on otpa excuse me
otpa on House Bill 1049 with Amendment
0269 H okay represent kto yes represent
Davis represent Stapleton yes represent
hola yes represent Ken
yes represent Mason yes represent sorn
yes represent Bixby yes representative
Horgan yes representative Schultz yes
representative Duty yes represent Murray
yes represent Von
plinsky represent Kaplan yes represent
perz yes Mr chair
yes motion passes 160
all right so the motion passes 16 to Zer
and we've adopted ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 1049 I'm now going
to close the executive session on House
Bill 1049 Mr chair is this going to go
on consent oh yes uh any objection to
going on consent thank you n seen all
right we'll put it on consent and with
that I will close the hearing on uh the
exact session on House Bill
okay we're going to uh go back to our
regular schedule and we'll be opening up
house B the hearing on House Bill
11 186 relative to companion animals
during a declared state of emergency and
I will call on rep Gallagher from
conquered Ward six to come in and
introduce the bill welcome TOA
good hi so I'm representative Eric
Gallagher from uh Mar County district 15
which is conquered w six so I have this
bill on
pet evacuations um so you if you pay
attention to the news much
um you know there there's often lots of
natural disasters being reported um and
even in my Committee just yesterday my U
my own committee Municipal and County
government we were hearing about
flooding in um
aworth um and when there's something
like a blood people need to be evacuated
and one thing I've heard about is that
sometimes when people get evacuated they
get separated from their pets and
they'll
and that is not good for either the
people or the pets
um so in the aftermath of in the
aftermath of Hurricane Katrina uh the
federal
government passed the pets act um the
pet evacuation and transportation
standards act I think is um what it
stood for um so that was a bipartisan
bill um setting up standards for how
exactly pets would be evacuated in the
case of emergencies but it had some
holes in it uh um
so um that applies pretty much just to
FEMA
shelters um but the thing is sometimes
people when being evacuated from an
emergency uh get sheltered in other
places so this bill is intended to close
some of the loopholes in the pets act
um such as when people get sheltered in
a hotel for instance
um
so
um so the language here
um
so says uh during a declared state of
emergency containing an evacuation order
any hotel or Community shelter which is
required to shelter evacuated persons
shall also shelter a companion animal
belonging to such evacuated persons so
that's the text as it reads um there's
also an
amendment uh which uh the uh drafting
attorney that OS should have or um I
mean I I got the email for I think you
all were CC on it too um So after
talking with some people about this bill
um some concerns that were raised um
were so where it says hotel or Community
Shelter
Hotel uh some of the people I talked to
were fine with but um there's a concern
that Community shelter was a little bit
vague as to what exactly that might
apply to so um I tried
to I tried to come up with an
amendment um to clarify that a bit but
um unfortunately um that
part did make it in um the idea is
basically that it should only be places
and shelter um places used as shelters
where like it's possible for the people
and their pets to have their own
separate rooms so like if it's a
[Music]
school if if it's a school auditorium or
a sports Stadium or something where
everyone would just be in a big common
area that probably wouldn't be the best
idea
um but the thing is it's hard to come up
with a term that um besides Community
shelters that draws that sort of
Distinction um so what the amendment
does actually do um so the DHHS um it
has this program called the disaster
animal response team which has kind of
been kicked around from Department to
Department
um which is kind of why I'm confused as
to why this bill is before this
committee rather than uh before the
Health and Human Services committee but
I guess that's a question for the clerk
um but anyways um the disaster animal
response team needs some help getting
set up and one of the things they raised
was how uh they enlist the help of
volunteers to help
people uh
evacuate animals in the case of
emergencies so
um but state law is kind of unclear
about how exactly to treat
um treat these volunteers when they're
doing this so um my what my Amendment
does is it adds a definition of to
Define these volunteers
as um
emergency as emergency workers so
they're created the same as other
emergency
workers
um so yeah the the idea is basically to
help get this disaster animal response
team and DHHS set up and going so it can
actually help rescue or help Pro
properly keep people P people and their
pets together during emergency
evacuation so that's the bill and the
amendment and I'll take any
questions thank you representative so we
have not seen copies of the amendment um
okay would so we right now we're kind of
working from the original Bill itself
let me see if I can well that's all
right probably the best thing you could
do is we we'll sort of continue on uh
it's I think we all have a general
understanding of the amendment language
from what you've described but if you
could provide that to the committee as
perhaps after the hearing here when you
get a chance would be good or email us
the copy that you do have would be
helpful any questions for rep Galler yes
representative amola yes thank you for
taking my question um I was just curious
about how the process works now during
an evacuation would would the companion
uh animal be boarded somehow left behind
at the house what what what exactly
happens right
now
um
so well if they're if they're brought to
a FEMA shelter then they're kept
together
um
if um if it's not a FEMA shelter then um
I Heard uh that DHHS has some sort of
trailer specific specifically for this
purpose
um that they put the animals into
um but anyways um yeah in in the case of
Hurricane Katrina with the original pets
you did actually hear about um pets
getting left
behind but um okay thank you could I
have a follow follow up sure uh the
question I had is in here if I'm reading
this under understandingly it says a
companion animal there's no sort of
limit on what that definition is did
your Amendment address that in any way
because I mean it could be a companion
llama a companion dog I is there any
kind of cap to
that
um I
mean the the intent here is pretty much
the type of I um I mean my original
language just said pets and then o OAS
changed it to companion animals um so
I'm assuming that's because companion
animals must already be a term some
defined um somewhere else in the law
that has a specific meaning that would
be only applicable to the kinds I'm
thinking of which is the types of an
people normally people's pets you know
dogs cats snakes guinea pigs um rodents
whatever
else thank you repola there there is
definitions in other areas of Statute
for companion animals I'm not sure if
there is in 126a specifically we'll have
to look into that but representative
Oregon yes I assume the term companion
animals also encompasses service dogs as
well as pets but do you know if there's
already a provision in RSA 2026 or
somewhere else that uh specifically
requires uh humans service animals in
there to be uh sheltered along with
their
humans uh thanks for the question and
sorry but no I do not
know that the answer to that
question representative Murray thank you
Mr chair for taking my question and uh
welcome to the committee thank you for
bringing the bill before us um I did
have one question in addition to I'm
still looking for an amendment that I I
couldn't get track down so thank you for
sending that along when you get it but
also um is there a limit to physically
how many animals
may join a person who is seeking shelter
during an
evacuation
um yeah
they're
um yeah all right that's um a fair point
I don't see one currently WR in this
language um I mean i' I'd
assume
that the people doing the evacuations
would interpret it reasonably and not
try to pack more animals into a room
then can fit into it but um if you
wouldd like
an additional amendment to clarify that
I would be open to
that okay thank you any further
questions for rip
gallager seeing none we thank you sir
appreciate you coming
in okay next we have uh rep Ellen Reed
from Rockingham
17 good afternoon and welcome to Ena
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you honorable members for welcoming me
into your committee I believe this is
the first time I've ever testified in
front of Ena before so thank you very
much I actually wasn't planning oh for
the record my name is Ellen Reed I
represent Rockingham 17 New Market and
new Fields very proudly represent
Rockingham 17 I wasn't planning on
testifying but as I was hearing the the
hearing I had a few thoughts because I
have an unrelated but um kind of similar
topic bill in another committee and I I
happen to have some uh have been working
on similar language about these types of
issues that bill has to do with pets in
rental housing um so I am a co-sponsor
of this bill I will say that
statistically speaking everyone here
two-thirds of you own companion animals
pets um and when I was introducing this
other bill I had a member I want to say
of the opposite party but there is no
opposite party for me anymore so for my
former opposite Party come to me after
and say can you imagine can you imagine
having to choose between giving up your
animal who will most certainly die or
having to choose being homeless and that
was very poignant in fact that
particular member was recounting to me a
story of one of her friends having to
lose her housing because um of a dog
that she had now can you imagine that
awful choice and now combine it with an
emergency a weather event or whatever
and you being displaced from your home
and on top of all of the trauma and all
of the loss having to lose your beloved
Companion Animal on top of it or being
forced to not be insecure housing
because you've decided to choose to make
sure that your animal stays alive
because you have that profound sense of
of obligation to to that
animal so um in terms of the questions
that were brought up about definitions
of which an animal uh in in the language
I've worked on separately I use the
definition cats dogs and animals in
enclosures so that would be caged or
aquarium type animals so that I felt
that that was very reasonable in terms
of limiting it to something that wasn't
llamas and farm animals and what have
you um I do think this is a reasonable
idea I'm happy to work with the
committee members who are interested as
well as rep Gallagher on further
amendments to to help clarify those
definitions also the limit in the
language I've worked on on a separate
bill I use the limit by saying whatever
Municipal ordinances exists so if
Municipal ordinance exists that says no
more than six cats then that would be
apply to whatever the individual um
separate family housing structure that
exists that is the shelter so I just
wanted to put those little notes out
there again I'm happy to work on
Amendment if that's um what the members
of this committee would be interested in
thank you thank you representative any
uh questions for representative
Reed I did really well it easy and I I
think your assistance would be uh
definitely of value thank
you okay our final pink card that I have
is Stacy obber from
AKC good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Stacy oer I
am the legislative analyst and community
outreach contact in New England for the
American Kennel Club uh the AKC is a 135
yearold not for-profit organization
that's recognized as an expert in K9
Health breeding training and responsible
dog ownership and when we saw this bill
we were're grateful that rep Gallagher
has raised it and support the intent of
the bill
um you've already heard the consequence
of Katrina resulting in uh federal law
to establish the pets act which creates
some standards around evacuation and
transportation of pets my understanding
is that back in '06 New Hampshire did
enact statutory language that requires
uh shelters the femous shelters to house
the service animals that might go with
an individual a disabled person who
would have a service animal to be sure
they weren't separated um and AKC has in
the past few years uh with our clubs
raised funds to establish disaster
animal disaster relief trailers and we
have deployed 92 of these trailers
across the country because we know
people will refuse to evacuate if they
can't bring their companion animal with
them um we have 12 more trailers that
are in the pipeline to be distributed
and so not knowing whether or not that
was a gap here for New Hampshire had
discussed with New Hampshire dogs
whether or not um the clubs in New
Hampshire might be interested in in
looking to fund a trailer um I did reach
out and speak to the individual over at
DHHS about the DART program here in New
Hampshire um and she acknowledged that
there are four Trail trailers here in
New Hampshire uh that probably could
accommodate about 200 companion animals
uh if there were a
disaster and I think that's important
it's important to acknowledge because we
know for instance in the recent past
there was the flooding in New York City
as a consequence of the hurricane that
hit uh the southern part of the country
we know that Kentucky just suffered
those uh tornadoes for instance uh so it
is a crucial uh part of the emergency
plan I did read online that New
Hampshire does have its emergency plan
and it's carved up by state agency and
chapter so for instance the Department
of Agriculture has responsibility for
creating a plan for agricultural animals
and livestock and my understanding is
that the responsibility for companion
animals that would be housed in domicile
or people's residences and homes was
transferred over to DHHS right before Co
hit
so there really hasn't been a lot of
work that's been done in um implementing
and the volunteer uh network has fallen
apart so to speak uh because of the
issue heard rep Gallagher address in his
Amendment around um volunteers who are
trained in the transport of dogs cats
and I'm told Turtles are very popular in
New Hampshire as a companion animal um
that there's a dis incentive to become a
trained volunteer because under the
emergency Powers uh anyone who is a
Public Employee whether that be for the
state or a local subdivision there are
certain Protections in the event you're
deployed and you might be injured while
providing those uh uh those
responsibilities and that same
protection doesn't exist for the
disaster animal Response Team volunteers
so I'm grateful to rep Gallagher for
working on some language uh with the
Legislative Office to attempt to address
that because of those are some
fundamental pieces I think that ought to
be put in place so that the program can
um reconvene and and formalize itself
and um eliminate some of these gaps on
the question of how many animals I agree
with rep Reed that commonly there may be
by local ordinance a uh limit for
instance on how many dogs you can own
without before having to get a kennel
license and I will share with you that
AKC when we do our kennel inspections uh
we have our club members fill out
paperwork and do recordkeeping and
included as part of that is to have an
emergency evacuation plan for those dogs
that would be in your kennel um so
that's a critical component that's
covered by a and the clubs as
well thank you for your
support all right thank you for
Testimony any questions uh
representative Murray
um yes I I did have one question for you
but I also just wanted to call to the
record that the amendment did make its
way to us so it is there um also thank
you for taking my question
um I am curious so you did mention that
obviously the dart vehicle uh trailers
are already there um would those be also
would they be transporting those animals
I'm trying to educate myself would they
be transported to another location or
would
those when the animals are then put on
those safety trailers where would they
go after that so my understanding is the
New Hampshire for trailers are between
16 and 24 feet long and they would come
supplied with everything you would need
to be able to quickly identify animals
who the owner is it would come with um
crates so that you could individually
shelter those animals and move them to
safety whatever wherever that might be
whether it was a flood a fire or tornado
I guess arguably if the only public
shelter was uh let's say an a an
auditorium then arguably the the
trailers could be in the parking lot and
that would perhaps suffice as ter in in
the context of keeping um owners with
their companion animals in close
proximity thank
you excuse me representative Bixby yes
thank you for taking my question U I'm
wondering if there is leg legislation or
if there are laws in other states that
we could use as um that might help us uh
as as a model for this because it I have
this feeling that the bill as pres I
haven't seen the amendment but I have
the feeling that the bill is has
presented doesn't have a lot of the
working
mechanisms necessary to to actually make
this
operational I think one of the biggest
issues is probably funding I my
understanding is that DHHS had
anticipated getting a Federal grant so
they could hire a program manager so
these responsibilities were brought over
to DHHS and assigned to someone who has
responsibility for other programs um the
grant didn't go forward as an
application because it was specific
under the uh US Department of Homeland
Security for terrorism and that's kind
of a narrow focus and uh animal
relocation in a disaster would include
so many other traumatic events outside
of terrorism so apparently that was not
a viable funding opportunity as they had
hoped for um but I do think that it
would be um very helpful if there was
funding for a program manager to pull
all of those straight pieces
together thank
you any further questions for is
over I have read through the amendment
real quickly and it appears to address
the liability protection that you were
looking for but um it does not address
some of the other concerns that were
raised here so we may have some further
work to do on that but we'll um
certainly get copies for everyone to
see all right thank you for your
testimony thank you very much appreciate
you coming in all right final pink card
I have is from uh Angela Ferrari for dog
owners of the Granite
State
welcome to the ENA thank you chairman
members of the committee it's nice to
see you all in person um I am
representing my name is Angela Ferrari
I'm representing dog owners of the
Granite State we are an AKC Affiliated
group that monitors legislation on
behalf of pet owners and include a wide
variety from cat dog owners um mushers
breeders you name it and we wanted to
just let you know that we support this
bill um some concerns were raised today
that we think are valid and would be
happy to try and provide any input as
the bill goes through further work but
just wanted to provide our support for
the bill and its
intentions thank you any questions for
Miss
Ferrari seeing none thank you for coming
in
today okay that's the last of the pink
cards I have anybody else wishing to
speak on this bill
that not for this bill okay all right
seeing none then I will read the blue
sheet uh we have four signed in in all
in support and online we have 28 in
support and two
opposed and with that I will close the
hearing on HBU
oh Mr chairman so I'm I'm a co-sponsor
of the bills so I will not I guess I did
put in a pink card but I won't be uh
questioning any of the other testifiers
and I'll probably since there room out
there probably sit out there for for the
hearing well representative we uh we
don't ask the co-sponsors not to
participate as long as they didn't speak
so if you're not going to testify you're
welcome to sit here with the committee
and you are allowed to ask questions
okay sure thank
you okay it is after 3 o' so we're going
to open up the hearing on House Bill
1226 FN prohibiting the declaring of
cats and we have our Prime sponsor rep
cam Kenny who is here to speak in to the
committee and introduce the
bill good afternoon and welcome to the
ENA thank you Mr
chairman good afternoon uh honorable
colleagues um so since I have joined the
legislature I have been educated in many
areas of law uh but nothing surprised me
quite like
decline I've always known decline was
painful barbaric and should never be
allowed but after learning the specifics
and what the procedure actually consists
of I'm truly surprised that it is still
allowed the lure consistently shows that
decline has permanent and detrimental
effects on cats uh quick disclaimer
there are many sources used throughout
my testimony and after I get home
tonight I will send the committee uh
written testimony with the those sources
uh for your reference uh so there is uh
no literature that I could find that
states decline is harmless an article in
the Journal of feline medicine and
surgery from 2018 shows de declaw cats
one Bitmore two used a litter box less
three have back pain and four are overg
groomed uh which is a sign of pain and
frustration if there is any literature
that offers information to disprove it I
would love to see it
I'll now briefly highlight five
important facts related to some
objections I anticipate you may hear uh
so first decline is common and a law is
needed to stop it an estimated 20% to
25% of own cats are
declawed I keep hearing that declawing
is rare but this stat consistently
disproves that again I have searched for
alternative information but cannot find
it in 2014 a survey of 3,000
veterinarians only 24% responded that
they do not
declo also in 2014 a report out of North
Carolina 21% of cat 21% of cats seen in
vet hospitals were
declawed so I find it hard that we can
truly consider that
uncommon now outside of the USA uh you
may be wondering what other countries
are doing Canada is the only other
nation that regularly declaw eight out
of 10 of their provinces uh have banned
it with the two remaining pending
legislation in the UK the College of
veterinarian services coins it
unnecessary mutilation Veterinary
Ireland has pointed out that the cat uh
gets no benefits from this and quote
while commonly performed in USA it is
not performed in Ireland and any
Veterinary practitioner performing this
act would clearly be open to
disciplinary action this mindset is not
uncommon in the rest of the world's
countries again only the US and Canada
practice this
currently two uh decline cats do not
keep cats out of shelters on the
contrary declaw bands keep cats out of
shelters a survey of shelters and
Rescuers show that these entities have
strict no declaw policies in their
contracts why would an organization that
is desperate to find animals a home
disqualify potential adopters only on
the basis that they are going uh to
declaw their cat I have two cats and
that question was asked uh when I
adopted them they know that declawed
cats bite more and use the litter box
less if someone is intolerant of cat
scratching which is a very normal feline
Behavior enough that they seek a maming
surgery to stop it that person is really
going to probably be intolerant of a cat
peeing on the couch or biting to defend
itself or the other consistent
behavioral issues that we have seen a
study published in 2021 examined data
from 3 years prior and 3 years after
Durban in British Columbia and found no
difference in the number of cats
surrendered including those surrendered
specifically for destructive scratching
there was also no difference in the
length of time cats spent at the shelter
or a number of cats that were euthanized
however the number of owner requested
euthanize Asia decreased after the
ban excuse me considering uh the time of
the committee I will just state that
there are many examples from other
studies like one in La that I uh will
provide through uh
email so to conclude this point in a
survey of owners of cats that had been
brought in to be declawed by their
veterinarians only 4% of owners said
that they would relinquish their pets if
it could not be declawed in contrast the
veterinarians in the survey speculated
that 50% of those owners would have
relinquished their
pets uh and again it was only
4% uh so third Point laser decline uh is
not painless uh or better for cats where
lasers are used uh it they essentially
burn uh the cat's toe tissues the
American Animal Hospital Association
published a study that only 12.2% of
veterinarian hospitals use this
technique research shows that lasers
offered no benefit over a more
conventional method of declawing finding
differences in discomfort and
complications between groups treated um
were not clinically r
another study found complications such
as bleeding limping swelling infections
were generally worse in the laser
decline group compared against uh blade
laser decline can result uh in fourth
degree
burns it can leave the cat suffering
from bony fragments left under the skin
just like any other method of decline so
it is absolutely not a per uh ferred
method four exemp exemptions for the
cat's medical and physical health Health
are already included in this bill the
language is that a physical or medical
condition that compromises the health or
well-being of the animal but not
including cosmetic reasons or reasons of
convenience uh in the keeping or
handling of the animal so medical
necessity like a tumor or a deformity of
the toe is
included decline to avert cat scratching
is not allowed in this bill like I said
declawed cats develop far worse Behavior
than the scratching ever was and
therefore will likely lose their homes
for those behaviors not using the litter
box and biting are the number one one
and two behavioral reasons that cats
lose their home decline can and in many
cases does cause both these bad
behaviors medical exemptions for the
well-being of the cat owner are not
warranted because there is no valid
human health reason to declaw a cat
which will bring me to
0.5 uh people with compromised immune
systems do not need to declaw their cat
in fact decl cats to prevent human
illnesses is not recommended by the CDC
the US Public Health Service uh the
National Institute of Health or
infectious disease experts just to make
the point one more time all around the
world people are living with indoor cats
and not decline them despite human
health issues this is because there is
no reason to decline cat for the already
said
reasons uh you know personally I I
believe CDC and those other
organizations are the ones that we
should listen to regarding uh human
health
uh and uh yeah so I'll conclude here Mr
chairman um so for the reasons just
stated Banning decline is good for
everyone uh it's a horrible surgery that
was invented in the 1950s to stop a very
normal behavior at this point we know
better uh and we should do better I
humbly ask for your support I think this
is a bipartisan issue I think the cats
have the right for the highest uh
standard of Medical Care
I think cats have the right to bear arms
uh I ask for your
support and I am happy to take any
questions um and there will be um
veterinarians in support of the bill
testifying after uh who you can also
direct questions to thank you
representative uh representative Aaron
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Kenny for your
introducing this bill um I do have a
question in your bill you said say that
first of all that this is a clas D
misdemeanor to dclock hat um but it also
says that it gives an exception um that
you know whatever medical condition the
cat such as uh recurring illness disease
injury abnormal condition of the claw so
for instance if there's a tumor on one
paw of the
cat I'm assuming this bill would allow
the veterinarian to remove the
claw would that be of the entire paw or
just one or all of them I mean it's it
doesn't State
specifically how that medical procedure
would have to
be uh done sure and at risk of being a
misdemeanor you know I think it would be
important to determine that yeah sure
and um there will be vets who um speak
after me but to my understanding if
there's a tumor on just one claw then
the whole paw does not have to be
declawed is that your question right so
follow up so if the veterinarian then
declaws the toes that do not have the
illness or disease on it would they be
facing a misdemeanor
charge um how I could answer that is if
there is a medic I reason to take off
the other um the other claws on the Paw
then then yes but um you know basically
if there is a reason um medically and a
veterinarian feels so then that would be
allowed thank
you any other
questions representative Murray uh thank
you Mr chair for taking my question and
thank you to the prime sponsor for um
taking my question as well can you speak
to
the um fiscal note a little bit in the
how is it in the event of a a
misdemeanor are we actually we're
talking here about incarcerating an
individual um so for the there's a lot
of ambiguity in the um fiscal note um
one sentence says a new case study is
being conducted and updated uh estimates
will be a available in the future
um
but so so a lot of it is indeterminable
right now um in the bill it's a
misdemeanor um so however the law deals
with that misdemeanor is how the bill
would deal with it okay thank you
representative
Duty thank you for taking my question
and recognizing me um the question that
I had uh was similar to that it says any
person who violates this section will be
guilty of a Class B misdemeanor so would
that be the owner and the
vet um so to my understanding I I I
believe it would be the veterinarian
because the veterinarian would have to
be practicing um the
decline okay thank
you any further
questions representative
Kennedy thank you for taking my question
so
so why do you not see that the
relationship between the vet and the cat
owner
itself
is shouldn't this decision be between
them and not us and should it not be
reprimanded because it's between an
animal and their professional
veterinarian that's doing declawing sure
yeah well veterinarians uh from around
the world come out because this is a
barbaric practice for uh to be honest
there's there's very limited reasons why
uh decline is necessary it's been quite
commonly since the 50s used more for
convenience um again if there is a
legitimate medical reason then this bill
does still allow
that representative Murray uh thank you
for Tak my question thank you also when
uh let's go back to that point about
medical reasons for the health of the um
owner as well is there any situation
where that would be a reason for which
that would be necessary uh no um you
know according to um human human health
experts um that there's there's been no
evidence of that the only um the only
place where you have seen that is
through the recommendations of of
certain
veterinarians thank you
any further
questions I guess I would ask one
so we have to dis you know the the
charge of our committee is always
looking at policy relating to animals
and and their care certainly
and when we start down a path of going
into deciding Veterinary decisions
versus in owner
decisions information that should be on
that we kind of get into an area that
gets a little touchy at times and I
think you've had a couple of questions
in in fact the last one was one I was
going to ask about the health of the
owner as well but is there um has there
been any consideration given to
why that why this would be good public
policy I understand that you're looking
at at the health of the cat but about as
far as general policy if we start down
this path of deciding Veterinary
ownership decisions you know would would
would you see that extending into other
animals as well beyond cats um no
personally I wouldn't only because um
you know what kind of surprised me was
most of the world has never done this
because again they just view it as
barbaric um so you know I don't think
it's a slippery slope I I think
primarily right now um cats are are the
animal being declawed and there's really
no justifiable reason for it um although
if it was happening to other animals I
don't think it should there too because
again other than the few uh medical
reasons which the bill does allow
there's just no reason other than
convenience um that that I've seen uh
you know including about human health um
for
decline thank you any further question
we have one more I do apologize I I'm
just looking through the bill and I
wanted to make doubly and triple sure
that what we're talking about would be
Cit
against the entity performing the
declawing and or would this potentially
then by default
because the individual who owns the cat
is signing off on the medical procedure
asking for that like who where does the
legal
liability lie with the person
potentially being charged with the
misdemeanor sure so um line four it says
um that no person shall remove the claw
um so it's it's essentially saying that
that the vet because you know if if an
owner wants it a vet would have to um
perform the
surgery thank you any further
questions thank you representative we
appreciate your testimony thank you so
much okay next up we have uh rep Timothy
Horgan from
straford I'm not sure is that straford
six yes okay thank
you um as most of you probably know
because I've been sitting here all day
I'm represented Timothy Horan from
straford County district 6 to towns of
Durham and Madbury and that's the same
district that rent Kenny represents and
um I have indeed uh mat and petted his
cats they're like truly outstanding
felines not just like all other felines
um I just want reiterate this is a
barbaric practice it um the fing jamine
basically means you're they're cutting
the uh last fance we also have three
fanes on all our fingers and two on our
toes and big toes so like you're
basically amputating the cat's fingers
and then if you do it in the back you're
amputating his toes too so that's um
just as bad or maybe even worse for a
cat than if it happened to one of us
because they're just as sensitive
probably more so than um than we humans
are so that that alone is a a reason to
reason to ban it it uh
and uh sometimes sometimes decline is
Justified because they'll scratch their
humans or others who annoy them but
usually uh usually scratching is one of
their first lines of defenses and then
after that uh biting is one of the next
ones so they basally they're skipping
their first way of one of their first
ways of telling you to back off and then
they have to go straight to biting and
that also uh that probably also
partially explains uh the worst use of
the litter box aside from the fact that
like it can't just like you human who
didn't have all his fingers would be
less happy all things being equ than
someone who has all his fingers can't um
the can't be less happy and there's uh
it does appear that usually there's a
lot of residual pain and even if they're
um and then that's also a means of uh
marking their territory in terms of uh
terms of scratching your furniture I
guess that depends on what your
priorities are but there are uh tips you
can affix to their their claws which uh
you know make their claws
softer and um so I just think this is a
barbaric practice that should be should
be outlawed and um answer ver Erin's
question if for some reason this
wouldn't prevent a vet from amputating
the cat's leg or front or back leg or
even just a foot if that was uh
medically needed because the cat had
cancer or an injury or something so
that's uh and I myself one of my late
cats I did have to have one of the claws
taken off because he dislocated it well
climbing a tree when he's about 18 years
old and too old to be climbing trees
like that but um so uh I think this bill
is uh this bill is very well drafted um
and it's been for this committee before
and hopefully this time we'll we'll pass
it and send it on its way to the cross
the wall to the other body and hopefully
for Signature by the governor who I
learned this summer is uh very fond of
cats himself so he's I think I think
he'll be happy to be able to sign this
bill so thanks any questions
rep
pamola yes sir thank you for taking my
my question um I I just have to be
honest I'm sitting here thinking how
different this conversation would be if
we were talking about a fetus and not
cat claws um but I'll just say that uh
do you have sir do you know how many uh
decline procedures happen in the state
every year just so we have some
perspective I don't I don't own a cat so
well the estimate uh estimate I seen is
about 25% of the uh 25% of of uh of cats
uh in the United States have been
declawed and virtually zero elsewhere
so do you
so do so do you have any statistics or
if maybe maybe somebody might provide
that after you but do you have any
statistics on how many times this
procedure is performed in New Hampshire
um that yeah you might have to ask
somebody somebody El probably would ask
somebody else about it I know um first
many vets are uh
many RS are elant to uh elant to do the
procedure and or if you do ask them to
do it they would uh you know try to Cel
you to make sure you really understood
the implications of it but I I don't
have the number maybe somebody has an
estimate I don't know thank
sir representative Aaron thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Horgan so
my question is I know the um previous
speaker and and uh sponsor of the bill
mentioned that there was no health
issues of owners that would require a
cat to be
declawed what if a person had developed
some sort of illness that uh required
them to be on blood
thinners
and their cat then
became a you know problem with that
because of their claws and despite any
kind of behavior modification trials or
other ways to uh prevent the cat from
scratching them they would have then the
decision of whether to keep the cat or
not um in this situation would you say
that the owner would be justified for
their own health reasons to have be able
to have the cat declaw um well
my first this is a little out of my area
of expertise although I did have a
family member who was taking warer and
and had a cat living in the household
with her and
um and and um they did not die of that
so and even with even in the absence of
cats there's lots of other things that
can scratch you and cause minor minor
bleeding so he probably had to have a
strategy for dealing with that
possibility anyway so uh that might I
think probably deploying the cat would
not be your first alternative and uh
frankly that may be uh and then perhaps
you may may want to probably the best
thing to do if you if you don't have a
way of you know dealing with that
dealing with minor bleeding is to you
might have to rehome the cat which is uh
a terrible thing to say but it's not as
bad as cutting off it's uh fingers I
think so thanks thank you probably not
the answer you wanted to hear
and representative
Duty yeah thank you for taking my
question um the original owners of my
house had two dogs and I still have uh
doors that have been gouged uh from
those dogs yeah so my question is um how
much how many times do we do declawing
of dogs and and if not why not since
they can also tear apart um furniture
and uh woodwork well we
um this this bill is about cats um with
with the dogs we did have a bill which
has come to this committee a number of
times I sponsored it at least once if I
remember offand and uh just a band
taking off the do Claws from the cat and
we got uh we got a lot of push back from
various people who felt that they um
especially dog especially dogs are
trained to trace animals and tight
spaces were concerned that the uh dog
might get caught on his two claw in the
tunnel or whatever it's going through so
there it's uh
it has been uh there have been bills
about that and they haven't uh they
haven't passed yet and uh as far as I
know actually have the whole list of
bills on my desk there there's not one
of those this year but yeah that yeah we
did anyway we did have a bill about not
not we have been had a bill in the past
about not Banning the appication of du
Claws and that which is just the claw
which cats have sort of on their wrist
and that actually frankly has failed
there's a lot of there's just a lot of
resistance from U especially from uh The
Kennel Club and dog readers and people
like that so that's I guess it didn't
come with this year just because you
know we're not operating a full capacity
in the house we want to pick our battles
so follow up yeah Ju Just to be clear do
you know of cases where we declaw dogs
uh for cosmetic reasons or because they
destroy Furniture um I I don't know but
it probably has happened
f
any further
questions I'm going to ask one actually
you I want to clarify and make sure that
I heard what you said earlier you were
made a statement about there wasn't a
lot of veterinaries that were doing it
and they see would have a long
conversation with their clients so my
question is do you feel like the
veterinaries are doing a good job in
educating their clients on the benefits
or issues with the cats when they do
this perform this well procedure this
particular procedure I've never wanted
to be done to my cat the one time I had
one toe cut off was because the cat was
injured and I um I was uh I was
reluctant to do it and I've heard that
was that was many years ago in that
particular vet I was back when I was
living in the Upper Valley I for if that
was actually based in Vermont but I do
know he um I do know he if you come in
ask him to claw the cat I've heard him
them try to talk other clients out of it
and I mean most veterans are very caring
people they're uh probably in general uh
better at their job than human doctors
are so I think I my companion Andel here
I think have gotten better Medical Care
than I've gotten from my doctors not
that I haven't had some very good
doctors but
um thank you uh any other questions
appreciate your
testimony all right next up we have H
representative Ellen Reid from
Rockingham
17 welcome again to the ENA thank you
again Mr chair again I am Ellen Reed I
represent Rockingham 17 New Market and
newfields again I'm very uh grateful
that you're welcoming me to your
committee and um again I actually wasn't
planning on speaking but I did hear a
couple things I wanted to to mention um
the idea of a slippery slope or starting
something new we already have cruelty
statute for domesticated animals and
animals in captivity longstanding
cruelty statute which I'm sure you're
familiar with so the concept is not a
New Concept we do prohibit certain types
of actions acted upon animals in
captivity um and certainly I think if
you think about it and just imagine if
every single one of your fingers and
toes were amputated or burned off at the
first knuckle the kind of pain and
impairment that that would cause that
certainly would qualify if it was done
for no reason uh for your health as
cruelty in your mind and because of that
I think personally it should under our
cruelty statute unfortunately it's not
been considered um to do so prior to
this but it's not a New Concept to say
that we have to prohibit certain
behaviors towards
animals the the difference here is the
doctor element human doctors are held to
the standard that they have to always
act in the best interest of their
patient whereas veterinarians are not
held to that standard certainly I think
probably the majority of veterinarians
believe in that standard but they're not
legally required they can do something
that is not in The Animals best interest
in fact I was speaking with my vet once
and he said he had to put an animal down
he actually refused to do it but the
owner requested that he put the animal
down because um the animal was allergic
to her
perfume um that's not something a human
doctor would ever consider obviously
just really quick on the idea of if if a
person developed like you know
hemophilia or had to take blood thinners
so the first thing is is that if you
have that condition that the if the
animal doesn't have claws the next thing
they're going to do is bite and how much
worse the bleeding would be from a bite
rather than a scratch but the
Alternatives exist the Caps that you can
have and they they they wear off after a
few weeks the Caps can be placed on the
the claws of the cat but also just and I
think this is the number one thing
because we talk about this as a
convenience thing providing for any
animal that you decide to own being
responsible in providing the appropriate
material so the animal can engage in
their natural behaviors providing
scratching posts providing um
attractants to the scratching posts and
the toys that you provide and then
deterrence on your furniture these
things exist so anyway uh again I just
had a few comments and thoughts as we
were going through the hearing and
wanted to share them I appreciate your
time thank you representative any
questions seeing none we thank you next
up we have representative Chris Schultz
representing conquered ward
nine welcome to the ENA
representative thank you Mr chair it's
an honor to be here with you all today I
would have been here even if I wasn't
subbing because I'm a co-sponsor of the
bill and while I'm not an animal expert
overall certainly not agriculture expert
overall uh my marriage depended on a
conversation about cat Decline and in
brief I will tell you that story and
some of the things that impacted my
decision and hopefully this is helpful
hopefully it mirrors the conversations
that a lot of people have around this
issue that can be helpful uh growing up
I had to during the summer I agreed to
really take care of the neighbor's cat
when they went uh to their camp out of
town and that sies cat hated
me and I developed a fear cats because
of that I liked the extra money so I
found my way to run in feed the cat
scoop the litter get out uh and that
perpetuated a fear of cats into my
adulthood I did not know any friendly
cats other than my experience with this
cat then I met my now husband uh
definitely a cat person I brought a pug
along with me and marrying me meant you
got the pug
too um and over time we discussed often
you know cat people dog people thinking
these issues out and not only was my
fear a concern but so was the I'd heard
cats can destroy your
furniture uh I was worried would the cat
get along with my pug he's used to being
the only pet in the house uh long story
short I first talked to my dog's vet who
also cared for cats and she went into
great details
about how harmful cat dcang was and
encouraged me to look at the literature
on uh actually buying some books she
recommended that you can actually not as
much as a dog maybe but you can do
certain things with a cat that is
essentially training a cat and I was
skeptical at first long story short
hopefully um I learned a lot from that
and decided for my husband's sake that
getting a cat was the right thing to do
and we definitely had some challenges at
the
beginning my husband at one point even
thought about returning the cat to the
SPCA here in conquer where we adopted
him and I'm so glad we didn't he's a
wonderful addition to our family and
there were ways to keep him from
scratching the furniture There were ways
to keep him from using his claws on us
when we played and we slowly introduced
him to our dog and um knowing the
cruelty that happens to cats because of
deawing if it's something that isn't
medically
necessary um it's not even just about
missing your fingers and toes it's about
how cats move in general cats uh you
know obviously don't move the same way
as humans but having that contact on the
objects that they're on uh is a really
crucial thing too it's not just the you
know missing fingers and toes it's an
integral part of their senses I don't
know maybe you could say it's an
additional sense I'm not that kind of an
expert to say that but I certainly am
glad that we made the decision we
did and um you know I get that this
committee has a culture and developed uh
you know just like other committees that
I've served on to look at the bills that
come before you and I know that you've
had bills about ear docking of dogs tail
docking uh I had a pug who his Duke claw
were gone before I adopted him I didn't
know that would be a decision that was
made and I didn't know anything about
that at that time anyway but um I don't
know that the decisions around other
animals necessarily impacts this one um
I can't tell you how to think or feel
about that I get that you have developed
your own um way of looking at these
issues but I would encourage you to
consider the fact that uh over
overwhelmingly the vets in America won't
do this but there are vets who do and
like representative cam Kenny said and
all the facts that he presented I think
they're compelling um you know
apparently we're one of the few
countries that even uh has this as a
practice and I would suggest that uh
decla cats is is a is a fear-based
vanity
decision uh that unknowingly people do
because maybe it was a norm to their
introduction of cats but because not
everyone has uh learned what I've
learned not everybody researches that
much I do think that understanding the
cruelty to animals as it is that decline
cats uh uh is worthy of inclusion in
that um how we as a State look at cats
and decisions about cruelty to cats I
think it's an integral thing and I will
add and I don't think he's here our
friend representative abis is a
supporter of this uh hopefully he will
be emailing you you know he's a cat
person too and um we talk about our cats
often so I don't know if that's
persuasive to any Republicans but um it
is a bipartisan issue so I hope that's
helpful and I'm happy to take any
questions any questions for
representative
Schultz seeing none we thank you for oh
I'm sorry I missed you looked right over
you all right representative Duty uh
representative Schultz do you think if
we pass this bill that this would give
the veterinarians another tool in which
to um basically use with clients or
customers you know who want to have uh
declin for a cosmetic reason um um
because my assumption would be that
they're put in a difficult position
between what they feel is the best for
the animal and uh having being pressured
by a customer I what's your opinion well
absolutely and our new vet actually
we've talked about it my state WRA and
this bill came up uh Veterinary Schools
often now aren't even teaching this as a
practice except as any other emergency
procedure they might have to perform
on any animal's bones or limbs or skin
um as far as I know uh well I don't know
the statistics of how many veterinary
schools aren't teaching it as a practice
but it certainly is becoming a norm but
the pressures from unknowing families
that want a cat I think it would be very
helpful to that decision for the state
to have this as a part of our animal
cruelty
laws
representative
comto thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
if
we Outlaw declaring do you think that
these uh owners who want to declaw their
cats would find other means that are
actually more unsafe and unhealthy I
hope not obviously that's a hypothetical
so I can't speak to that I certainly
think I do know a family in my district
that had made that decision and we've
talked about it I would hope
that anyone who has a pet has a a vet
that they can speak to I would
hope uh that that would be considered
any other thing than the law where
someone takes something into their own
hands I mean I don't know I mean that's
a hypothetical that I hope wouldn't
happen but geez people make some weird
decisions sometimes I would hope not and
I would consider it cruelty if they
did any further
questions thank thank you representative
we appreciate your testimony thank you
so
much next we're going to have uh Richard
headed from the judicial
branch good afternoon welcome to Ena
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard
headed I'm the government Affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch um
as you might expect we do not have a
policy position on this bill um I did
submit written testimony through the
very helpful uh electronic system my
request is an amendment on this bill um
the bill includes a criminal penalty and
there is a statute that deals with the
effective data bills that impact the
judicial branch uh create new criminal
or civil penalties and this would fall
within RSA 14 col and N um and as I put
in the written testimony each law
affecting judicial practice and
procedure or establishing or eliminating
criminal prohibitions civil causes of
action or remedies or eliminates uh or
uh or limitations of actions shall take
effect January 1 of the following year
and the reason for that is is fairly
straightforward um every year
legislation amends a wide range of
statutes and include criminal Provisions
civil Provisions change policies and
procedures within the judicial branch
with when it comes to a criminal penalty
as this statute would create um there's
something called J1 which is which is
essentially the uniform charge table
used by law enforcement officers to
ensure that we have a very uniform
system of charging individuals that
takes a little while to get updated
Department of Safety Department of
Justice work on that within the judicial
branch we have a system called Odyssey
so every line of code in in the J1 and
in our Odyssey database have to match up
with the statutory Provisions where
there's a criminal penalty there are
lots of them and every time there's even
the slightest tweak in one of those all
of those things have to to get adjusted
and and realigned to whatever the new
Criminal penalty is you know if it's a
drug it may be the amount of the drug it
takes a long time to get all those
things lined up to train law enforcement
to train the judges so there's a statute
that says if you're doing any of those
things it should be a January 1
effective date so my simple request is
is that the um the effective dat of the
bill be changed to January 1
2023 and with that I'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you uh representative Aaron yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you so much
for taking my question and for giving
testimony this afternoon my question is
if this bill were to be
passed how would somebody
be
um reported or I mean if this is between
a veterinarian who maybe doesn't know
the law or maybe doesn't care about
about the law and does it
anyway um who who might be somebody who
would report such an
action family members who don't get
along um uh there could be a wide range
of of people probably I can come up with
a 100
hypotheticals um but I'll start with
spouses that are
fighting okay uh follow up follow up so
and is there would there be some sort of
time limit where somebody would be able
to report a veterinarian for doing that
I mean um say somebody had their cat
declawed prior to this law going into
effect would they be able to report that
somebody's cat was
declawed in a you know previous time so
so generally if if uh if at the time the
ACT occurred it was not a crime it
wouldn't become a crime by passage of of
the statute there are statutes of
limitations for crimes actually don't
know what the clasp of misdemeanor of
Statute is I I'm guessing three years
but I don't I don't know off the top of
my head um so there are statutes and
limitations you can't go further back in
time um based on the statute of
limitations and if the Act was not a
crime at the time it wouldn't become a
crime by virtue of the passage of the
law thank
you so actually generates a question
from a previous question that I heard
rep Aon ask another W another person who
was testified
by your read of this who would be the
Violator because this is very vague in
the sense of any person and knowing the
definition of person and statute it's
it's pretty wide open could be a
business it could be the individual
themselves there's there's multiple
definitions of what person is in statute
how how would the judicial branch
interpret this would would you have any
guidance for us in a way to for us to
understand um so the best thing about my
job is I'm not a judge uh I don't I
don't uh interpret them um I will talk
generally instead of the the statute so
as you said person is is uh typically a
very broad definition include
individuals or corporations um sometimes
you see um uh criminal penalties based
on whether or not the person is an
individual or or a Crim or a corporation
um this one does not it does not have
um any more specificity than a person so
I I would say potentially you know could
be the business or it could be uh the
individual veterinarian but the the uh
the tie is that the statute at least has
a a connection between person and the
removal of clause so there has to be a
direct connection between those two I
would assume um and so to whether it be
the individual veterinarian or the
corporation would be a charging decision
as the judicial branch we don't get
involved in the charging decisions we
only rece receive the the uh the charge
and then go from there understood thank
you any further
questions seeing none we appreciate you
coming in your testimony today thank you
for letting me
testify okay next we'll have uh Joyce
aravella from New
Boston
good afternoon welcome to the ENA
committee good afternoon thanks for
having me so um my name is Joyce
Arabella and I live in New
Boston I am a manun hobby breeder my cat
is registered with and I'm a member of
both cat fanciers Association and Cat
fanciers Federation I'm here
representing
myself I'm here to speak in opposition
of HB
1226 cats are generally clawed to
protect the owner's Furniture walls
themselves or their children from being
scratched they can unintentionally be
quite destructive and even harmful to
their owners although there are ways to
discourage this Behavior they do not
work with all cats the population of
cats and animal shelters is always very
high declaring prevents abandon
abandonment and
euthanasia declaring can also be done by
laser now this laser method is much less
painful
it minimizes the bleeding and seals the
nerve endings during surgery which means
less pain faster healing and fewer
complications in my opinion declaring
would be a last resort that is decided
between an owner and their
veterinarian however if it is
criminalized the owners feel as if they
will have no choice and then cats will
likely be abandoned Outdoors or
surrendered to already cat cat filled
shelters and rescues I spoke with my
veterinarians office and they're not
aware of any veterinarians in the state
that still do that
so if there are any it must be few and
far between now that's my opinion now
this is not to say they wouldn't
consider it if it you know meant the
health of the cat or giving up the cat
and the they had tried everything else I
think it should be a last
resort it seems to me that this isn't a
problem in New Hampshire and should be
left to the discretion of our vets and
their clients rather than put another
unnecessary law on the books just for
the sake of having it
there and I read I read a lot today to
put this together this is a very short
testimony but I wrote a thesis that
somebody did that showed that cats did
not bite
more in fact were in shelters longer
than cats that were not clawed so in
spite of what somebody previously said
they do not buy any more than cats with
claws and they in fact are in shelters
for longer before they're adopted than
cats that are not
declined and as for the health of people
cats often scratch unintentionally I
have scratches all over myself and or
they in fear you know somebody just
takes off and they happen to be standing
on your foot and they push off and you
got a scratch it happens it's an
accident they didn't do it on
purpose so these if if your cat has um
some germs on their claws that can cause
SC cat scratch fever and that's pretty
uncomfortable for
people so I ask that you recommend hb1
1226 in expedient to
legislate thank you will you take
questions yes any questions Miss
AR I actually do you did you say you
were a breeder of cats I am so were are
you aware
of this being a general practice of
decoring cats that amongst the breeder
Community absolutely
not so that doesn't mean that if it
meant saving somebody's pet and all else
was exhausted it's in my contract
if you have any inklings of declaring
please contact me so we can talk about
it we can try different solutions can do
whatever we need to do to prevent that
but as a last resort if you love your
cat and you don't want to give it up
which most people
do you know I'm not going to say no to
somebody that wants to have it done
because they're a cat they just can't
train it not not to
do what is normal so as a instinctual as
a breeder do you have conversations with
your veterinarian about declaring and it
and if it was necessary no okay no I
don't expect to declaw any of my cats
okay because I know a lot of tips tips
and tricks to stop them and I have a lot
of scratching posts around my house sure
so I don't have an issue with cats
scratching my furniture because I have a
squirt
gun thank you any other
questions seeing none we thank you to
for coming in today thank you for your
time okay next we have uh Christina
Snider from Chester New
Hampshire good afternoon and welcome to
Ena good afternoon uh yes I'm I'm here
in heavy support of this bill I did send
in um testimony online I'm not sure if
any of you got to see
it
I adopted a cat that was declawed in the
90s and I just want to verify
that the person that had that CAT
declaw that was the relationship they
had with that veterinarian and they
decided to do that and then she turned
around and said I don't want the
cat so the cat I adopted that cat and I
had that CAT for over 20 years and I
watched that cat suffer his whole life
okay because someone did that to him
someone mutilated him and then said I
don't want it and I remember her telling
me she says I actually like
dogs so it was my gift and my
blessing but I had to watch him suffer
his whole life
he couldn't climb he couldn't scratch he
couldn't be a
cat and I I remember when I had this
cat I remember thinking that if someone
offered me a million
dollars or a chance to give my cat his
fingers back I would have chosen to give
my cat his fingers back and that is 100%
the truth I can't believe we're even
discussing this bill
it is it is so cruel it is complete
mutilation of an animal just for the
sake of doing it you know we have a cat
now her name is Manu and she has an
extra toe you know what we do we clip
her claws we take her up and we hold her
and at first she didn't like it but now
she knows she gets a treat after it so
you can clip the claws too I'm going to
tell you back to my my wonderful
beautiful cat that I had towards the end
of his life he really suffered he had
trouble walking he had more pain I was
struggling with like what do I
do and I'll tell you this right at the
end the fur came off of his paws a
little bit so you could actually see it
and this is what it looked like that's
what looked like you could see it he was
missing his fingers be because she
decided a woman who want I'm sure once
she for got rid of the cat she never
thought about that cat
again and I it's it's just heartbreaking
for me and you
know to me it's it's it's such obvious
animal cruelty and if if you need to do
that to your cat or you think you do you
shouldn't have a cat there's plenty of
people people like me that will take
more and more cats so I'm just really
you know I'm
just I'm very surprised that that
there's even this much debate about this
I'm I'm telling you right now if you had
seen what I had seen and you love that
cat like the way I love the cat the way
you love your dog the way you love your
child why do we do these things what's
the quality decision the quality
decision is to not mutilate an animal
just because
so I'm asking you today to please
support this and let's end this heinous
egregious cool
practice that's it thank you will you
take
questions Miss Snider will you take
questions yes okay sure any questions
for Miss
Snider representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question you mentioned
clipping of um the
claws is that an effective way to um
remedy uh scratching damage and injury
to children or adults even um and how
long does that last before you have to
repeat
that yes it is it is
effective uh because we do it to our cat
and my parents did it to their cat and
it lasts usually a couple of weeks and
if you have trouble doing that
that's why you have friends that's why
you have relatives you can even bring it
to your vet and your vet will offer that
service and do it for you you can go
there and say you know a monthly cat uh
you know Nail clipping for your cat and
it is very effective because they still
have their fingers but they don't have
the sharpness so it's
just it's just like a blunt nothing but
they still can make it feel like they're
scratching so it's very effective it's
very simple and a cat can be trained to
actually appreciate it if you give them
a treat right after you do
it follow up follow up sure what's the
extent of that practice of claw clipping
um is it as much as 25% of the claw
declawing that we've heard about more or
less how prevalent is the practice of
clipping the claws instead of
declawing well I can only go by my
experience I know that I know that nail
clippers are sold in any store and I
know that I personally have done it my
family has done it and I know that my
friends have done it with their own cats
so just within my circles nobody has
declawed their cat and they all clip
their cat's
nails any further questions committee
members representative Shel you're not
on the committee currently because
you've testified but thank
you well right right now right now miss
Snider is testifying thank you any other
uh members of the committee with a
question all right we thank you for
testifying okay next up we have uh Kathy
Farley from Raymond New
Hampshire
CR thank you for taking me um actually
this was a remote uh thing that somebody
uh from the group uh sent in uh Nancy
Holmes was not able to be here and she
wanted to to speak originally but uh so
I I said okay I'll do it so I I'm here
and
basically um she's you know to speak in
opposition to House Bill 1226
and it's she says like a number of
people have said I believe there choices
in veterinarian care should remain
between the animal owner in the
veterinarian any veterinarian or owner
currently can particip uh in Partnership
choose to determine if the procedure in
is right or necessary for a particular
Pet's
well-being you know there are situations
where cat remains in its home de cling
is best option whether to protect the
owners health or to prevent cruelty to
the animal that is unable to conform to
its owner needs or wishes in terms of
how and where the claws are
used odds for rehoming a cat that is so
destructive or so willing to use its
claws on people that the person who
loves it wants it to you know wants to
give it up are poor a frequent recourse
is lying about the behavior and before
turning around and and giving it to the
rescue or whatever organizations out
there and you know it's it doesn't
because you're and you know I'll expound
on this I I've haven't had cats for a
long time but the cat I had was more
like a dog she followed me everywhere
when I was growing up
but you know a
person loves their animal you cannot
always change their you know their
behavior I don't care how nice or how
bad you know you know you can do you
know you can come down on an animal
figuring that's going to correct Its
Behavior and it's not and you can be
real good to it and it's like okay I've
I I'm ruling you now the cat is ruling
you saying okay I can get anything I
want by by using my
claws so I think it you know it still
boils down to the situation that Nancy
says that you know they want to keep
their animal they don't want to give it
up
they've tried everything else and if
that's the you know situation to to keep
this animal in their home instead of
trying to pass the behavior off to
somebody else I think it's worth you
know it's worth that it says in a in a
recent peer review American veterinarian
Medical Association article from July
23rd 2019 and apparently it was
submitted to the committee as remote
testimony entitled welfare implications
of decoring of dis domestic cats
this article in part states that PO uh
potential benefits to the cat cats are
the following in some cases decoring may
be an alternative to re re
relinquishment outdoor housing meaning
shipping the dog out the cat outside or
euthanasia for example in a 1991 survey
of Ontario veterinarians respondents
indicated that approximately 50% of
their clients would no longer own their
cat if if it had not been for
decoring following aggression is a
survey of veterinarians reported
scratching is the behavioral problem
most frequently associated with the
abandonment of cats in
Brazil unacceptable behaviors such as
daily scratching increase the risk of
Rel relinquishing of an animal to a
shelter and decoring decrease the risk
of Rel
relinquishing as approximately 72% of
cats relinquished two animal shelters
are euthanized owners may feel they are
faced with choice of decoring their pet
cat or potentially condemning it to
death there get her part here there is
no specific evidence found to support
that decoring leads to a higher rate of
behavior problems in cats when compared
to a control controlled group of cats
that have not been
declawed one study found declawed cats
were significantly un underrepresented
in a Washington shelter Pro uh
population when compared to estimates in
the population at large there was no
correlation between declawed status and
use the nasia at the
shelter in addition supporters of the
procedures asserted that a properly
performed declar is not no less Humane
than spaying or
neutering leaving a cat at a shelter may
not be an option at all given the cost
of surrender fees the long waiting list
and the fact that shelters have no
interest in handling an aggressive cat
for
rehoming do I believe there are people
possibly even right in the hearing who
think it is better to kill cats than
declaw them yes I do again this is
quotes from Nancy do I think that this
is the right choice for everyone no I do
not it is my belief that the studies
prove that elimin ating the option of
declaring is very likely to result in
more animal cruelty cases and higher
rates of
cats you see I'll say about putting them
down you know putting a dog a cat down
because it's you know they cannot get it
to claw I'm sorry I don't you know and I
don't like I said I don't have cats
anymore but if that was the final Choice
that's what I would do but I believe
leaving the decision up to the
veterinarians of New Hampshire and the
owners of the animals in question
Remains the best choice for onus and
cats please vote this bill inexpedient
to legislate and leave veterinarian
medicine to the veterinarians and
medical choices that let people keep
their pets a viable
option so that was Nancy Holmes thank
you will you take any questions I could
try but I'm not like I said I'm not fair
enough representative comto could you
pass up the written testimony when yeah
I know it see that was an easy question
yeah I can do that any other questions
got my highlights on it so just want to
point out all right seeing none we thank
you for coming in
today all right next up we're gonna have
uh Kurt aronberg from
hsus good afternoon and welcome to the
ENA good afternoon Mr chairman me
members of the committee I'm Kurt
aronberg I'm the uh state director for
the Humane Society of the United States
here in
support of House Bill
um uh so before I start my prepared
remarks I just want to make sure people
understand declawing procedure is not
pulling out the claw and it's not
cutting the claw it's cutting the
knuckle the
bone generates the claw you need to
remove the whole bone or the claw will
continue to keep growing back there'll
be a veterinarian testifying after me to
verify or correct me in any way because
I am not a veterinarian but it's
important to
remember it's it's kind of like if we
took 25% of the children in the
country and before they were school age
you take the tops of their fingers and
the top of their thumbs off of their
hands without any choice and they live
the rest of their life that way for
better or worse think of yourself in
that situation no choice wake up one day
oh well I liked my fingers the way they
were but now I have to live with them
and
adapt without those claws fingernails
tips of the fingers I don't know I like
to play the guitar I'm not a cat we're
human beings but the other thing I would
say that any veterinarian that speaks
about human conditions in terms terms of
resulting in scratches they're not human
doctors we shouldn't consider their
testimony as that um they're
veterinarians um with that I will start
and I'll try to be brief with my written
testimony I'll also submit it for the
committee sorry I couldn't get it to you
online
um uh the Humane Society the United
States is the nation's largest Animal
Protection Organization supports passage
of this bill which would in the practice
of non-therapeutic declawing or Den
knuckling of cats in the state declawing
has serious implications for feline
welfare and the bond between people and
their cats if Pass New Hampshire would
joined a rapidly growing number of
communities taking a stand against this
inhumane
practice convenience declawing of cats
is now and already illegal in New York
state and in numerous counties cities
and towns across the country it's banned
by the City and County of Denver
Colorado the city and county of St leis
Missouri in eight cities in California
most recently declaw bans have been
passed in Austin Texas Pittsburg
Pennsylvania and Madison Wisconsin all
by unanimous vote eight out of 10
Canadian provinces eight out of 10
Canadian provinces prohibit
nontherapeutic
Decline and that what we're talking
about here is non- therapeutic
decline the the owner chooses to do this
so when you say you know we're going to
Mu mutilate our our cat so we can love
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
um the veterinary Community is
increasingly opposed to decline the
American Association of feline
practitioners opposes it the American
Animal Hospital Association opposes it
the Canadian Veterinary Medical
Association and the Humane Society
Veterinary Medical Association are
opposed to it the major Veterinary
Hospital change VCA Banfield and blue
pearl the three major Veterinary
Hospital chains in the United States do
not offer elective declaw procedures on
C
many US Veterinary Schools no longer
routinely teach declaw
procedures however we cannot continue to
wait for the veterinary profession to
end declawing in this country on its
own these amputations are still too
commonly practiced and cat owners are
often not made aware of the high risk of
permanent adverse effects on C paths or
of the procedures
controversies and that you know even
today is the responsibility of the
veterinarian really to explain this uh
to their
clients that many veterinarians will not
refuse to amputate a cat's toes which is
what we're talking about unless there is
a valid medical needs and by the way
we're talking about just cats just
cats just cats
cats arguments in favor of declawing
often center around the desire to
prevent unwanted scratching of either
furniture or
people well amputation is an extreme
response to what can be addressed we
heard with a squirt gun with regular
nail trimming as we heard a variety of
scratching posts and better
understanding of feline Behavior better
understanding of feline Behavior how
about that moreover declawed cats are at
a greater risk of developing more
serious adverse
behaviors not withstanding what any kind
of anecdotal doal information you've
heard here
today adverse behaviors after amputation
such as litterbox adversion or an
increase in biting and
aggression now in
pain
and no longer able to defend themselves
with their claws cats May resort to
biting the documented increased biting
behavior of declawed cats can lead to
more severe disease in people than cat
scratches ask a human doctor about that
not a vet or not somebody you talk to a
vet but cat bites are
serious scratches are another
issue um
so there is a false narrative here that
cat owners unable to get their cats
declawed are likely to relinquish their
cats to animal shelters or abandon that
cat Outdoors the risk of a cat ending up
homeless or Worse euthanized due to
declaw prohibition is grossly
overestimated a recent study of data
from British Columbia shelters covering
the three years prior to and three years
after a provincewide declaw ban went
into effect showed that there was no
increase in cats being relinquished or
euthanized the number of owner
surrendered cats actually decreased
after the ban publicly available data
from Los Angeles California also show no
increase in cat intake at shelters
Citywide once declawing was prohibited
so the reality is that due to the higher
prevalence of long-term adverse impacts
of multiple amputations decline puts
cats at a greater risk of eviction from
their home homes and relin
relinquishment to shelters and rescue
organizations and according to a study
published in the Journal of American
Veterinary Medical Association among
relinquished cats
52% of declawed cats were reported to
exhibit litterbox avoidance compared to
29% of non declawed
cats now declawing is not good for cats
or people and it's time to end that
practice in the state of New Hampshire
thanks for your
time thank you for your testimony any
questions from Mr Arenberg
representative
Bixby it's getting late and get to get a
little spy so um our uh you had a list
of states and uh that had uh have banned
it I was wondering if Maine Vermont
Massachusetts uh the New England states
if is are there bands in any New England
State in terms of a Statewide ban New
York state is currently the only state
okay but there are so numerous other
communities counties towns cities that
that have bed follow up uh do you happen
to know what the rate of uh decline
currently is in New Hampshire roughly
somewhere between 20
25% okay thank you
declawing representative Murray thank
you Mr chair for taking my question and
thank you for taking my question I'm
curious if you could tell me um how many
I mean obviously you mentioned New York
state but how many other counties and
states are using the penal system
through misdemeanor charges versus
license revocation or suspension as the
method of enforcement
I don't have an an answer for you but
I'll try to get one for you and email it
to you or we can talk thank you I'm
happy to talk to anyone and about any of
this anytime representative Aon thank
you Mr shair and thank you for taking my
question so I'm interested to know you
just said that you uh the
25% of uh cats are declawed in New
Hampshire where did you get that figure
from I I I will stand by the figure
somewhere between 20 and 25 I can't give
you a citation unfortunately right now
because I can't remember exactly where
I've heard that I'll stand by it as
something I believe is true I also stand
ready to be corrected that is a number
that I believe is
correct and there um there maybe someone
here who can verify that
I'll get it to you by the way is that
based on observation of you or I mean
it's based on it's based on a statistic
that I believe is correct that I can't
cite the source to you right now I'm
apologize for that okay thank
you representative
comto thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and this is along
the lines of what representative just
just asked um we keep batting around the
number 20
25% but in terms of actual numbers do we
actually have a figure of the number of
cats that are actually being declawed in
New Hampshire because percentages mean
nothing when we don't know what the
actual number is uh and there must be
some database somewhere where we can get
those figures
correct I don't know the answer to
that he any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you next we have Karen Campell Campbell
excuse me from
Epsom good afternoon and welcome to the
ENA thank you thank you committee good
to see you all um I'm Karen Campbell I'm
a veterinarian in the state of New
Hampshire and I'm a specialist in
Internal Medicine and um I'm a member of
the Humane Society
VMA and my husband is a veterinarian as
well we were just uh reminiscing
recently over when we learned the
procedure of doing declaw on cats this
was over 20 25 years ago um in my
situation I was on a rotation where we
learned to do spays and neuters and
dentistry and decoy claw and we were
taught by one instructor for three out
of four of those things she didn't teach
us the dclaw and the rumor that we heard
through all of our classmates was it was
because she didn't believe in it that
she didn't think it was ethical and so
she did not teach us that part of the
class when I learned to do the procedure
I thought o this is brutal um and I also
thought it seems very difficult um it's
actually technically
very challenging to do and in my catch
that I did the procedure on I had very
serious concerns that I didn't know if I
had done it well and that I didn't know
if they would do well long term because
a lot of times you don't know that you
haven't done it well for weeks or months
down the road um we were taught though
that it was a core part of the
curriculum and that it was helpful for
the cat population in general because
there were a certain percent of kitties
that would um scratch furniture scratch
their owners that kind of thing and they
wouldn't make suitable pets for the
household so I thought in the interest
of the greater good you know I will
learn to do this procedure if it helps
cats stay in their home my husband he
and two of his classmates that he's very
good friends with they actually went to
a shelter and adopted three cats and in
their curriculum the way it was set up
they were able then to spay a new those
cats when they were learning how to do
the surgeries and they were able to
declaw them as well and not only did
they declaw these three cats front feet
they declawed the back feet too because
they thought I'm trying to learn how to
do this procedure I want to be a really
good veterinarian this is core something
I need to know how to do so those were
going to be indoor cats that they were
keeping and so they decco all four of
their feet now fast forward 20 years
later my husband is a a uh Veterinary
Hospital owner in the state of New
Hampshire and since he's the owner he
gets to decide what is and what is not
done at his practice and they don't
allow the declaw they don't do the
procedure because he thinks that it's
unethical so our personal feelings have
changed about the procedure and that's
because over the 2025 years we've gotten
more data about what happens to these
kites long term and we're no longer in
favor of it um the procedure hasn't
changed it's still brutal it still is an
actual amputation of all 10 of the cat's
digits um and I'm sort of you know
demonstrating with my own hands it's a
little bit worse even in a cat because
their hands so to speak you know they
walk on so then they're walking on top
of 10 amputated digits and so that can
be painful and it turns out it is hard
to do
correctly um most of the papers that I
have seen there's about a 25 to 30% rate
of complications which is a pretty high
complication rate in an animal where
their limbs were perfectly healthy to
begin with there's nothing wrong with
them and it's completely elective
surgery it's not for the benefit of the
cat at all um it's hard to do because
you would kind of expect that these
bones are straight in the end and you
just cut in between them but that's not
the case they're they're a curved end
and they are curved to fit each other
and so when you're trying to do the
procedure you're having this little
blade trying to go into this very tiny
space that's curved and make your way
around all of these little curves and
not damage the bone that you're trying
to leave behind make sure you do remove
all the bone that you're trying to
remove cut the tendons that are
appropriate not cut the other tendons
that aren't appropri roate you end up
cutting nerves and sometimes you have
permanent nerve damage from that and
it's difficult to do and that's why
there's such a high complication rate
you can
have cut the bone that you didn't want
to the bone that you did want to
completely remove you can leave a little
fragment behind and then when you do
that little fragment will sit underneath
this other bone so it's like you're
walking on a pubble all the time there's
a pretty high rate of infections
abscesses draining tracts so they get
infected a lot um if this tendon on the
bottom is left intact but the one on top
is not the digit that remains it will
pull it underneath and so the the cat
ends up walking sort of like this on top
of a bent toe and then it will cause the
pad that's underneath the foot to
retract back and so now they're not even
walking on their pad they're just
walking on skin instead of the pad
itself um you all should know probably
anytime anybody suffers any kind of an
injury and you're painful somewhere
you're going to offload your weight and
and shift it some other part of your
body and Studies have shown that that
happens with the cats and that they uh
then develop higher rates of arthritis
in other parts of their body after
they've been declawed and they have
higher rates of back
pain um behaviorally it's not good for
them as well they have scent glands on
the bottom of their feet that they mark
their territory with and if their feet
are not comfortable and they don't feel
like marking anymore with their scent
glands unfortunately for homeowners they
can Mark people's houses with their
urine they uh normally like to stretch
and then when they stretch they stretch
their claws they like to scratch their
claws to keep them nice and sharp and
they use their claws for defense and so
when they don't have these behaviors
that they can exhibit anymore a lot of
the kitties become irritable and they
are more likely to bite um more Studies
have shown that decla cats are more
likely to bite than cats that are not
declaw and then lastly it is also true
that more cats who've been declawed
don't use the litter pan because their
feet hurt they may be comfortable enough
to walk around on carpet and uh beds and
couches and things like that but when
they get on that sharp irregular Rocky
kind of litter they don't like it and so
they'll urinate outside the
pan so an important
question
until probably within the past five
years or so has
been but can they be acceptable pets you
know what is the overall good for cats
and cat owners if we don't allow
decline um how many cats are going to be
relinquished back to shelters and I say
the past five years or so because the um
the state of New York and the cities
that have been referenced and the
provinces in Canada that have been
referenced that have banned declawing
have largely done it within the past
five years or so and that's allowed for
the studies to be done to see what are
the relinquishment rates in those areas
after those declaw banss have gone into
effect and uh not every single area has
been studied but all of the studies that
I have seen have shown the
relinquishment rate does not go up and
in some cases it actually goes down and
that makes sense because if you have
declawed cats biting more and soiling
the house more they're more likely to be
turned back into the
shelter so because of all this
additional information that has been
obtained over the past 20 years you know
I don't have the same attitude I did
before well for the greater good I'm I'm
in favor of this procedure now I support
Banning the decline
I think it's better for the cats
physically it's better for them mentally
it seems to be better for pet owners in
statistically they keep their cats
longer and then it would be better for
municipalities as well because they
don't have to deal with as many cats
being turned into shelters and trying to
rehome them take care of them while
they're in the shelter or pay for Ethan
Asia so those are my current thoughts
I'm happy to entertain any questions all
right thank you
excuse me uh representative Bixby yes
thank you for taking my question um so
uh I'm I'm curious about how common The
Practice still is because I we we we get
this rate of 20 to 25% C of cats being
declawed but I'm not sure if that means
that 25 that that percentage of new cats
are newly owned cats are being declawed
or whether that is a residual from when
it was a more common practice and cats
live 15 years or so uh so do how how
common is that practice in New Hampshire
right now yeah the the problem for you
guys is there's a scarcity of this data
um the number 20 to 25% that is thrown
around is from some fairly recent
studies within the past five years or so
but they're National studies or their
studies in other states I don't know of
any data in the state of New Hampshire
honestly I know that the New Hampshire
VMA because I'm a member of them sent
out a
survey a month or so ago prior to this
hearing asking veterinarians four or
five simple questions about declawing
you know do we do them how often do we
do them how do we feel about them you
know that kind of thing so I know that
they have gathered that data I don't
know what the results were they haven't
published them and I do know that about
40% of veterinarians in the state are
members of the New Hampshire VMA so even
whatever data they've gotten it's only
from 40% or less of the
veterinarians so I honestly feel like
nobody really knows the answer to that
question thank
you representative Aaron thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
this afternoon and thank you for taking
my question
so is there any do do veterinarians
report to any
body um the types of uh procedures that
they do no no okay thank
you any further
questions see none we'll thank you for
your testimony thank
you
okay next is uh Michelle francen Conroy
from
conquer hello everyone good afternoon
welcome to Thea thank you for allowing
me to testify um again my name is
Michelle fransen Conroy I live in
Conquer New Hampshire um I am here
representing myself but I will let you
know that I'm on the board of the New
Hampshire animal rights League
and I um went to UNH Thompson school
back in the 80s I have an associates
degree in uh animal science specializing
in Small Animal Care and I have worked
at numerous animal shelters and animal
hospitals and I'm just here to give you
a Viewpoint a firsthand account of um
what happens to some cats after right
after the surgery I won't mention the
name of the animal hospital I worked at
but it's local in Conquer New Hampshire
and this was was back in the early '90s
um I was in surgery assisting with some
of the veterinarians for the procedures
and taking care of the um cats
afterwards and was out back you know
cleaning cages and things so I would see
the cats as they're coming out of the
anesthesia and it was just horrible to
watch when the anesthesia was wearing
off they had bandages on them all the
way you know the whole length of their
arm and they would just be howling in
pain and like flailing around in the
cages and a lot of them would manage to
get the bandages off and there would be
blood all over the inside of the cage
they would have to take the cat
rebandage it a lot of times it would
happen again same thing same cat would
end up getting the bandages off just
trying to rid themselves of that and
just dealing in with the agony of having
that procedure done to them I personally
don't have a declawed cat I've adopted
many cats rescued cats none of them have
been de been de clawed so I don't have
experience with them after that all of
my cats I just clip their nails if you
start when they're little I hold my cat
upside down like a baby and just poke
the nail out and just take the tip of it
off and you just get them used to doing
that on a normal thing and their treat
that I give them is catnip which they
absolutely love and they only get catnip
after I do their nails so um that's
their incentive and for them to allow me
to cut their nails um so it's very easy
to manage that way but um I just I
hadn't heard anybody speak about what
happens and have anybody show you um or
explain to you the after effects right
after their surgery but it was just
horrible to watch and I think it was a
big money maker I don't know if this
Animal Hospital still declaw because
like I said this was back in the 90s but
there was a lot of cats and I think you
know that was a good part of the
business MoneyWise was performing this
procedure but it was just hor horrible
to watch those cats go through that um
coming out of the anesthesia with with
the blood everywhere and I I'll never
forget it so I just wanted to share that
testimony I don't know if anybody has
any questions or Mr
sh sorry about that uh any
questions representative Aaron thank you
Mr chair thank you for coming and giving
testimony this
afternoon um I'm interested to know what
you feel about the
um uh the penalty for declawing in this
bill that um calls for Class B
misdemeanor I can't really speak to that
I I didn't really take a look at that
part of the language I I did email my
testimony also um I didn't know that
that was actually part of it until I got
here and read that so um I really can't
speak to the that part of it thank you
I'm sorry any further questions
seeing none thank you for your
testimony next up we have uh Angela
Ferrari from dog owners of the Granite
estate welcome back again thank you
all so as mentioned previously I'm here
on behalf of dog owners of the Granite
State but we do have a large number of
cat owners and breeders as part of our
membership um we oppose hb22 six and for
many reasons most of them revolve around
the fact that this is something that
should be determined between a
veterinarian and an owner um even going
back and looking at some documentation
from the avma while they discourage
decline they also respect the
veterinarian's right to use professional
judgment when deciding how to best
protect their individual patients Health
and
Welfare we agree uh with them and always
recommend working with an animal to curb
bad behaviors before turning to a
medical procedure however when
everything else fails and a veterinarian
determines that decline is the only
remaining solution that choice should
remain between the veterinarian and the
pet
owner somebody had mentioned earlier
that veterinarians aren't held to any
standards as far as what they are
allowed and supposed to do um with the
animals that they treat and I just
wanted to read a section of the
veterinarians oath from the avma
website it says that being admitted to
the profession of veterinary medicine I
solemnly swear to use my scientific
knowledge and skills for the benefit of
society through the protection of Animal
Health and Welfare the prevention and
relief of animal suffering the
conservation of animal resources the
promotion of Public Health and the
advancement of medical knowledge there's
a little bit more to it but that was the
one that I felt really hit home um um
with this bill and the ability to have a
veterinarian maintain that oath and
treat animals as they see fit with the
uh information coming from the
owners um one of our members actually
called Eight veterinarian offices this
week and half of them said that they do
not offer the procedure so we don't feel
that this is very popular uh in New
Hampshire here those that will do it say
that they try to discourage the
procedure and offer Alternatives and a
couple of the veterinarian offices who
have performed the procedure related to
our member that it was done to support
the health of the owner who was on blood
thinners um so that they wouldn't have
to relinquish the animal or have to give
it up to a shelter in order to keep
their health safe um and as we just
heard um from Miss Campbell I believe
her name was that vets can choose to not
do the surgery as her practice has done
so so I do think that it's something
that the veterinarian field can make
decisions about in our state rather than
being forced down on them from
government um on a side note I did have
a cat that was declawed when I was
growing up and he was a wonderful cat he
could still climb trees he was a pretty
avid chipmunk Hunter um and would always
try and bring little mice into the house
that he would catch and temperamentally
physically everything he was very
healthy and a great cat we didn't have
any adverse effects from it um so while
I think with any procedure or surgery
there are going to be situations where
things don't go as well as planned there
are times and probably more often than
not with decline that it is truly to the
benefit of the animal and their owners
um if you look at spay and neuter that's
something that we do that is extremely
invasive we do it for convenience um it
creates a lot of issues it can increase
cancers it can create
incontinance um you can have
temperamental problems if it is done too
early as the males age and different
things like that but that isn't
something that you're going to see the
others coming in here and asking you to
prevent veterinarians from being able to
do so I think it's important uh that we
let the veterinarians continue to
educate their clients about decline and
not make anyone a criminal when they
feel it's best to perform the procedure
I would be happy to take any
questions thank you any questions from
Miss farar yes representative uh thank
you for taking my question again I would
ask how many dogs have you seen that
have been declawed dogs dogs um I am not
aware of anybody that actually declaws
dogs the only time I've ever heard of it
and it's not based on any stat statistic
but it was usually like drug dealers or
something that didn't want the police to
hear the dogs running down the Halls can
I follow follow up why do you think that
is because dogs destroy furniture and
they also scratch people so why are cats
subjected to this but not
dogs this would just be based on my own
thoughts but um dogs tend to be more
destructive with their mouths chewing on
things than they're going to be with
line um their claws are or their nails
are much more dense and not as sharp if
you look at a cat's nail and comparison
to a dog's nail it is like a hook um so
if you don't keep those Nails on the cat
trimmed back very short um they're
extremely sharp even just touching you
sometimes they can cut right into you
dog nails they're much thicker more
dense um and generally not going to be
sharp and be as
destructive
any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony I'll turn in my testimony I
have for you as well
okay next up is Joan O'Brien from
Amherst all right thank you she's waving
off thank you so our final speaker is uh
Dr Jane Barlo from the New Hampshire
Veterinary Medical asso
assciation good afternoon and welcome to
the
ENA thank you for letting me speak today
and I appreciate you all hanging in
there with me um to kind of wrap things
up um as introduced my name is Dr Jane
Barlo Roy I am a representative from the
New Hampshire Veterinary Medical
Association um I also to disclose I am a
member um and delegate to the house of
delegates to the American Veterinary
Medical Association the
avma I do have a letter that was drafted
um to the committee from the avma as
well and I'll make sure that that gets
to you chair um in opposition to this
bill as
well as I said um I represent the New
Hampshire Veterinary Medical Association
and we are opposed to this
legislation for all the reasons that
other people have already mentioned that
we're opposed to it um our main goal is
to maintain the veterinary patient
client relationship the vprc and we feel
that that is our best asset and our best
tool to perform um to our best of our
abilities we do not feel that this
should be a
legislated event it should not be
medical procedures in the veterinary
Community should not be a legislated
thing
but let me be abundantly clear we do not
promote declaw we follow the tenants and
the position statement of the avma which
discourages decline we also follow the
American animal he Hospital
association's position statement aafp
American Association of Veterinary uh
feline practitioners um and I do have
copies of those uh position statements
if you would um so choose to have those
and again those position statements they
do not promote declaw they give other
options for the management of Claws and
the destructiveness in them but nowhere
in any of those position statements do
they promote Banning in legislative
form and to also what was brought up um
we also are seeing a phasing out um of
declawing in the veterinary profession I
am a current practicing uh veterinarian
here in in the conquered area um I've
been practicing since
2006 and it is true that when I first
graduated and first practiced in the
early 2000s you know we did you know a
tremendous amount of of declaw but in my
16 years um we have seen quite a drop
off in the number of declaws that we
have done um to that end um like I said
I've been practicing since
2006 I think the last time I
did a declaw procedure was about seven
to eight years ago or even more I kind
of just lost track um we do promote
the education client education with our
clients um we make sure that they
understand what the procedure actually
involves and we do go into detail of
about exactly what we're doing so nobody
is under the misguidance of not knowing
what the true declaw procedure is um you
know we don't we don't try to kind of
pull the wow of anybody's
eyes and because I haven't done this
procedure in about 7 to 10 years I have
a pat on my own back um 100% rate of
convincing owners not to do declaw um
but if the situation should arise that I
need to do a declaw procedure I don't
want the threat of a criminal penalty
behind my back um and if I could tell a
small story this morning I did
surgery representative erens you said
about a tumor on a toe my initial plan
going in doing the surgery this morning
was to remove the tumor and the tumor
only however plans changed I needed to
amputate a claw if this claw ended up
becoming something that was involving
more than just the other toe if I
thought that it was also potentially
involving other toes on the claw or on
the
foot if this was a criminal penalty I
would have to think long and hard about
removing other toes um in the the middle
of my procedure um would I have even
taken that claw off at that point um I
made a game d decision to remove the
entire claw but I don't want the idea of
a medical procedure a very ubiquitous
nebulous term medical reason hanging
over me making my decisions in the
middle of surgery while I have a patient
under
anesthesia I also don't want the threat
of a criminal penalty when I'm making
these decisions with another client if
they're coming to me they're asking my
opinion on things and in this bill with
a medical exemption medical reason
there's no definition in this bill so
there is no way for me to know at the
time if I'm making a true medical
decision for this
cat I want to make sure I get all of
your an questions answered
um I know that the uh
survey was brought up by one of our
other other veterinarians here and we
did do a survey as the New Hampshire VMA
we wanted to know what the answers were
um unfortunately we do not have the um
Financial capabilities of doing any sort
of data processing so I can only speak
to what the survey said to us and our
survey did um kind of resoundingly say
that veterinarians
are opposed and do not promote decline
um but they do not appreciate being
legislated about it um I can get you
that information you know so you choose
um but it is in a very lengthy document
because like I said we don't have data
processing so I don't have actual
percentages for you
um I can also speak on the number of
cats being declawed here in the state
nor the number of cats that are already
declawed U but I can say 25% in my
practice ice is a gross exaggeration
that would mean one out of every four
cats coming into my practice was declaw
and I can honestly tell you I don't
remember the last time I saw a declaw
cat coming into my office um it actually
takes me by surprise sometimes when I do
go to clip the nails on a front foot and
there are no claws to be clipped so um
it's not something that here in New
Hampshire we are seeing a lot of um but
again we don't have any data uh so I
can't give you hard and true facts but I
can tell you that in my practice ractice
here in conquered um one of the busiest
practices here in conquered um we do not
see that level of decla cats and like I
said we also have not P per performed
the procedure in almost a decade um and
I did want to clarify um with some of
the assumptions that have been brought
up about how these are painful
procedures I want to make sure everybody
realizes that we're not doing this
procedure on an awake animal the cat is
not
awake we use general
anesthesia we use a plethora of
different pre-anesthetic medications we
use medications during the
procedure and we use medications
afterwards and I think anybody can agree
with me that has had a surgical
procedure that surgery is not pain free
our goal in surgery is to make
it as less of a pain as possible and we
do that right now with all of our surg
surgical procedures
um and we make it a point of Pride that
we are keeping up with all of the
different medications that are arising
for our cat patients um so I just wanted
to make that abundantly clear that this
is not done on an awake animal
um me make sure that I'm answering all
of the questions that kind of came up as
well
uh I think that's all that I had um so
we also want to just bring out you know
the the point of we are willing to work
with any organization um as the
veterinary medical profession um that
works with bills that are directly uh
affecting us um so we we're open to um
helping craft legislation that that
revolves us
directly thank you all right will you
take some questions of course
representative Aaron thank you Mr chair
and thank you so much for your testimony
this afternoon and thank you for taking
my question I'm interested to know for
the cats in your practice
that have been
declawed can you speak to their General
Health are they having problems because
of it are they brought to you because
there's
problems uh stemming from their declaw
or just other
issues there was a recent research paper
out that studied specifically arthritis
and cats and by a certain age I believe
it was five years old 65% of all cats
five years and older have arthritis
whether
we whether we see it or
not and so I can't speak directly to the
declaw cats because again there's not
many decla cats in my practice um but I
would say that arthritis is a big issue
in cats and I'm not quite sure how to
link up arthritis that are directly
related to a declawed cat versus an UND
declawed cat because the abundance of
cats that have arthritis as a general
statement okay thank you
any further
questions seeing none thank you for
coming in I appreciate your testimony
thank you very much that's the last card
that I have is there anyone else that
wishes to speak on this
bill seeing none I'm going to read the
results from the blue sheet we have uh
four people signed in three in favor one
against online we had 93 Pro 23 con and
one
neutral and with that I am going to to
close the hearing on HB
1226 question Mr Question um is this an
early
bill this I believe yes it is an early
bill so for the committee we were
intending to exec more bills but
obviously it's getting pretty late in
the day so doing that uh today I don't
think is going to be fair to the
committee I'm going to schedule a full
committee work session next Tuesday and
we'll be working on House Bill
1454 and we'll be doing a exec session
after that I I may
add I may add another bill or two to
that but we will have a full committee
work session so plan on that and then
we'll have an exec session as well but
we we'll definitely be working on 1454
and I'll U I'll work with rep Bixby and
see if there's others maybe that we need
to add to that I have until noon
tomorrow to commit to a calendar so
other than that any other questions from
the committee before I adjourn us for
today yeah both both bills we exact are
on the consent
calendar Mr chair yes rep St could you
give me the repeat on the blue sheet and
then the online I missed that sure the
blue sheet was uh 3 Pro one con and
online it was 93 Pro 23 con one
neutral thank you you're welcome
anything else before I let you go for
the
day all right see nothing now we will
adjourn for today and you all have a
safe trip home thank you for coming
in thank you Mr chair I enjoyed
it